welcome back to the devops week by
simply run as announced we are here with
Dockers and kubernetes Docker is an
important open source platform for
building deploying and managing
containerized applications Dockers
simplify the delivery of distributed
applications and have become
increasingly popular similarly
kubernetes provides an easier way to
scale up your application compared to
Virtual machines it keeps code
operational and speeds up the delivery
process kubernetes API allows automating
a lot of resource management and
provisioning tasks and much more we will
begin this full course video with what
Docker is then we will look into the
services and components of Docker in
detail next we will see what Docker
container is and what are the basic
commands of a Docker container then we
will focus on Docker swarm and Docker
compose after that we will discuss
everything about docker networking then
we will see how to install Docker on
Ubuntu and Windows 10. next we will talk
about 12 crucial Docker interview
questions and answers for beginners and
experienced candidates finally we will
conclude this video by discussing the
differences between the two famous tools
which are Docker and kubernetes
by the end of this video I can assure
you that all your Docker career related
queries will have been answered let's
dive deep and learn about these
important tools of devops so without
further Ado let's get started hello this
is Matthew from Simply learn and today
we're going to cover what is Docker and
why it should be of value to you as
somebody who works in devops so let's
say take a slow scenario of a
developerating a tester before you had
the world of Docker a developer would
actually build their code and then they
send it to the tester but then the code
wouldn't work on their system encoders
will work on the other system due to the
differences in computer environments so
what could be the solution to this well
you could go ahead and create a virtual
machine to be the same of the solution
in both areas we think Docker is an even
better solution so let's kind of break
out what the main big differences are
between Docker and virtual machines as
you can see between the left and the
right hand side both look to be very
similar what you'll see however is that
on the docker side what you'll see as a
big difference is that the guest OS for
each container has been illuminated
Docker is inherently more lightweight
but provides the same functionality as a
virtual machine so let's step through
some of the pros and cons of the Virtual
Machine versus Docker so first of all a
virtual machine occupies a lot more
memory space on the host machine in
contrast Docker occupies significantly
less memory space the boot up time
between both is very different Docker
just boots up faster the performance of
the docker environment is actually
better and more consistent than the
virtual machine Docker is also very easy
to set up and very easy to scale the
efficiencies therefore are much higher
with a Docker environment versus a
virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to Port Docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between Docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest OS your eliminating a
significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after Docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester and as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where Docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what Docker actually is and how Docker
works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
Solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the Venn diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the dev devops
Team sets if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate a monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key and elements then you can have
the efficiencies of an excellent devops
team so planning and code base we use
tools like jit and gearer for building
we use Gradle and Maven testing we use
selenium the integration between Dev and
Ops is through tools such as Jenkins and
then the deployment operation is done
with tools such as Docker and Chef
finally nagias is used to monitor the
entire environment so let's step deeper
into what Docker actually is so Docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments now it's important to note
that the container is actually a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
application so multiple containers can
run on the same Hardware the containers
are maintained in isolated environments
they're highly productive and they're
quick and easy to configure so let's
take an example of what Docker is by
using a house that may be rented for
someone using Airbnb so in the house
there are three rooms and only one
cupboard and kitchen and the problem we
have is that none of the guests are
really ready to share the cupboard and
kitchen because every individual has a
different preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used this is
very similar to how we run software
applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different Frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails perfect and
flask and you may want to have them
running for different applications for
different situations this is where
Docker will help you run the
applications with the suitable
Frameworks so let's go back to our
Airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers Docker provides
the suitable Frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that are long and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder Docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how Docker
actually works so when we look at Docker
and we call something Docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your Docker
environment and if we look at the image
on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see that Docker has a client
server relationship there's a client
installed on the hardware there is a
client that contains the docker product
and then there is a server which
controls how that Docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that Docker client
relationship it's done through a rest
API this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that API so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server information about the
infrastructure and it's using this rest
API as that Communication channel the
docker server then will check out the
requests and the interaction necessary
for it to be the docker Daemon which
runs on the server itself well then
check out the interaction and the
necessary operating system pieces needed
to be able to run the container okay so
that's just an overview of the docker
engine which is probably where you're
going to spend most of your time but
there are some other components that
form the infrastructure for Docker let's
dig into those a little bit deeper as
well so what we're going to do now is
break out the four main components that
comprise of the docker environment the
four components are as follows the
docker client and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on Docker
images Docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relation between the docker
client and the docker server and then we
have the rest API in between now if we
start digging into that rest API
particularly the relationship with the
docker Daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using Windows this can be
Powershell on Mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker Daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your Docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within Docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
Docker file you'll store that that image
in the docker Hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a Docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
Docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple Docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your Solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
Consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that document
image and to get access to that image we
use a Docker registry which is an Open
Source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use Docker
itself as its own default registry and
Docker Hub now something that has to be
bear in mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and I really
encourage you to go out to Docker and
see the other Docker images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker register is through simple pull
and push commands but you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write Docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pause so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your Docker
environment and that command will be
Docker pull with the image name and any
Associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in Reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with new
information you do a push command where
you take the script that you've written
about the docker container that you
Define and push it to the repository and
as you can imagine the commands for that
are also fairly simple in terminal
window you would write Docker push the
image name any Associated tags and then
that would then push that image to the
docker repository again either a public
or a private repository so if we recap
the docker file creates a Docker image
that's using the build commands Docker
image then contains all the information
necessary for you to be able to execute
the project using the docker image any
user can run the code in order to create
a Docker container and once a Docker
image is built it's uploaded to a
registry or to a Docker Hub where it can
be shared across your entire team and
from the docker Hub users can get access
to the docker image and build their own
new containers so let's jump into our
first section of life before kubernetes
so the way that you have done work in
the past or you may be doing work right
now is really building out and deploying
Solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a Data Center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to Blind code
out to Virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployments that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have error issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not not effectively and not load
balance effectively across the
environment the problem that you have
with this kind of info infrastructure is
that it gets very expensive you can only
install one piece of software one
service on one piece of Hardware so your
Hardware is being massively
underutilized this is where virtual
machines have become really popular with
a virtual machine you're able to have
better resource utilization and
scalability a much less cost and this
allows you to be able to run multiple
virtual machines on a single piece of
Hardware the problem is is that VMS are
for virtual machines are not perfect
either some of the challenges you run
with VMS is that the actual hardware and
software need needed to manage the VM
environment can be expensive there are
security risks with virtual with VMS
there are security risks with VMS there
have been data breaches recorded about
solutions that run in virtualized
environments you also run into an issue
of availability and this is largely
because you can only have a finite
number of virtual machine running on a
piece of hardware and this results in
limitations and restrictions in the
types of environment you want to be
running and then finally setting up and
managing a virtualized environment is
time consuming it can take a lot of time
and it can also get very expensive so
how about kubernetes well kubernetes is
a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions an
inherently kubernetes is a tool that is
really a Next Level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to Hardware in a Data Center
and then deploying your solutions to
Virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes we've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risk and what you'll
find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
and this is largely because of the
Legacy code the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we will talk about
that in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure virtual machines are
not easily portable now with that said
they they are technically portable
they're just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with Docker container Solutions it is
extremely portable and it means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas we want to kind of highlight the
differences virtual machines use much
less isolation when building out the
encapsulated environment then kubernetes
does for instance with a virtual machine
you have to run hypervisor on top of the
OS and hardware and then inside of the
virtual machine you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a Docker
container and or container like
Technologies it only has to have the OS
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional iOS layer it's able to
inherit what it needs to be able to run
the application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of Hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
Hardware so as we highlighted here VMS
are not as portable as kubernetes and
kubernetes is portable directly related
to the use of containerization and
because kubernetes is built on top of
containers it is much less time
consuming because you can actually
script and automatically allocate
resource to nodes within your kubernetes
environment because it allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
while we are running into a searching
where kubernetes had to come about
because the demand for having more
highly scalable solutions that are more
efficient was just really a natural
evolution of this software deployment
model that started with pushing out code
to physical hardware and then pushing
code out to Virtual machines and then
needing to have a solution much more
sophisticated kubernetes would have come
about at some point in time I'm just
really glad it came back when it did so
what is kubernetes let's dig into the
history of kubernetes and how it came
about so in essence kubernetes is is an
open source platform that allows you to
manage and deploy and maintain groups of
containers and a container is something
like Docker and if you're developing
code you're probably already using
Docker today consider kubernetes as the
tool that manages multiple Docker
environments together now we talk a lot
about Docker and as a container solution
with kubernetes the reality is is that
kubernetes can actually use other
container tools out there but Docker
just simply is the most popular
container out there both these tools are
open source that's why they're so
popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your Solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live in exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
Google and the original project was
Google Google it does exactly what
kubernetes does today but kubernetes was
Rewritten from the ground up and then
released as an open source project in
2014 so that people outside of Google
could take advantage of the power of
kubernetes containerization management
tools and today it is managed by the
cloud native Computing foundation and
there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
Microsoft Azure AWS Google Cloud all of
them will leverage kubernetes and it's
just become the the de facto tool for
managing large groups of containers so
let's kind of Step through some of the
key benefits that you'd experience from
kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits the first it is highly portable
and is 100 open source code and this
means that you can actually go ahead and
contribute to this code project if you
want to through GitHub the ability to
scale up the solution is incredible
um what's um the the history of
kubernetes being part of a Google
project for managing the Google network
and infrastructure
um kind of really sets the groundwork
for having a surgeon that is highly
scalable the out of the high scalability
also comes the need for high
availability and this is the desire to
be able to have a highly efficient and
highly energized environment that also
you can really rely on so if you're
building outer kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're maintaining and it's really
designed for deployment so you can
script out the environment and actually
have it as part of your devops model so
you can scale up and meet the demands of
your customer then what you'll find is
that the load balancing is extremely
efficient and it allows you to
distribute the load efficiently across
your entire network so your network
remains stable and then also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an SSD on the hardware
that the kubernetes is maintaining or if
the kubernetes environment is pulling
storage from a public Cloud such as
Azure or AWS you can actually go ahead
and make that available to your entire
system and you can inherit the security
that goes back and forth between the
cloud environments and one of the things
you'll find consistent with kubernetes
is that it is designed for a cloud-first
environment um kubernetes as well is
that it's it's really a self-healing
environment so if something happens or
something fails kubernetes will detect
that failure and then either restart the
process kill the process or replace it
and then because of that you also have
automated rollouts and rollbacks in case
you need to be able to manage the state
of the environment and then finally you
have automatic bin packaging so you can
actually specify the compute power
that's being used from CPM ramp for each
container so let's dig into the final
area which is the actual kubernetes
architecture I'm going to cover this at
a high level there's actually another
video that you can that simply learn has
developed which digs deeper into the
kubernetes architecture and so the
kubernetes architecture is a clustered
based architecture and it's really about
two key areas you have the kubernetes
master which actually controls
um and all of the activities within your
entire kubernetes infrastructure and
then you have nodes that actually are
running on Linux machines
um out that are controlled by the master
so let's kind of go through some of
these areas so if we look at the
kubernetes master to begin with
um then we'll start with uh Etc this is
a tool that allows for the configuration
and the information and the management
of nodes within your cluster and one of
the key features that you'll find with
all of the tools that are managed within
either a the master environment or
within a node is that they are all
accessible via the API server and what's
interesting about the API server is that
it's a restful based infrastructure
which means that you can actually secure
each connection with SSL and other
security models to ensure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect actually
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual plaster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
Daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so the other tools really are
the the infrastructure and you can
consider them the administration site um
of the master whereas controller is the
management it actually pushes out all of
the controls via the API server so let's
actually dig into one of the actual
nodes themselves and there are three key
areas of the nodes one is the document
frame which actually helps and manage
and maintain the container that's
actually inside of the node and then you
have the Kubler which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the API server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node now the
kubernetes Mazda has the instructions of
what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those instructors to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way today I'll be taking you to the
installation process for Docker so now
let's begin with the demo we'll be
installing Docker on an Ubuntu system so
this is my system I just open the
terminal so the first thing you can
start with is removing any Docker
installation that you probably already
have present in your system if you want
to start from scratch so this is the
command to do so sudo app get removed
docker
dock engine Docker dot IO enter your
password
and Docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install Docker
once again before that I'll just clear
my screen
okay so before I install Docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo app get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type Docker install
and that by itself will give you the
commands you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install.io
is a command that we will need to
execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the sudo
snap install Docker so sudo apt install
Docker dot IO first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have pseudo
snap install Docker so snap install
Docker installs a newly created snap
package
they are basically some other
dependencies for Docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire Docker i o it
will take some time
great so our Docker is installed the
next thing we do as I mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install talk
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for Docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for Docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is Docker
version
and as you can see Docker version
17.12.1 CE has been installed next thing
we do is we pull an image from the
docker hub
so Docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a Docker image which
is present on the docker Hub Docker Hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
if pseudo Docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository this is present on our system
currently so the image has been
successfully pulled onto the system and
this means that our Docker is working
now we'll try out another command
pseudo Docker PF minus a this displays
all the containers that you have pulled
so far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed and
all of them are in exited state so I did
this demo previously too which is why
the two hello worlds which is created
two minutes ago is also displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for Docker PS
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running State you can
simply execute sudo Docker PS
pseudo docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running State welcome everyone to our
one another demo on which we are going
to see that how exactly we can do the
installation of Docker on the Windows
platform specifically on Windows 10. now
Docker is something which is available
for most of the operating systems
different different platforms so it
supports both the Unix and the windows
platform as such so Linux through
various commands we can do the
installation but in the case of Windows
you have to download the exe file and a
particular installer from the docker Hub
websites you can simply Google it and
you will get a kind of a link from where
you will be able to download the package
so let's go to the Chrome and try to
search on for the windows string uh
particular installer you will get a link
from Docker Hub you download it you get
the stable version you get the edge
version whichever version you want you
wish to download you can download it so
let's go back to the Chrome so here you
have the docker desktop for Windows so
you can go for the stable or you can go
for the edge and right so you also have
the comparison that what is the
difference between these two versions
right so um the particular Edge version
is something which is getting releases
every month and uh the
um stable version is getting the
releases every quarter so they are not
doing much of the changes to the stable
version as compared to the edge there so
you just have to double click on the
installer and that will help you to do
the installation of the process so let's
get started so you just click on the get
in stable version so when you do that
the particular installer is going to
install now it's going to take like
around 300 MB there so that's the kind
of install which is available so once
the installer is downloaded so what you
can do is that you can actually go ahead
and you can proceed with the doing the
double click on this installer when you
double click on that you have to proceed
with some of the steps like you know
from the GUI itself you are going to
proceed with these steps so we'll wait
for 10 to 20 seconds more and then the
installer will be done and then we can
do the double click and the install
solution will proceed so another thing
is that uh there is a huge difference
between the installer like for example
in case of Unix the installer is a
little bit less but in case of windows
it's a GUI is also involved and there
are a lot of binders which is available
there so that's the reason why you know
the Hue size is there now it's available
for free that's for sure and it also
requires the Windows 10 professional or
Enterprise 64-bit there so um if you are
working on some previous uh version of
operating systems like Windows 7 and all
you have the older version called Docker
toolbox so they used to call it as like
Docker toolbox earlier but now they are
calling it as in Docker desktop with a
new Docker Windows 10 support as such
here so another couple of seconds and
then the installer will be done and then
we will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so I'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a GUI component will open there
so it will start proceeding with the
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay I'm going to
click on OK so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for the
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any Docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here that Docker
is you know something which is installed
so you can run like Docker version you
will be able to get a version of the
client when you do the restart of the
machine then add that moment of time the
docker server will also be started and
then this particular error message will
go off right now the docker demon is not
up and running because the installation
requires a restart and when you close on
this one and go for the restart the
machine will be restarted here so this
is the way that how exactly we can go
for a Docker installation and we can go
on that part now let's start with what
exactly isn't devops all about here now
devops is nothing but a collaboration
between the development and the
operations teams over here which enables
continuous delivery of the applications
and services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration continuous
deployment continuous delivery all these
things are possible with this
collaboration over here now why exactly
Docker is important for us as such
in a city far away from this one so a
developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single VM now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the the
multiple application on a single machine
but for him these virtual machine got a
crash because definitely if you are
putting up more uh different different
applications as such on the on a single
VM it's not able to take up that much
kind of load over there so in order to
avoid this situation how exactly he can
do the various options or what he can
Implement to have this uh issue result
so ultimately Docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications uh
on a single virtual machine or he want
to have different different applications
then Docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so uh there
will be no issues as such when we talk
about that uh the errors or the virtual
machines cannot be crashed and well
there will be no impact on the virtual
machine as such so why exactly Docker is
important so let's talk about the
comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly the docker is being
chosen overnight virtual machine because
virtual machine is a full-fledged
component which can take up any kind of
load but some of the reasons are still
that in which case we will be preferring
the docker instead of the virtual
machine here the very first one is the
memory users so Docker is having a very
less memory users because there is no
concept of guest operating system
whereas on the other hand the virtual
machines are going to take a huge amount
of Ram uh resources in order to keep
that particular operating system up and
running second one performance because
uh if definitely if you have less uh
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver that amount of performance as
such over there and then again we have
portability so portability is also quite
easy when we talk about the virtual
machines in case of Docker it's quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine put
on time is probably in minutes but uh in
case of Docker it's in second so if we
summarize it on this one so the memory
utilization the boot up time the
performance everything is better in case
of Docker as compared to the virtual
machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that I have one app to and app3
is there so green and red color
represents the occupied memory and the
wasted memory now
there is a particular utilization of
let's say that
um you know a server which is available
there and uh you know 3gb of uh RAM is
something which is wasted and 4GB of RAM
is something which is being occupied
there so app2 is using like 2GB and uh
then you can see that the specific 2GB
of RAM is occupied and 3gb is occupied
and the wasted one is 1GB so VM can see
over there that uh you know 9 GB of RAM
is used and the remaining 6gb of uh
unused Ram cannot be reused here because
if for example I allocate like 4GB of
ram to the virtual machine it's there
itself it gets logged on so it's not
like okay uh I'm using only 4GB Ram out
of this 9gb of ram then the next uh 5 GB
of RAM will be totally wasted so you
cannot reuse it for any purpose so this
is a problem with the virtual machine
that if you allocate some memory to the
specific virtual machine if you are not
using that much uh resources or that
much memory the remaining memory will be
simply pasted because this is hard
coally allocated to a virtual machine
and you cannot utilize this unused
memory as such over there so this is the
limitation from the memory perspective
but in case of Docker definitely if uh
you know out of the 9 GB of RAM if we
are using uh only 3gb of RAM
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to for the new
containers so it's not delicately
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using a out of 9gb if you are using
1GB 2GB 3gb or 4GB whatever the
remaining uh memory is available that
you can simply use it for the other
containers also this ensures that you
always go for an optimal utilization of
your resources and unnecessarily there
is no wastage of the different different
resources or the different components
over here in this one so that's the
reason why the docker containers are
quite uh efficient in terms of memory
when we compare it with the virtual
machine next one is a performance now um
in a virtual machine we know that you
know on the infrastructure on the
physical infrastructure on top of that
you put up a kind of operating system a
base operating system is there and then
on top of that you have the hypervisor
and this hypervisor then is used to
create the virtual machines which is
having a kind of desktop operating
system inside it now the issue over here
is that you have two operating systems
over here so the guest operating system
is also going to take some particular
resources and for example the memory or
a space a processor so in every terms in
every resource terms it is going to
go ahead and say that okay I'm going to
use the particular sum of the resources
Now problem is that if you are hosting a
very small application you will end up
in having a more consumption because of
this guest operating system will take
more of more of the resources and then
you are just using some small very small
resources for your application in an uh
real world so Docker container on the
other hand does not have a concept of
the guest operating system and that's
where what happens that the docker
engine is more than sufficient to handle
the docker containers and inside the
docker containers there is the
application which is being hosted over
there now with this one definitely the
performance is quite better as compared
to any uh virtual machine because of the
terms that there is no unnecessarily
wasted of the resources because in the
previous case virtual machines are
full-fledged cash operating system is up
and running you need some resources to
be allocated to that but in case of
containers you don't need to have that
particular functionality implemented
then portability so
um you know having a portability or
moving an application which works on a
system a does not mean that it will work
on the system B also this is a similar
problem which we face that you know
usually the application works perfectly
fine in a lower environment and when it
goes to the production environment it
sometimes fails and it does not comes up
properly so this isn't portability issue
which we have when we talk about the
virtual machines but when in case of
containers when we got a container up
and running in a lower environment and
once the container is prepared you don't
have to do the changes or modification
to that depending on the environment the
same container can be deployed till
production environment and it's very
easy so whatever a container prepared in
the lower environment in a Dev
environment the same will work in
production environment without any
issues because it contains all the
dependencies and executables everything
inside it so you don't have to do any
kind of modifications or changes to
these containers as such over here and
the last one is a boot up time so uh the
boot up time of the virtual machines is
in minutes and whereas the boot up time
of the docker containers is in seconds
or probably in milliseconds so these are
the reason why we consider the virtual
machine as in uh resources based
environment but on the other hand Docker
is something which is quite light and
fast as compared to Virtual machines so
let's see that what exactly is in Docker
all about here so in this one you can
see we have the physical infrastructure
on which we have the host operating
system now we don't have the hypervisor
and the guest operating system instead
of that we have the docker engine which
is taking care of managing the docker
containers and inside these Docker
containers you have the applications and
all the required binaries and the
libraries here so there is no concept of
the gift operating system these Docker
engine is the uh person or is the
process which is taking care of all the
requests which is going on and if this
Docker engine is up and running then all
the containers will also be accessible
and will be available now Docker is
nothing but a OS level virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and it administrators to
create deploy and run applications in a
Docker container with all its
dependencies so Docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production environment now let's talk
about what exactly is in dock container
here now Docker container is a
lightweight software package that uh
includes all the dependencies whether
it's a base operating system uh some
framework sample libraries it's it's
something which is uh part of this one
so that if you will be if you want to
host your application you will be able
to do that so it's a complete package so
both the source code and the
dependencies is what you put up inside
the docker containers now
within this Docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
Frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
this Docker containers you can host them
as such over there now one of the
different advantages of Docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so rapid deployment is
the very first advantages which we are
getting over here second quick and easy
configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability and security over here now
there are different ways in which we can
understand the benefits or we can have
the understanding about the docker here
so uh these are some couple of benefits
now let's take a uh take them one by one
the first the first one is the
deployment part so it's it supports the
rapid deployment now
just like a web application for instance
I want to deploy to Webster so there are
some couple of steps which needs to be
done across different different
environments like for example if I have
five environments I have to do the
deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
Docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one Docker
container the same Docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay I have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your Docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we goes for
the quick and easy configurations so uh
the configurations of Docker containers
is quite easy you can have your own
custom Docker images built out the
docker files so these processes can be
integrated within the Jenkins also so
cicd is quite possible with the help of
Docker if you want to really do that and
then we have better efficiency yes they
have a better efficiency and resources
management as compared to the virtual
machines portability uh we have already
thought about that that it's easy to
move from one environment from one
system to another in fact it's easy from
the developer also so from one machine
from one developer to another developer
it's very easy to move these uh
different Docker containers then we have
scalability
scalability is also possible with the
Stocker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
orchestration tools then security is
there so you can have your best
practices of the security implemented
because
um it's just a kind of a virtualization
just like a virtual machine so you have
all the uh different uh possibilities
which is available which you can explore
when you talk when you want to make the
stock container secure right so these
were some of the benefits which was
there for the docker here now let's talk
about the installation of Docker here
now installation of Docker is pretty
common and whatever platform you want
it's available over there so it's
available for Ubuntu windows
it's available for Mac operating system
so for Ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the Ubuntu part operating
system to download it and for Windows
it's actually having a a particular exe
file so you can go for the installation
of exe file and then we have the Mac
operating system so for Mac operating
system you have the DMG files and when
you do the DMG file so it will help you
to install the component over there so
Mac you can also use the home view wants
to do the installation of that
particular component now next one is the
architecture of Docker now the
architecture of Docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of Docker here the very
first one is the as the client facing is
the docker client now Docker client or
you can say the docker CLI is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example I'm running the command so it
will take all the requests from me as an
end user and it will send those uh
particular uh things or the requirements
to the docker demon to the server using
the rest API interface so this Docker
demon is something which keeps on
running on the server and it's a
background process it gets deployed as
in service there in case this Docker
demon is not available or it's not up
and running you will not get the proper
response from the docker command line
here so in order to get your activity or
your procedures implemented you need to
have the docker server or Docker demon
up and running in fact this Docker CLI
can be configured to connect to any
other servers or any other different
server Docker demon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest API interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demand and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of Docker here let's talk
about that so Docker client consists of
the CLI component like we have already
discussed so that is something which is
going to take up all the requests from
the end user then
um it's using the rest API interface
which is there to have the connectivity
with the docker Daemon so Docker demon
is something which is always up and
running so if you run a couple of
commands like Docker pull position also
that activity you are actually sending
the request to the docker demon and
Docker demon is actually doing all the
work so it's not a Docker client which
is doing it's just taking its kind of
interface which will take the things up
and send it back or send it forward to
the docker there
right so it's a background process which
keeps on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's the same
process across all the infrastructure
all the different platforms whether you
use Mac operating system use Windows or
you use Linux everywhere this is the
basic functionality and it keeps on
listening to the rest API interface so
uh whatever the request new request
comes in it immediately process it and
whatever the response whether you are
stopping a container whether you're
running a container according to that
the action will be taken and the
response will be sent back to the rest
API to the docker client so a Docker is
a processor it's a command line which is
used to start the docker demon when you
run the command like service Docker
status on the server you will be able to
see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that Docker is the process or is
the command line which is used to
initialize the docker Daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psyphen EF
command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
particular Docker in history so we have
a ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker Hub so you
can actually store the docker images on
these Docker registry so there are a lot
of ready-made Docker images which is
available there but of course you can
have your own Docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom registry Docker Registries also
for example in jfrog you can have your
private hosted Registries also so all
these uh different repositories you can
use with your Docker container so Docker
containers is having the flexibility
that whichever Registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here in detail
now a Docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions it's having a
couple of instructions in which you will
be using these instructions to create a
final doc container so Docker image is
uh nothing but uh for example I want to
have a Target Apache Docker image so
what are the instructions I have to do
so the very first thing is that I have
to pick up a base operating system then
on top of that I will be installing the
jdk or some pre-request packages and
then on top of that we will be
configuring on to the Target Apache
there so these are the steps these are
the different instructions step by step
procedure which we are implementing so
that at the end of the activity we will
be able to have a Docker container ready
which we can deploy to host Tomcat
Apache so it's a template which is
having all the particular instructions
in order to build a Docker image you
require a file called Docker file which
is uh of course having all these
different uh
instructions embedded that so when you
run the docker file it acts like a build
tool so whatever the instructions you
are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting a processed and
you are able to get a end result and
then these Docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration of of the Tomcat
Apache and then another layer will be
there so it's a multi-layered in uh
component which is available and these
layers are in incremental order so
definitely the oldest one will be known
as the base layer and then on top of
that all the latest changes will be done
in the latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that there
are four instructions and these four
instructions are also known as the four
layer Docker image so whatever over the
final Docker image you will get in there
you will be able to see four layers of
the docker image here now the very first
is Ubuntu so Ubuntu 18.04 we are pulling
up and then we are pulling like uh the
file over here and uh then we are
running the make utility and uh once
that is done then we are running that
file dot uh python file over here in
this one so these are four instructions
which is available right so uh which
will definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can make or we can perform
the different activities right from the
base so in this case the base layer will
be like uh the Ubuntu one so Ubuntu one
will be the base image and the moment
the final CMP attribute or CMD uh
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full flash Docker image over there
so this will be a full complete Docker
image or Docker container which you will
get once the whole build process is
completed
now in this ways you have you can see
that the previous Docker file which we
processed so the base layer is Ubuntu
18.04 we are not building that actually
it's automatically it's uh it's by
default getting downloaded as in full
base layer after that only we have like
layer one layer 2 layer 3 added up
because those modifications we are doing
it after the uh because from does not
means that you are doing any kind of
layer modifications just like you are
importing some base operating system or
base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new uh layer is something which is
stopped on top of the image these layers
are known as the containers layers so
one to one the very first instruction
does not comprises it it is it's not a
com kind of uh container layer we can
call it as an base image layer there so
every container has a separate read
write container layer and any
modification in a container is reflected
upon the container layers only so layer
one may be having some different of
instructions layer 2 may be having
different instructions so like that it's
a step-by-step processor
in case you know whenever a container is
deleted the top layer also gets deleted
over there in that one so if I delete
some particular containers and that is
something which is gone so it was
suppose having like three layers so the
top layer will be simply deleted because
the container is also deleted for that
particular part now Docker uses a copy
and write strategy with both Docker
images and Docker containers so uh
whenever we uh perform any activity or
whenever we copy on uh write a
strategies and strategy to share and
copy files for better efficiency so it's
something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes the
docker efficient by reducing the uses of
this space because whenever uh required
okay whenever is needed only at that
moment of time it's actually performing
the copy and uh it definitely reduces
the overall disk utilization and this is
very important also because when you
have so many docker containers up and
running so you have to worry or you have
to make the utilization of a disk or
your disk users or resources also
minimum so that is also you need to make
sure that it does not exceed a
particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about uh some of the
facts here so the base layers are
something which is purely read-only
formed so you cannot do the
modifications Union file system saves
the memory uh you know by avoiding the
duplications of the files uh the layers
can be combined in a union file system
to create a single image so all these
layers are combined and got a final
product are called you know you can call
it as Docker image or Docker containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a writable which is known as copy on
right so copy and write strategy is
being used so to do the changes or to do
the perform the modifications of this
Union file system file creating the
different different layers so
now let's talk about the dock
registering very important component
because even if you prepare the docker
image locally and you don't have the
collaborative tool or you don't have the
uh tool where you can share these images
definitely it's not easy for you to Port
these Docker images from one system to
another so Docker registry is very
important for the portability feature of
Docker so Docker registry is a service
to host and distribute Docker images
among users so uh it can be built up by
one user and multiple users can use it
for example I'm using a Jenkins one so
um shankins uh image is prepared only
once but it's being used by different
people as such Docker registry again
it's a repository is a collection of
Docker images so in a repository you
will be having like different different
uh Docker images as such so in registry
a user can distinguish between the
docker images with their tag names so uh
for example Jenkins is an a kind of a
single image they might be different
type of images there let's say that okay
let's talk about uh Jenkins uh gdkade so
there will be image called Jenkins the
name of the image will be same but the
tags will be different so one tag could
be like jedicate one tag would be like
jdk9 and one time would be jdk10 so the
difference between all these three
Docker images is that that jdk81 is
prepared on gdk8 it's running on jdk8
and if you want to use jtk 9 in that
case you have to pull down the the
docker image of Jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the framework
so depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distinguish between
the uh Docker images and whichever
Docker image you feel you want to use
you can Implement according to your
requirement and uh Docker by default is
having its own uh cloud-based registry
called as Docker Hub which gets
automatically connected when the moment
you do the docker installation but in
case you are walking into your private
infrastructure so in that case you may
use the repositories uh Docker
repositories on the specific jfrog
artifactory or the private repositories
also can be hosted
but Docker Hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use a
push and pull activities to interact
with these Docker images you want to
download a Docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your Docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the docker Hub so when
you run some build process or when you
run the containers there may be some
Docker containers which is getting
pulled down from the specific registry
from the docker Hub and uh if that
specific image and tag is available
definitely pull command will be
successful but in case of push command
you are pushing your custom Docker
images uh you cannot push the ready-made
Docker images which is available you can
publish your own Docker image only to
the docker Hub and then you can further
on do the Poland push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready made and third party
images which is available you can only
do the poll activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom Docker image next one
is the docker container now Docker
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a Docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the application source
code inside it so the docker container
don't have to look for the dependencies
on the host machine on the server so
this is one of the benefit where we see
that the portability is very easy
because whatever I'm building up on one
system everything is inside the docker
container so I don't really need to do
any further activity on other machines
so whatever works on one system can be
easily worked on another system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular servers because
it does not take that much utilization
like a virtual machine so if you are
looking forward for having your
application hosted into your local
system you can easily do it within the
dock container so the utilization is
very less as compared to the virtual
machine so you don't have to worry about
your operating host operating system and
the qualifications
so Docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine so
there is no interaction or there is no
interface so they share the OS called uh
kernel but uh the thing is they don't
have the interface as such over there so
it works totally in isolation uh two
different containers will not have any
interaction unless and until we do we
set up that window containers to have
the interactions
now there is uh data volumes which can
be shared and uh be used among the
multiple containers so
um you have the capability over here
that you know if the there is some on
used uh space that can be easily shared
across the multiple containers here so
uh it is uh built using the docker
images so uh using the docker images the
docker containers are built up and uh
Docker run is a specific command which
is used to build a Docker container so
if you got a Docker image let's say that
I have prepared a Docker image a custom
Docker image using the docker file now
if I need to create a Docker container
out of a Docker image I have to run a
docket one command so Docker run command
is nothing but it initializes or creates
an instance of a Docker image now let's
component is the docker compose now
typically when we work with the the
docker containers so we had to run like
if I want to run like five six
containers I have to initialize like
five six times or I have to run Docker
and months five six times there so and
if you want to create a relationship
between the containers then definitely
that is something which you need to
manage using the docker commands but
sometimes it's not an easy task for you
to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so Docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
we just got off a kind of a single file
you just run it and all the containers
definitions and relationships everything
is inside this Docker file here so you
want to run two containers that's
totally fine instead of running two
commands now you just have to run one
file and that will do take care of that
now you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any manual
activity or without any maintenance onto
the server
so these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to uh
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these uh
Docker compose files so Docker compose
file is something which is written in a
vml format and in this you define that
okay I need two containers and this in
this image should be there these are the
parameters which you need to run and if
you want to have the interaction or the
linkage between the images that also you
can establish within this yml files or
this in within this Docker compose file
here right so let's say for example I
want to have an application which
requires Apache web server and mySQL
database now I can create a Docker
compose file which can run both
containers and uh without you know you
don't require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so I will be having a final Docker
compose file which is having like a uh
you know containers like Apache
containers and mysq containers both
inside a single Docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you are going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate Apache and
separate viable MySQL so you can get it
done with the help of a single Docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker spam now Docker spam is a
inbuilt or it's a default oxygen tool
which is being provided by the docker
itself it's a service for containers
which allows the it administrators and
the developers to create and manage a
cluster of swamp nodes so um in a
typical world when you do the
installation of Docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high availability multiple uh
instances or scalability all these
things are not possible as it is with a
code Docker now on top of that you
require the organization tools like
Docker spam where you have a swam of
node machines five six known machines
are there on which you can have your
highly available application
infrastructure implemented now this one
means that if I want to run my
applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of Docker swam is having a
Docker demon which is uh used to for
performing the interaction so there will
be a master node which is available so
uh it will be interacting with all the
known machine on the all the client
machines and this interaction will be in
such a way that it will let them know
okay I want to deploy the container or
onto the Note 3 so it will perform that
activity and the container will be up
and running on the Note 3 there so a
swam consists of two type of nodes one
is the manager node and one is a worker
node so manager is the master node which
you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so the
manager node is not something which is
expected to host uh anything apart from
the main component but yes uh you can
always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can do during the deployment of
the containers so manager will will keep
on connecting to the different worker
nodes there and whenever new request
comes in so it will basically try to
connect and see that okay I just want to
go ahead and deploy a container so it
will do the deployment of the container
on the worker node so the main work will
be done by the worker nodes and manager
is just doing the management of all
these resources the worker nodes will be
definitely receiving the request from
the manager and it will be proceeding
and Performing those activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active or online so the master node will
not be able to deploy the containers on
that server so right now let's talk
about a demo in which we have to create
a Docker image using a Docker file on
the open220 so if you want to use a base
operating system as an Ubuntu 20 there
and using that we will we are going to
create a custom Docker image so let's
connect to our virtual machine and see
that how we can do that okay so as part
of this demo here we are going to
prepare a Docker image and in that we
are going to use a base image of Ubuntu
so let's take an operating system of
Ubuntu 20 20 is the latest version of
the Ubuntu operating system so I have
got a server so let's see so first of
all we have to install the docker.io
package which will install the docker
package and then we can enable the uh
service we can make sure that the docker
service is up and running because if the
service itself is down then we will not
be able to perform any activity and then
our sample if you run Docker run allo
hyphen volt so that is going to pull a
Docker image from the docker Hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also try
some of the Ubuntu Docker image also if
you feel that you want to try you can do
that but the main uh demo which we need
to do over here is that we need to
prepare a custom Docker image and in
this one we will be having like we will
be using an uh Ubuntu base operating
system on top of that we will be
installing PHP nginx all these different
components so we are going to have a PHP
based website hosted onto the Apache web
server as an nginx and then we will be
able to access that application so the
very first thing which we need to do is
that we need to create a folder uh let's
say that I just created a particular
folder called nginx iPhone image and
then I create a Docker file over there
so Docker file uh content we are going
to take from this one so let's go to the
server and see that how we can go ahead
with the activity now uh what we can do
is that uh What uh we have got a server
over here now in this server what I'm
going to do is that I am going to
proceed with installation of Docker
first now when I do the docker
installation first so what will happen
that I will be able to have my Docker
installation completed and then further
on I can take the further steps of
having the accessibility of going
through the understanding that what is
this uh particular platform or how to
prepare different different kind of
containers so
I have got a particular container over
here so what I can really do is that I
can simply say that okay I have got a
server so this is a one two server so
I'm going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that I will
be able to have establish the fact that
I'm trying to connect I'm trying to uh
connect to the Ubuntu URL so that at any
moment of time I should be able to fetch
on the latest packages now once that is
done so I'm going to run the command
called apt install Docker dot IO now the
moment I do this what will happen that
it will try to download some packages it
will ask for the confirmation you can
give your confirmation and I can say yes
the moment you give the confirmations
the download of the packages will
proceed over here step by step it will
download the packages and the
installation will go on now once the
installation is done so what you can do
is that that you can see that Docker is
deployed into your system or not you can
run Docker version command or you can
also use the service command to check to
make sure to ensure that the docker
service is always up and running if the
service is not up and running you have
to make sure you have to enable it you
have to start that service so these are
some couple of steps which you need to
do in order to make sure that your
connectivity or your environment is
ready for with the docker installation
and once the docker installation is done
then only you will be able to proceed
further with the further activities like
preparing the containers preparing the
images and all that stuff but if you
don't have the docker installed prior to
that then definitely it's going to be a
problem so just make sure that before
even doing any kind of activity before
even doing any kind of steps we ensure
that the docker is fully up and running
so it's going to take some time to
download the packages and we will wait
for that and once the installation is
done we will continue further on that
part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command call service
Docker status and when you do that it
will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response and uh now you can see that
it's showing up that a process is
running so earlier it was not uh up and
running it was inactive but now it's
active and you can see here the dock
right is the process which is running
over here as in a process to initialize
the docker demand so Docker demon is up
and running now and we are good to go
here so now uh if we go and say like
Docker run hello hyphen world so we are
doing a validation to our Docker
instance that whether our Docker
instance is working fine as expected or
not because uh if there is any kind of
problem with the docker demon and Docker
demon is not up and running properly we
would be able to get an error message
over there but right now there is no
error message which represents that uh
yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh Docker
images when you run so you will be able
to see that the docker image is pulled
down to your system and definitely you
have executed that and it got you the
response now the next thing which you
need to do is that we need to run a
particular Ubuntu one so for example if
I go for docker run hyphen ID Ubuntu
bash so what exactly we are doing in
this one is that we are pulling down a
Ubuntu Docker image and we are running
the bash executable on top of that the
whole purpose of doing that activity is
that so that if I want to do some uh
process or I want to perform some
activity I should be able to connect to
that Docker image so the moment I drew
this first of all if this Docker image
is available locally that's great it
will immediately create the container if
the docker image is not available
locally the very first thing which it
will perform over here is to pull down
the docker image the correct one and as
you can see here that it uh definitely
pulls down the docker image and once it
is done so it got a terminal for you now
you can see it shows that root and the
ID root and the rate one ID is there
this ID is nothing but it's a container
ID which we are getting here so
definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come out of the docker
container over here and the moment you
run Docker PS hyphen a command you can
actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far so you run
hello world you ran the Ubuntu One both
of them are stopped there you can see
the exit 0 in the uh status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the interactive mode so they
are done so if you want to keep your
container up and running you need to
have a container which runs in the dash
mode and always up and running but for
that you have to go ahead to the level
where we need to create a custom Docker
image and do the setup accordingly so
let's see that how we can do that now
I'm going to create a particular folder
called nginx hyphen image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
I'm going to put up a file called Docker
file so let's see that what content we
need to put as such when we talk about
the docker file because whatever content
you put over here that is what according
which the docker image will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay Ubuntu 20.04 is what I want to
use then we are giving some labels now
these labels are used to give some
information like what is the version Who
is the maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so these
labels are actually defined and utilized
so that I will be able to give an
information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh Docker file or will
this build script we have to reach out
to that specific person so this is what
we typically do with the labels here now
um we also have to set up a parameter
like devian underscore fronted as in
non-interactive because whenever we talk
about any build process in Docker file
it it cannot be there in the interactive
session it should be there in the
non-interactive and definitely a typical
uh scenarios like you can run app update
command and then we are installing the
PHP nginx super supervisor all these
things we are doing we are doing the
installation uh we are using the Run
attribute run a particular step and in
there whatever the commands are executed
these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so nginx we are virtual host PHP
underscore conf nginx underscore conf
and supervisor underscore conf these are
the different environment variables
which we configuring over here now next
thing which we have is that uh we have
to transfer some files like probably
nginx and the virtual host file we may
have to transfer from a Linux server to
the destination to the docker container
so for that we are going to run some
copy commands copy statements so that we
can do that stuff and uh then definitely
we are transferring the supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that configurations uh
set up over there and uh these uh config
supervisor underscore conf and all these
different variables we have already
established where we are saying that
what exactly configuration we are
looking forward over here and then we
are you know creating in some folder
structure via WWE HTML folder structure
we are creating so that we will be able
to push some content over there and then
we have the volume configurations so
whatever the volume configurations are
there we are putting up so that uh you
know we will be able to have all the uh
specific direct directories mounted on
the host machine on the host server so
that we can even talk about locally also
and then the start.sh is something which
we need to run because that's uh that
will go into the command statement which
needs to be executed because when you
want to run your process when you want
to run your engineers process or your
Docker container some process should be
up and running that's where uh if any
interactive process will run then only
the docker container will be hold up so
that's what you can do do or you can
configure over there so I'm going to
copy this whole content now this whole
content represents the complete Docker
file so uh we have already gone through
this content one by one but uh if we
combine all these content together till
the exposed part that's where we come up
into these one so exposed we are doing
80 and 443 over here right after this
one we have to create a host file
virtual host file supervisor D file and
the star.sh file so let's go back to the
server here now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that uh so this is what I
will my master file will look like you
can see I'm running some run commands uh
these are the environment variables I'm
using then further on this variables I'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the host machine from
the server to the docker container and
then second file is supervisor D not
confile and then we have star.sh file so
these are the different files which we
want to configure here so once this file
is prepared we have to uh type in or we
have to create a default file over here
in this current directory so in this
current directory we have to put up a
file called default now in this one we
will be having the default virtual host
configuration config so we need to put
our server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the Via WWE HTML directory
there so I'm just going to copy this
content
and put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so I'll save it
and then we have a supervisor d.com file
so
so I'll just copy the content of this
one
I'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisor d.com file
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into our
Docker file so we can double check that
so once this is done save it and we can
check the docker file we can grab
so you can see okay this one so super
visor D so the name is correct that's
cool so we got default we got supervisor
D now we have to create the star.sh file
because in this one we will be
configuring that how we want to start
our process of this nginx or this web
server so in this one again we have to
run the supervisory process over here
and a configuration file so we are going
to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there and
the moment is done so you are going to
give the execute permission to this one
because
um you can see that into our Docker file
that we are having the attribute where
we want to run this into the dots slash
there so if we want to refer in that
mode you have to change the permissions
in case so that uh change mode you have
to give the execute permission to the
start.shm now once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular components like you got uh
some couple of commands you have uh you
know got Docker file
supervisd.com default all these files
are there now the only thing which we
need to do next is that we need to build
to the build process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process what happens the docker build is
the command which we need to use and uh
engine xiphon image is the name which
you want to refer now you can totally
use this uh custom name you whatever
name you feel that you may want to use
you can always use that there's no
restriction on that part and once that
is on so you will be able to list down
those images that you got a new custom
Docker image here so you can see that
you got the Ubuntu as on base image
which is built down and The nginx Hyphen
image is also prepared over there and
once that is done so you are going to
create a Webroot folder and uh you can
run the docker run command to see that
if you really got connected with that
particular one so let's go back and see
that how we can create uh the docker
custom Docker image here so the moment I
do this so it will pick up the docker
file over here and start performing the
activities uh the package installations
all those configurations ones will be
performed over here in the
non-interactive mode there is no
confirmation which will be asked from
the user because you cannot put that
confirmations so the command should be
in such a way that it should not take
any kind of confirmations at all from
the end user so because tomorrow you may
be putting up these things in the
Jenkins so that will not be a physical
thing for you to put up the commands and
put up the confirmations during the
execution so so it's trying to do the
package installation for the PHP so fpm
packages are getting installed and um
here we go so we caught the successful
message now you can see it says
successfully tag this one this means
that there is no issues at all with the
docker image and when you run the docker
images or Docker images LS you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203 37 MB of the size
of this image that represents that this
Docker image is fully ready to run to
execute so now what we are going to do
is that we are going to map a volume
over here with VAR ww HTML directory
during the execution of this container
because I really want to deploy some
pages and web pages there if you have
the web pages now as part of the build
process as part of the docker find you
can do a git clone also of some
repository but I don't want to do that
uh during the preparation of Docker
image I just now got an environment
where the nginx is set up properly and
it's up and running there now it should
be upon me that how I want to put up my
content and all so that's the reason why
I'm putting up a kind of a folder
structure over here and sharing it with
the docker container so that the moment
I put the the HTML files or the PHP
files into that local folder I should be
able to get some web page up when
running there so that's what I'm going
to do over here in this one so I'm going
to create a folder structure saying
slash web root here okay so there is a
folder structure which is created now in
this Webroot I will be putting up some
files and then same files will be
redirected inside the docker container
with the help of Docker volume so let's
go back to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like I
said that you are going to connect on
that part okay so uh you can use this
port as an at also but here it is used
so whatever Port you feel you want to
use you can do that and we are giving
the container name as test and iPhone
container that also you can change nginx
iPhone image is the one which we are
using so if you use some different uh
particular image you can also use that
and uh you can see that the web root is
something which we are connecting with
the Via WWE HTML directory so the moment
you put some file in the web root the
same file will be reflected into the WWE
HTML directory there so I'm going to run
this command and once this is done so
you can see that for the testing purpose
we are putting up some content in the
HTML one so I'll come to that point also
and we'll validate as of now we should
be having our container up and running
over here in this one now I'm going to
copy that command
okay and hit on so if uh the 80 Port is
used so you have to make sure that photo
gets uh you know gets stopped
automatically or it should not be up and
running so just double check whatever
code you are using that should be free
now when you run the docker PS command
so uh you will be able to see a Docker
container up and running but if you see
like Docker psyphony that gives also the
stopped and running both the containers
are there but the main thing which we
want to run is that we want to run the
docker PS command and you can see that
this is a container which is running so
8080 is the container which is running
in test hyphen container is the name now
you got a container up and running so
you can actually do a curl on localhost
colon 8080 so um this is a way to get
the content uh you can get the public IP
also and uh in the browser you can put
up and you can have the content there
but right now we are getting the
response at least uh it's showing is 403
error forbidden error but that's fine we
will be putting up some web pages there
in the Via WWE HTML free or we can say
in local Webroot directory so that we
will be able to have some content so
what we can do is that we can have some
Eco commands to execute it so that we
can have some added some content added
up into the uh particular files there so
let's see that what different contents
we can do so uh you can use the vi mode
also to do a uh you know couple of files
so I'm just using this Eco command
so um the moment I go for this execution
so what happens that a file will be
created into that uh Slash Webroot there
so
um I'm expecting that I have put up a
index.html page so if you feel that you
want to put some different page you can
always do and uh the moment you do the
curl now you will be able to see the
same response so whatever the things you
put up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some PHP files you want to put up some
PHP content all that stuff you can do it
now what I'm going to do is that rather
than just a HTML static content I'm
going to put some PHP content that is
going to help me to get a file so my
Webroot will have now two files so
um if if you feel uh that index.html
file should have some uniform content
you can always do that you can pull some
of the websites also you can put that
into the you can do a git clone in the
web root and the whole application will
be started and now
if you feel that I got a info.php file
so I can use the NAT name into the URL I
have to modify the URL because uh
index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do if you want to
put up some different name you can
change the server configuration of nginx
and according to that it will work so um
when I do this so you will start getting
the output so this is the PHP content
output which is there it's a complete
information now it may look like a very
bulky content to you but when you put up
this one into the browser into the web
browser that will be a meaningful
information probably in terms of some
tables or something like that right so
um let me scroll to the top here so you
can see that it's showing an error sorry
it's showing in the output and this
output represents it you've got a
particular PHP content here so this is
how we will be able to have a container
and uh you know this container is up and
running you can modify it at any level
you feel that you want to prepare a
Docker image with the code embedded also
you can have the kit clone or you can
have this configuration into some git
repository have the source code also
there and then prepare a complete bundle
all together so this is what we have in
this demo how we can deploy a container
and a container up and running in case
of the docker yes
so that was the demo right uh which we
took to create a Docker custom Docker
image on using the docker file on Ubuntu
20. let's have a look at what we have in
our current environment so today when
you actually have your standard machine
you have the infrastructure you have the
host operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a Docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly the
different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest OS and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
now this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
Dev and opt environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running Apache Tomcat in it
with Java and second container is
running SQL server and microsoft.net
environment the third container is
running python with mySQL these are all
running just fine within the docker
engine and sitting on top of a host OS
which could be Linux it really could be
any host OS within a consistent
infrastructure and you're able to have a
solution that can be shared easily
amongst your teams so let's have a look
at an example that you'd have today if a
company is doing a traditional Java
application so you have your developers
working in JBoss on his system and he's
coding away and he has to get that code
over to a test and now what will happen
is that tester will then typically in
your traditional environment then have
to install JBoss on their machine and
get everything running and cool and
hopefully set up identically to the
developer chances are they probably
won't have it exactly the same but
they're trying to get it as close as
possible and then at some point you want
to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install JBoss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
JBoss three times and this is where it
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environments if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developers probably got a
whole bunch of development software they
could be conflicting with the JBoss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools that the developer
and tester have their own tools and so
what you want to be able to do is kind
of get away from The Challenge you have
of having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where Docker comes in and Docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on device you install
all of the code into your Docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what Docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of Docker and kind of go
through what Docker container is and how
to create a Docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of
using containers and then the commands
and finalize everything out with a brief
demo so what is darker so darker is as
you'd expect because all the software
that we cover in this series is an open
source solution and it is a container
solution that allows you to be able to
containerize all of the necessary files
and applications needed to run the
solution you're building so you can
share it from different people in your
team whether it's a developer a tester
or system administrator and this allows
you to have a consistent environment
from one group to the next so let's kind
of dig into the architecture so you
understand why Docker runs effectively
so the docker architecture itself is
built up of two key elements there is
the docker client and then there is a
rest API connection to a Docker Daemon
which actually hosts the entire
environment within the docker host and
the docker demon you have your different
different containers and each one has a
link to a Docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest API and that sends
command line to the docker Daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with Docker the docker
Dem then checks the request against
um the docket components and then
performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have the devops
tools that we're looking to use
throughout this series of videos are all
environments that can be scripted and
this is really important because it
allows you to be able to duplicate and
scale the environments that you want to
be able to build very quickly and
effectively the agile container itself
has all of the applications and the
dependencies of those applications in
one package you kind of think of it as a
really effective and efficient zip file
it's a little bit more than that but
it's one file that actually has
everything you need to be able to run
all of your Solutions the actual Docker
registry itself is an environment for
being able to host and distribute
different Docker images among your team
so say for instance you had a team of
developers that were working on multiple
different solutions so say you have a
team of developers and you have 50
developers and they're working on five
different applications you can actually
have the applications themselves the
containers shared in the docker registry
so each of those teams at any time check
out and have the latest container of
that latest image of the code that
you're working on so let's dig into what
actually is in a container so the
important part of a docking container is
that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtual environment it has all your
Frameworks and your libraries and it
allows the teams to be able to build out
and run exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then will run in isolation
so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
and the actual folder itself is much
smaller it's very secure highly portable
and the boot up time is incredibly fast
so let's actually get into how you would
actually create a Docker container so
the docker container itself is actually
built through command line and it's
built over file and Docker image so the
actual Docker file is a text file that
contains all the instructions you would
need to be able to create that Docker
image and then we'll actually then
create all of the project code with
inside of that image then the image
becomes the item that you would share
through the docker registry you would
then use the command line and we'll do
this later on select Docker run and then
the name of the image to be able to
easily and effectively run that image
locally and again once you've created
the document you can store that in the
docker registry making it available to
anybody within your network so something
to bear in mind is that Docker itself
has its own registry called Docker Hub
and that is a public restrict so you can
actually go out and see other Docker
images that have been created and access
those images as your own company you may
want to have your own private repository
so you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of Docker Hardware you
can actually then share those files now
something else it's also very
interesting to know is that you can have
multiple versions of a Docker image so
if you have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your Docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a Docker
image using some of our basic Docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a Docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using nginx as our registry and
we can actually then pull the image down
to our test environment on our local
machine so we're actually running the
container within our Docker application
on a local machine we're able to then
have the image run exactly as it would
in production and then you can actually
use the Run command to actually use the
docker image on your local machine so
just a you know a few interesting
tidbits about the docking container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the docker image layer
is called the container layer each
container has a separate read write
container layer and any changes made in
that docking container is then reflected
upon that particular container layout
and if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also gets
deleted as well so you know why with
using Docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
of software such as the example we gave
with JBoss at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy to share the containers amongst
your teams whether it's a developer
whether it's a tester whether it's
somebody on your operations environment
it's really easy to share those
containers amongst your entire team
different data volumes can be easily
reused and shared among multiple
containers and again this is another big
benefit and this is a reflection of the
lightweight nature of your containers
the the container itself also runs in
isolation which means that it is not
impacted by any dependencies you may
have on your own local environment so
it's a completely sandboxed environment
so some of the questions you might ask
us you know can you run multiple
containers together without the need to
start each one individually and you know
what yes you can with Docker compose
docking compose allows you to run
multiple containers in a single service
and again this is a reflection on the
lightweight nature of containers within
the docker environment so we're going to
end our presentation by looking at some
of the basic commands that you'd have
within Docker so we have here on the
left hand side we have a Docker
container and then the command for each
item we're actually going to go ahead
and use some of these commands and the
demo that we're going to do after this
presentation you'll see that in a moment
moment but just you know some of the
basic commands we have are committing
the docket image into the Container kill
is a you know standard kill command to
you know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stopped
working then restart those containers
but suddenly you can look at all the
image all of the commands here and try
them out for yourself so we're going to
go ahead and start a demo of how to use
the basic commands to run Docker so to
do this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line now depending
whether you're running Linux PC or Mac
and we're going to go ahead and the
first thing we want to do is see what
our Docker image lists are so we can go
sudo Docker images and this will give us
well first we'll enter in our passwords
let's go enter that in and this will now
give us a list of our Docker images and
here are the docker images I have
already been created in the system and
we can actually go ahead and actually
see the processes that are actually
running so I'm going to go ahead and
open up this window a little bit more
but this will show you the actual
processes and the containers that we
actually have and so on the far left
hand side you'll see under names you
have learned simply learn be unscore
cool these are all just different ones
that we've been working on so let's go
ahead and create a Docker image so I'm
going to do sudo
docker
run
Dash D Dash p
0.0.0.0 go on 80 colon 80
Ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run an Ubuntu image and this
will run the latest image and what we
have here is a hash number and this hash
number is a unique name that defines the
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
pseudo.go.ps and this actually show us
down there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exits see so let's do sucker
PS Dash a and this lists all the
containers that I have running on my
machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running State and in the
exit State and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running Ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go so let's change that to that
new dock container to a running state so
scroll down and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
Dash it Dash Dash
name my
um so this is going to be the new
container name it's going to be my
Docker so this is how we name our Docker
environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
Ubuntu
and dash bin Dash Bash
and it's now in our root and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my Docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that Docker
image and let's go ahead and check
against the other running Docker images
to make sure it's running correctly so
sudo docker
PS
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side here you see my Docker
along with the other Docker images that
we created and it's been running for 13
seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another Docker image
this to scrub this one and we'll put it
in rename
and we'll rename I'm putting the old
container name which is image and then
we'll put in the new container name and
let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
previously been called image is now
called Purple
so we do sudo Docker PS
to list all of our Docker images
and if we scroll up and there there we
go purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop container so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my Docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still there as an image it's
just not in an active State just what's
known as an exit state
so here we go
and there's my doco it's in an exited
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
RM
will remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep it's not not listed there on the
exit State anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be all
right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
I think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's going
to kill it
oops no I guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have so
pseudo Docker kill
oh we're gonna list out of the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
I know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo docker kill simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
Docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's they simply learn container is
not active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
Docker container did you know before
Docker and containers were introduced
companies had been deploying their
software either on a bare metal or in a
virtual machine
but they had been facing a lot of
challenges in managing orchestration of
services instant deployment of services
on different platforms and maintaining
multi-host applications
all these issues were solved with the
help of Docker and its containers
in this Docker and container tutorial
session we will give you the conceptual
exposure to Docker and its containers
consider an example where a company
develops a code on Oracle weblogic
software
in the company a developer installs
Oracle weblogic software on his computer
system
once the application is developed he
shares it with the other team for
testing the code now the tester repeats
the weblogic installation process which
was done by the developer earlier on his
system
later the same application file is
shared with the production team
to host the application the system admin
must install Oracle weblogic on his
system
let me ask you an important question
here have you noticed that the same
weblogic installation process was done
Thrice but what could be the reason
behind it due to the difference in
computer environments weblogic doesn't
work on the other systems so
installation is done separately on three
different computers
but this process of installing the same
software on different systems consume a
lot of time and effort in order to avoid
these problems Docker containers were
introduced before we start with the
concept of Docker containers let me
explain you what a Docker is Docker is
an open source platform that helps you
use a package and application and its
dependencies into a Docker container to
develop and deploy software Docker
provides suitable Frameworks for
different applications
since every application has a framework
with an appropriate version this space
also can be utilized for a new software
application along with its required
framework
as a result Docker makes more efficient
use of system resources
containerization includes all
dependencies Frameworks libraries Etc
required to run an application in an
efficient and bug-free manner with
Docker containers applications can work
efficiently in different computer
environments
after this let's talk about the benefits
the benefits of Docker containers show
up in many places
containers are widely used because of
their services since it's lightweight it
can be easily deployed and executed on
other computer environments regardless
of their host operating system or
configurations
containers take up less disk space and
relatively faster in executing
applications
containers run applications in isolation
and also share the operating system
kernel with other containers
by default containers are entirely
secure container policies ensure all
applications are highly secure including
the docker infrastructure containers are
highly portable and can run anywhere
across the docker ecosystem
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
as soon as a container is created it can
be deployed into any other system where
Docker is already installed on that
system the application will perform
exactly as it did in the previous
environment
containers take less put up time these
containers save time in the deployment
process of an application
here comes the next important concept
virtualization
virtualization is the technology of
running a virtual instance of a computer
system or running a virtual version of a
computer resource like Hardware software
storage devices and computer network
resources on the cloud
a virtual machine is an isolated
Computing environment that allows
developers to use an operating system
via a PC or computer system
let's now talk about some of the
significant benefits of using Docker
containers
the first benefit is the lack of
external dependency
containers have no external dependency
for applications to run containers will
just be used to host and run the
applications
as containers are lightweight they are
quickly shipped to other computers and
executed in different computer
environments regardless of their host
operating systems
containers are lightweight they share a
kernel across containers and therefore
use less memory space the next benefit
is the volume volumes are also a
convenient way to share data within the
docker ecosystem
volumes can be more safely shared among
other containers and the last one is
isolation containers run application in
isolation and share the operating system
kernel with other containers in
containers the host operating system
provides isolation along with the
applications microservices can also be
more easily isolated
next comes the most important topic of
the session that is containerization
versus virtualization
containerization and virtualization are
two different ways to deploy
applications and microservices in a
computer environment in VMS a hypervisor
is a firmware layer that enables
multiple operating system to run side by
side a virtual machine has unstable
performance as multiple running VMS run
simultaneously on the same machine
also the efficiency of hypervisors is
not as good as that of the host
operating system
due to the extra layer in VM an
application takes quite a long time to
start
as you can see there are two
architectures on the screen on the left
hand side is VM and on the right hand
side is the docker on the left hand side
as you see there is one host operating
system a hypervisor and guest operating
system shared by all containers along
with their dependencies
VM guest operating system occupies more
space and leads to unstable performance
guest operating system makes virtual
machines less efficient than the
physical machines
guest operating system makes a VM slope
because they access the hardware
indirectly
on the other hand Docker is efficient
unlike VMS Docker doesn't have a
hypervisor or guest operating system
Docker consists of containers these
containers are efficient and are easily
portable across different Platforms in
VMS the hypervisor has a scalability
issue the hypervisor creates a security
risk as well
well did you know that according to
vitana the chances of experiencing a
data breach while using virtualization
are high
well that could lead to a major problem
for companies who are still using
virtual machines
next let's have a closer look at the
docker containers
in case you are unsure what kind of
applications can be added to a container
then look on the right hand side
a container can package Apache tomcat
and its dependency that is Java
programming language in a single file
later a user can ship the container to
another computer environment and run the
code without any issue
it's usually challenging to understand
the differences between container and VM
so let me explain to you the differences
in layman terms
shown the virtual machine is compared to
a bungalow and the container is
considered as an apartment
in a bung law amenities like water left
roof Etc cannot be shared with the
neighbors likewise VM is less efficient
it doesn't share its resources with
other applications
on the other hand containers share their
amenities binaries and libraries with
the neighboring containers just like a
person who resides in an apartment
the bank law is owned by a single person
it cannot have tenants
likewise virtual machines cannot run
multiple applications on the other side
Docker runs multiple containers just
like numerous Finance reside in a single
building next let's look at the table in
which we have made a direct comparison
between virtual machines and containers
in Docker containers data volumes can be
shared and reused among multiple
containers
either Docker CLI or Docker API manages
the volumes
also the volume drivers give the
facility of storing volumes on remote
hosts or Cloud providers
VM is a container based model it
utilizes user space along with the
kernel space of an operating system
so data volumes cannot be shared
containers have a better performance as
they are hosted in a single Docker
engine
Docker provides the most substantial
default isolation capabilities among the
other configuration tools making the
performance better
virtual machines run multiple VMS at a
time which leads to unstable performance
Docker is much more efficient than
hypervisors Docker enables developers to
wrap
quickly and run applications as a
lightweight and portable container
on the other hand virtual machines are
less efficient
Docker containers can run multiple
containers on a system but virtual
machine can run only a limited number of
VMS on a system
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
containers are easily portable across
other platforms but virtual machines
have compatibility issues while porting
others across different platforms
moving on to the next one let's have a
look at the architecture of docker a
Docker or Docker engine consists of two
major components Docker client and dock
Daemon these two components are
connected to each other with the help of
the rest API now let's take a look at
the architecture a Docker client has no
components but a Docker Daemon consists
of a Docker host Docker Daemon Docker
registry and Docker images
Docker client is a service that uses
rest API to send commands to Docker
demon through CLI commands rest API is a
primary mode of communication between
Docker client and Docker Daemon Docker
engine or Docker is a client server
application that builds and executes
containers using Docker components
Docker demon checks the client's request
and communicates with the docker
components to perform a service
dock engine or Docker is a client server
application that builds and executes
containers using Docker components
Docker image is also one of the
essential components of docker
a Docker image is a file of instructions
that are used to create containers a
Docker image is built using a file
called Docker file
a Docker image is a template of
instructions that is used to create
containers
coming to containers
a Docker container is a portable
executable package that includes
applications and their dependencies
Docker containers are lightweight
because they do not require an extra
layer of a hypervisor and run directly
on the host operating system
there is a service in Docker called
Docker compose
a Docker compose is used for running
multiple containers as a single service
in compose service each container runs
in isolation but can interact with each
other with no limitations
talking about Docker registry it is a
service used for hosting and
distributing Docker images among users
Docker registry is a service to host and
distribute Docker matches among users
let's move on and understand how to
create a Docker container
first ensure to set up your development
environment then you can begin to
develop containerized applications
for that you need to create a Docker
image a Docker image can be created
using a Docker file a Docker Mage is
created using a build command
you must build a Docker image that
contains the code of what your
application needs to run
in simple terms a Docker image contains
all the Project's code
with Docker image you can run the code
to develop Docker containers
once the docker image is created ensure
to store it in the docker registry using
the docker push command
once a Docker image is created you can
either store it in a Docker Hub or in a
repository
Docker also has its default registry
called Docker hub
there are multiple Docker images
available in the registry and all can be
retrieved through the docker pull
command
as soon as a Docker image is retrieved
from the docker registry you can build
new containers
moving on to the next one let's
understand how Docker containers work
in Docker a Docker file is used to build
the image using the build command and
that image is stored in the registry
using the push command when you run the
pull command Docker image is retrieved
from the registry while a single
container is built using Docker image
through the Run command
did you know that a new layer is formed
on top of the docker image layers called
the container layer when a container is
created
this new layer consists of the
application and its dependencies
in Docker each container has a separate
read or write container layer
any modifications done in a Docker
container are reflected upon the
container layer
suppose a container is deleted the
container layer also gets permanently
deleted
this was the simple functionality of
Docker and containers in this one we are
going to see that how we can make use of
the docker files to prepare a Docker
image and using which we can create a
Docker container now let's talk about
what exactly is in Docker file here now
uh Docker file is a concept which is
being used as in build script so it's
being used so that we can have a build a
script there so this will definitely
helps to see that how we can go for a
build of a Docker image a custom Docker
image now when we are using the docker
file concept so it really helps to
prepare a kind of Docker image
so doc image is the end result when you
are going for the mechanism when you're
going for the docker file build up here
so Docker file is a build script which
is available for preparing the custom
Docker containers because not every
Docker image is available on Docker Hub
so some containers you have to use some
images you have to use to work on that
part
now Docker file is a very simple
straightforward text file which is
available there and it's basically used
to build up custom Docker images so
Docker file is basically used to prepare
a once so when you're running the docker
build so it's actually going to build up
a particular custom Docker image and
that will be given to you so Docker
image is the whole build process which
is being done so it's a custom process
which is available and being done over
here in this case
so you got a Docker file you run the
docker build command and that's how you
will be able to get a Docker image so
whatever these steps you are having in
the docker file that will be processed
one by one and as a end result you will
be able to get a full flash Docker image
over here in this case right now let's
talk about the syntax of the docker file
so Docker file is equal to commands
commands and the arguments so whatever
the things you want to put up so in the
docker file you can do that and as a
part of the execution so you will be
able to get a particular end result
now it's a kind of a mechanism where we
feel that how the execution and the
modifications can be done so uh the
comments which we are trying to do over
here is that you know we can put up the
whatever the comments we want to put in
the case of Docker files we can do that
comments is a standard process in uh
preparing any particular file or any
kind of code because it helps us to
understand that for what reason we are
preparing that particular line then uh
we have the uh particular run statements
the commands are there so you can see
that we are running a particular command
called Eco so using the Run attribute we
are basically going ahead and running a
particular command into our system as
part of our Docker file over here
now how to build up the docker images
using the docker file so um you know
Docker file is uh just a template which
is available there where we are putting
up that what are the different steps we
want to follow and these steps when we
follow one by one step by step so that's
where we will be able to get a
particular final Docker container over
here so Docker image is getting
converted as in Docker container and we
are getting a Docker container as an end
result
now Docker file is being built up and uh
stored in the version control system and
uh this particular Docker files when we
are processing So It prepares a
respective a specific uh image layer
over here and this image layer is
something which is uh benefiting us that
how the executions can be done and how
we can manage on that part so
that really helps us to see that how the
executions and the things can be managed
and that can help us to see that how the
management of the things can be
performed as such
so uh Docker file is a very good concept
which is there using which you can
prepare any kind of custom Docker image
and it can be very easily handled also
and it's a fully automated mechanism you
can use it inside the cicd pipelines for
automating the docker images right now
its Docker image is a layer by layer
mechanism which is there in which we
have multiple layers each and every
layer we are doing some specific entries
some specific tasks or some you know
changes we are trying to deploy in part
of Earth is layers right so uh you can
use the particular Docker build command
to perform the executions and you will
be able to get any particular response
an output will be given back to you so
Docker file is basically helping you to
see that how the executions can be done
and you will be able to get an end
result over here so the docker image is
the final result which we are getting
when we are talking about the docker
file here
right so these are all read-only formats
which is available you cannot modify
these directly but yes with the help of
Docker file you can do whatever the
changes you want to deploy on these
Docker images
right so uh this is a small example
where we are using a base image as an
Ubuntu 18.04 so we are using the from
attribute to specify that yes we are
going to use the Ubuntu 18.04 k then we
are pulling our uh the file into the uh
directory we are transferring a
particular file inside the docker
container and then we are running our
make Command and then CMD attribute is
there using which we can run the command
on the runtime on the docker container
so these are a very basic example but
eventually when we are done with this
Docker image we will be able to get a
four layer uh Docker image over here
because there are four steps and then
hence it will be providing you a
particular four layers in your final
Docker image over here so layer by layer
these changes will be done during the
build process and in fact using the
docker history command you can see that
layers these layers information also
right so layer 1 is Ubuntu 18.04 layer 2
is pull and uh the third layer is there
where we can run the uh make command to
you know run this file which we have
pulled on and then the finally the last
one is there where we are running like
using the CMD parent so uh the
difference between run and CMD is that
CMD will run only when you run a Docker
container so run attribute will be
executed during the docker build part so
this is a pretty much is a way that how
we can go for the execution of a Docker
file and how you know we can go for the
build up of a custom Docker image over
here so these are the for some couple of
attributes which we are using in the
docker file here
right now let's talk about the entry
point over here now entry point allows
you to specify a command along with the
parameters right so uh let's say that
you want to run a particular command uh
over here in the docker container so
entry point is something which you can
use to refer to that so application is
the command which you're trying to run
and then you can give some arguments to
that and argument one is what you're
trying to run over here so entry point
is very important because that
eventually helps to see that how the
executions can be done and the
implementations will be done over here
in this case
right so you can see like you can run a
command called Eco and then you can use
the parameters also it's not like only
the commands can be used but you can in
fact use the arguments also now add is
an attribute which is available in the
docker file which is primary used to see
to transfer the files from the host
machine inside the docker image
now let's see that you are trying to
prepare your own custom Docker image
apart from the dependencies you need the
source code also right so the source
code needs to be transferred inside the
docker image and for that reason we can
use the add attribute so add our
attribute requires a source and
destination Source will always be the
path on which uh on the testing on the
host machine the files are present so we
can give that
and destination is the folder which is
available inside the particular Docker
container where we want to store the
files so you can use the example over
here just like this you can use and you
can give two entries one is the source
one is the destination and once that is
done so you will be able to see your
files being stored up in the destination
directory once the final Docker image is
prepared
then we have a and b attribute uh now e
and B is something which is used to set
up some environment variables which is
required of course for the docker image
uh for the application which is running
inside the docker image now environment
variables are something which you can
hardcore during the docker build one but
using the when you are running like when
you're creating the docker container at
that time also you can write the these
environment variables so environment
variables are very important because uh
first during the build process you can
hard code some values but if you really
want to change them during the runtime
that also is being supported by the
environment variables so
most of the times we use it as a kind of
a keep value pay just like in in Linux
we use we used to set up a particular
environment variable so the key value
pair is being used in case of ENB
attribute maintainer is there where we
can describe that what is the details
about the author these are the fields
which is available in the top so where
we can give the the author name and the
author you know details like email ID
and all so that we know that who is the
person who is maintaining this a
particular file and we can reach out to
them in case any issues are there for
the docker files am right so that is
what we have here in this one so now we
are going to see that how we can go for
a small demo in Docker file and we can
go for the implementation of this
particular Docker file and prepare a
custom Docker image so let's just wait
on that part
so let's see some demo here now in this
one we have got two examples one is a
python one is the node.js one so first
of all what we need to do is that we
need to process the python one here so
this is the sample Docker file which we
have got here for the python now all
this one requires a python file which is
already present on the server and we are
going to transfer we are going to copy
this content over here that will this is
the specific Docker file content which
is available to us and all we need to do
is that we need to put this content
across the server so that we will be
able to build our custom Docker image so
let's go back to the server so here we
have already got the python file which
is present so we have to create a Docker
file here which will have the steps
related to the docker image preparation
over here so we will be including some
steps over here that these are the
different steps we want to configure we
want to set up over here in this one so
python 3.6.4 is the version of the
Python which we want to configure and
then we are going to transfer some files
into slash app we are also setting up
the working directory AS Slash app and
ultimately we are running a command
called install flask to do the
installation of flask package and then
we are starting the specific
applications on that part so I'm going
to save this file and once I save this
file so all we need to do is that we
need to create a custom Docker image
right so right now there is no image
which is available over here and it's in
complete FD installs so I'm going to run
a command called docker
build
hyphen e python hyphen amp dot so Docker
build is the typical command but hyphen
T is for the tag that what kind of
Docker image you want to build and then
now we are giving a image name and then
we are specifying dot over there now
once we are done with that so it will
pick up all the things one by one the
basic Docker image is being pulled down
then some sequence of steps is being
executed so it's a step-by-step process
which is happening over here in this
case and we are then transferring some
files in the slash app and then
ultimately we are going for the PIP
install flask so it's installing those
packages and at the end the final Docker
image will be prepared and will be given
back to us so we will be able to get
this uh Docker images over here when we
run that command we will be able to find
out that we got our custom Docker image
also available and as you can see that
the base of Docker image is also
available in this one but yes we have
added up like around 10 MB of work we
have added on top of this python base
Docker image here so that's how we are
able to do the processing over here in
this case in this setup so that's what
we can do to prepare a custom
environment of python with the help of
the docker file here now let's see that
we will be proceeding on with the
node.js to see that if the node.js kind
of setup also can be done now for
node.js again of course we got the
specific Docker file which is present so
we can process that but let's create a
new folder over there so I'm going to
create for a new node.js folder so that
we can create the work all together in
this one so I'm going to run a command
called npminute which is the comma to
initialize any empty project in case of
node now you can typically bring down
some real code also or you can say that
I want to process an empty a project so
you can give the configurations you can
give the custom names but I want to
process with these as default name
itself so ultimately it's going to
create an entries now like uh you will
be able to see like all these uh values
which we are not providing these
standards value will be picked up for
the uh specific code and at the end you
will be able to get a package.json file
created over here in this one now you
can actually bring down the steps that
how you can perform or you can build up
a custom node.js based Docker image now
these Docker files is giving you the
capability that you can convert a
full-fledged application which is
Deployable on the virtual machine you
can actually convert them in the format
of the docker containers over here in
this one so that's what we are going to
get over here with this uh particular
setup or these mechanisms so let's go
back to the document and see that what
exactly we can copy the docker file so
we have got this Docker file over here
so all we can do is that we can copy
this one so once we copy this uh
specific file here so all we can do is
that we can transfer these files into
the onto the server we can convert it
into the docker file there so that we
will be able to set up the
configurations and we can perform the
setup around that so Docker file is
again we want to create and we want to
set up on that here so let's go back to
the server
so here we want to create a Docker file
and we want to set up the files inside
that these are the different files which
is being available which is being
configured over here in this one so we
are running like node server.js which is
a master file so we are doing an exposed
of 8080 then of course we have copy
commands which is there then npm install
command is there and then package.json
file is also there now what you need to
really do is that you need to go for a
server.js file which is available in
which you can configure that how the
setup needs to be done and how the
configurations should be performed there
because that's a command that's a script
which is going to be executed within the
container so let's copy the content now
I'm going to copy this content over here
which is like a sample node.js code
which is available so I'm just copy this
one and transfer it to the server
so server.js file we have to create here
just like we did in case of the Python
because this is the source we want to
transfer inside the docker container so
this is what we have got now I'm going
to transfer like uh I want to change
this port value from 5000 to 8080
because that's what it's configured in
the docker file of course you can
configure 5000 also depending on your
requirement you can do that
configurations now you have got uh these
two files over here in this one so all
you need to do is that you need to run
like Docker build
hyphen T node.js hyphen app and Dot so
it will automatically pick up like what
exactly it will uh you know go for the
node.js basic Docker image over here so
that will be processed over here in this
one so step by step it will be able to
do the configurations
so first of all it will download the
basic Docker image which is um quite uh
more in size over here in this one once
it's downloaded onto your system then it
will proceed further with the build
activity on processing the docker file
performing the execution so all that
stuff will be performed with this help
of this Docker build process over here
so it's going to process it one by one
in this one
and it's going to the next step where
it's transferring some of the files like
creating some working directory
transferring the files uh putting up
there and running the npm install
command and uh then ultimately it will
expose the port and then it will have
the CMD attribute configured over there
so this is basically typically trying to
portray it how a particular Docker image
can be built up and of course once the
build is Success you can validate it
with the help of Docker images here so
this is the app Docker image which has
been prepared of 911 MB and we have got
it like a final package where the
runtime is also there and the code base
is also available now you can pretty
much
experience it like with other actual
Source codes like you can generate the
download some pre-configured node.js
websites or the source codes there and
you can try to run them onto the docker
container so that you can get the full
uh the complete idea about that how it
goes on but right now the uh these are
the basic Docker image which you can
prepare and you can build up over here
in this one so that's how it really
works on for you let's dig into what a
Docker swarm is so a Docker swarm is
essentially a tool that allows you to
very easily create and schedule multiple
Docker nodes so really two or more
Docker nodes and you can have quite a
large number of Docker nodes in a single
swarm each node itself is actually a
Docker demon and that demon is able to
interact with the docker API and have
all the benefits of being a full Docker
environment one of the other advantages
you have is that the each duck container
within the Swarm camera and then be
deployed and managed but as a node in
that entire clustered environment so
what we have here is a breakdown of the
five key elements within a Docker
environment you have the docker
container you have the Daemon the docker
images and the docker client and Docker
registry so the docker Daemon itself is
what does all the work interacting with
the actual host operating system to be
able to manage the docker containers so
if we look here here we have set up an
environment where we have three docket
container being run with Docker and what
we want to be able to do is be able to
interact with the environment because
what would happen if we actually have
something change in our environment so
we have the environment set up there's a
Docker swarm and one of our containers
fails what we're able to do is use the
Swarm to be able to correct that failure
so the docker swarm manager is able to
come in and and reschedule containers
and as you would imagine the actual
swarm note has full backups and full
redundancy for any kind of failures that
would happen and we would do all of this
work through command line interface so
let's go through some of the features
that you have within the actual Docker
swarm itself so a key feature for
dockersworm is that it is fully
decentralized which means that it makes
it very easy for teams to be able to
access and manage the environment as you
would expect as well is that the
communication that happens between the
manager and client nodes within the
swamp is highly secure and of course
this is really just a fundamental that
you should have for any kind of solution
but it is good to know that Docker swarm
has that built in there is also Auto
load balancing within your environment
and you can actually script that into
how you write out and structure your
swarm environment and that load
balancing then also allows you to then
and convert that swarm environment into
a highly scalable infrastructure and
then rollback task allows you to be able
to roll back environments to previous
safe environments so say something does
get pushed out and something breaks
you're able to immediately roll back
into a safe environment so each of the
containers are pushed out and and are
controlled using services and they
actually happen to be breast Services
which make it very easy for you to be
able to integrate within your
environment and each of the different
Services contains a group of containers
of the same image Now by having this
structure it allows you to be able to
scale your application appropriate to
the demands on your server so if you
have a service that needs to have a
significantly larger number of services
for it to run you can actually scale
that appropriately and they can be
either Geo or demand based one of the
requirements for setting up a double
swarm is you must have it least one node
deployed so the way that the
architecture is set up is that you have
a manager node and a client node then
there must be one of each for the entire
environment to be able to work
effectively so you know here we are just
jumping ahead of sales a little bit we
have two types of nodes in a Docker
swamp we have the manager node and we
have the worker node which is the client
that does the actual execution of the
tasks the manager knows very similar to
other systems that we've talked about on
simply learn allows you to actually
control and manage the actual tasks that
are being executed by the worker nodes
and the worker nodes as you can imagine
and then actually execute the
instructions that the manager are
sending out to it so here we have a
situation where we can illustrate what
would happen with a manager node sending
out commands to different worker nodes
the manager is fully aware of the status
of the entire swarm environment at all
times this is because of the two-way
secure communication that's going from
the manager to the work environment the
workers as you'd expect are accepting
tasks that are being sent from the
manager so the manager sends out a task
saying that you need to be running as a
MySQL environment then the work and node
will then convert to a MySQL environment
and all of these environments are
scripted and controlled by you as the
manager the actual worker nodes
themselves actually have a client agent
and that client will then communicate
all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that anytime the manager node is in full
control of the entire swarm the major is
the controller of this environment and
so you always want to be able to ensure
that the manager has full access to all
the work that's happening within the
Swarm and this allows you as the manager
to be able to control your swarm and
very quickly be able to react to any
changes without having to rely on manual
installations of software and hardware
and as we covered earlier on there is a
rest API that uses the communication
over HTTP from the manager to the worker
node it's interesting to note that it is
a rest API because if you wanted to you
could actually integrate that API into
custom applications and even then create
automated Docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big Advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the form any of the
services that you create can be accessed
by any node of the same cluster one of
the things you do have to do though is
you have to specify what container image
that you're going to use when you're
creating a new servers and you can do
that either through a centralized Docker
Hub environment or through your own
private Docker Hub environment one of
the things that's interesting is that
you can set up commands and services to
be either Global or replicated a global
Service will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
Swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey is it a
service and task the same thing no that
they're kind of not in the docker world
and the difference is is a service is a
description of a task for the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get done and that's the
differentiator here so what you can do
as a Docker user is you actually create
services and then you can then Define
when you want them to start as tasks now
what's interesting is that when you do
assign a task to a node that same task
cannot be assigned to another node also
what's interesting is that you can
actually have multiple managers within a
Docker swarm environment if you do
however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really similar in
concept to worker nodes in which they
have the capability of a manager but
they are dependent on that single
primary manager to be able to provide
the right instructions and for services
and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our store
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their IP address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager node to
be able to check for when tasks come in
so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manual know to
the work note so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build all right so
with that said let's go ahead and we're
going to do a demo so we're going to go
ahead and do a demo and showing how you
can run Docker Swan for this you'll need
to have both a virtual environment
running your manager and you're working
in environment so here we have our
worker and here we have our manager so
we're just going to open up terminal
window and we're going to go into the
manager for terminal window so the
following command here is used to
initialize Docker Swan which is going to
type this in so sudo Docker swamp in it
and we purchased the IP address for the
network we're connecting to
open in our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and we want
to be able to highlight is the specific
token which identifies the docker swarm
environment and this is our token right
here so we're going to copy that
because we'll need to use that for our
workout environment so here we are in
the worker environment and we'll use the
token that we just copied
um as a way to be able to connect to the
manager and connect to the docker swarm
environment
and so sudo
I'll paste in the darker swarm and we'll
join that I will now here we shows that
we have joined the Swarm environment as
a worker
and now we're in the manager we can
actually show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's Docker node LS to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually depended or wrong area
so we want to write pseudo Docker node
allows to list out all the nodes in the
Swarm and there you are you see we've
actually connected the worker to the
manager node and both are active and the
manager is the leader and the worker
virtualbox is in the swan
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so Dr Swan create and
we're going to just change the name to
hello world for the new service and we
use the Alpine image from docker.com
takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go Services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new Hello World
Service
and we go ahead and check the docking
containers and we're going to do Docker
PS and
here's our Alpine it's running the
latest image
and that's the docker container ID
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or continue to created because it's not
in the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we'll make the Mode Global and that
way the surface is available across all
of the Swarm
so we're just going to execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different IDs which shows the
two different Services running and if we
go back to the working mode and we run
sudo.go PS again and there we are now we
see that we have the hello world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of Alpine and we also
have the new token ID for that
if we want to kill a node from the Swarm
we can use the following command which
is pseudo Docker swamp leave dash dash
force and that will force the node to
leave the Swarm one of the questions
that will come up though is what if you
want to use two containers in a single
service and an example of this might be
like a web server that is using a
database but the database may be in one
container and the web server may be in
another container which is very typical
for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar I'm sorry
but how would you do this with dark app
so when I usually just Docker itself
it's actually very difficult to do this
you can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with Docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have Docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
Docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they they were running in a
production environment so let's dig into
what Docker compose is so let's consider
a scenario that you'd have today so
Mitra is a fashion website similar to
Amazon and you go to myntra with your
web browser and on that website you
would go through a number of activities
such as logging into your account
browsing a catalog you'd have your
checkout application server and you go
through the table process of building
out an application behind each of these
services are different products such as
you know to have an account database you
have a product database different
checkout processes and these would all
be run behind the scenes and each of
these can be considered a micro service
so the more microservices you build into
your environment the more complexity
you're adding and the more of value it
would be to have each of these services
in their own container but as a
developer you want to be able to jump
from one container to another container
so your login account can then be passed
on to your product catalog and then be
able to move through the whole process
so the environment that you would see
today would be small like what we're
showing right now where you'd have your
server and your database and you may
have a server running on an Apache
Tomcat or a SQL Server you'd have
different databases and you'd want to be
able to have each of those in their own
containerized environment so the way
that duck compose runs is that it works
as a single service so you have the
docker compose running multiple
containers but the perception is of a
single service run the thing that's
great though is that each of those
containers will run in there in
isolation and but they can interact with
each other so unlike a normal Docker
environment where you have multiple
Docker images running completely in
isolation of each other these are images
that will run in isolation but can
interact with each other the docker
compose files are very easy to write
they're all written with a scripting
language called yaml and yaml is an XML
based language it actually stands for
yet another markup language but it's an
XML based language and it's very easy to
use the great thing about learning yaml
is that a lot of Open Source tools in
the devops environment use yaml as the
scripting layer and then finally in
Docker compose as a user you can
actually go and and Trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single camera on as you can
imagine there's dramatically reduces the
amount of work that you as a developer
have to do so let's take an example of
if you're running a container one with a
nijex server and one with a redis
database uh you can create a yaml docket
compose file that actually has the
instructions on the containers needed to
build out both environments and then you
can run each of those environments
separately but have them connected as a
single service so the benefits of duck
and compose is that you have a single
host deployment environment you can run
this all on one piece of Hardware you
can have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get has developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional Docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level security
that you'd have with a traditional
Docker image but there is a question
here around Docker compose isn't it
similar in concept to Docker swarm
because at a high level it kind of seems
like both do the same thing and the
answer is well you actually know they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
Solutions so let's look at Docker
compose so Docker compose will allow you
to create multiple containers on a
single host and that's the important
part of being a single host which is
maybe your development PC with Docker
swarm it also allows you to create
multiple containers however you have to
manage those multiple containers on
multiple hosts which makes a lot of
sense if you're running an operations
environment but not so much if you're
doing a development environment and
Docker compose is scripted with yaml
which is very easy for you to be able to
control your scripts Docker swarm
doesn't have a scripting technology like
yaml so it's a little bit harder to work
with so what we have here is just some
basic commands that allow you to get up
and started working with Docker compose
in our next demo we're actually going to
take you through how to use all of those
commands so we're going and go ahead and
do a demo on how to use Docker compose
and the first thing you want to do is
check that you have Docker installed so
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the command window and we're
going to type in Docker you'll be able
to see now that we have Docker installed
if you don't have dog installed go ahead
and install Docker you can go to Google
Search to install Docker and it'll give
you the instructions for that we also
have videos that we've already done if
once you have dock installed then you
want to do a Google search on Docker
compose or go to the docker.com website
and select for the compose section and
look for the install Docker compose
instructions so we already have another
tab which has the instructions already
installed you'll see on the left hand
side there are a number of Docker tools
you want to expand the docket compose
section select install compose and then
on the right hand side you'll have
different install options for Mac
windows and Linux if you're installing
on those platforms make sure you copying
the correct command line so there's a
couple command ones you want to copy
copy the first one over and we paste
that in and it's going to go ahead and
download all of the files for compose it
takes a while but uh we have to get
another file so while it's downloading
we'll go get the other command line just
go back and grab it real quick so it's a
little faster but we'll copy that over
there was a second command instruction
and post that command yep there's the
command right there and that will apply
the appropriate binary and once you've
done that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of Docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
Docker Dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version build that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
that different version number depending
on how old the video is when you're
watching it but they're using very
content at the moment and just go ahead
and clear the screen and now what we're
going to do is create a folder where
we're actually going to install the yaml
file that will have the instructions for
our docking compose environment so we're
moving the cursor to the desktop and on
the desktop we're going to create a new
folder and using the MK Dev command and
we'll call this one Docker compose f for
file and then we'll move the cursor into
that new folder by using CD command and
now we are in the folder called Docker
compose F and you can go look at your
desktop and you'll see it's there and
now you want to select and pound touch
Docker Dash compose Dot yml and that
will actually create the new yaml file
for you and you can use the ls list
command LS Docker Dash compose.yaml and
they'll allow you actually now to step
in and edit that file so let's go ahead
and hit return and they'll allow us to
go in and edit the file so now I'm in
the editor and I'm going to write some
instructions
um so I'm I'm going to put a couple of
mistakes in these instructions so we can
see how Docker pose catches those
mistakes and so but most this is going
to be fairly correct so you can just
type this out so we're going to start
with Services colon then we do a web
colon and then we create image colon and
we'll do ninjas and then we'll do a
database colon and we'll call the image
redis and so what you can see because we
have two reference images we're actually
calling two different images two
different containers that will be
created by Docker Hub so what we're
going to do is uh where we can actually
show you how that's pulling in you can
go to Docker Hub and you can actually
see the references to the images that
we've just created so go to Docker Hub
which is Hub hub.docker.com and you'll
see that uh ninjix redis those are the
default names for the images so you
could do other images like HTP for
Apache web server if you wanted to there
are a lot of images in Docker Hub so
certainly have a lot of fun building
tools from that environment so we're
going to save those files in the dock
image and we're just going to do colon
WQ to exit this screen I save the text
and let's go and run our yaml file and
you'll see the two different error
messages that will come up so we're
going to do cat Docker Dash compose Dot
yml and here we have a display of the
text that we just wrote and now let's go
check the validity of the file that we
just created so we'll do Docker Dash
compose config and we should get an
error message and there we are error
message and the reason why we have an
error message is because the spacing is
not correct in the yaml file itself so
let's go to the actual yaml file that we
created let's go through and we're going
to use uh just the file finder and
you'll actually open up the yaml file in
your text and see your favorite text
editor and here we have um the code that
created it and let's use the correct
spacing so that everything is spaced out
appropriately in the image and so this
is the spacing that you'd expect to see
a space a line between surfaces and the
first image and the first image is a tab
in and then it reference what the image
is and let's go ahead and clear the
screen and we'll see whether or not
we've got that all correct this clear
screen and we're going to check that
everything is running correctly and
we're seeing we're still getting an
error message and the reason why we're
getting another error is that there's
still a config error in this the actual
yaml file so one of the things you have
to do when you're creating a yaml file
for Docker composers you actually have
to have the appropriate version number
in there so what we have to do is we
have to go and find which is the
appropriate version and there are three
major versions one two and three
depending on the age of Docker that you
have installed on your computer so if
you have the very latest version of
Docker 18 and newer you would put 3.7 as
a version number and what we're going to
do is we're going to just check on the
version that we have installed and so
just clear the screen and then we'll
just do Docker version and what we have
is our version of Dockers as 17.12 now
this is the version of Docker not Docker
compose it's your main Docker
environment and so if we go back to our
web browser we'll actually see that
version 17 should align with version
number 3.5 yep there we are version 3.5
so what we want to do is go back into
our yaml file and the very first line
that we want to put in above the server
is the version number and that version
number we're going to put in is 3.5 so
we type in version version and we'll put
colon and then version number is in
price in quotes and you save that and
now what we can actually do is we can
actually go ahead and use the single
line instruction to run both of these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way the
docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then push the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo Docker Dash compose D
and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database experiment and let's
use pseudo Docker PS to actually list
out that all the processes that are
running right now and there we are we
actually see all of the images are
running we have the names the commands
the images and everything's up and
running and if we want to close both of
those images we can actually use a
single line of command as well and that
command will be pseudo Docker Dash
compose down and that closes both of the
images and we can see that all the
databases and the web services images
have been closed and sudo Docker PS will
actually list that there is nothing
running and that's how to use Docker
compose why exactly the docker
networking is it important let's talk
about some scenario over here so my
application is something which totally
works perfectly fine into my system and
there is no issues on there I ran it
perfectly fine and I got the response
I'm able to interact everything I'm able
to do but the same application does not
works on the other person's system now
what could be the issue because it's
working on one machine and it's not
working on another machine now the
application does not work on another
system because there is a difference in
the computer systems maybe one system is
having a different machine and another
system is having a different machine and
you may be having some of the
differences maybe in the term of
Hardware maybe in the terms of software
so the differences are possible in two
different machines so how we can get a
solution that we don't get this kind of
problems and once the container is
prepared it should be able to run it
across different systems so Docker
networking is the ideal solution for
this problem over here with Docker
networking the application works totally
fine and it's something which can work
on any system you don't have any
dependency that it will run only on a
specific machine or a particular system
so what exactly is in Docker networking
all about so Docker networking enables a
user to link a Docker container to as
many as networks you know he or she
requires so you can actually connect a
Docker container to a specific Network
the docker networks are used to provide
complete isolation to the docker
containers so you can have it like okay
I want to run some couple of containers
in a different network and another
containers I want to run it into a
different networks so you can do that
isolations and the whole purpose of
doing that isolation is so that we will
be able to have a proper networking and
proper executions and all that stuff so
Docker networking is a very important
concept when we talk about or when we
come up with the interaction on having
the docker containers isolated so it
resolves most of the problems okay so
you can have like multiple containers in
running in same network you can have a
different uh particular networks also
there so a specific Network
have its own attributes and then you can
use those attributes to connect to that
containers and to access that containers
but the whole idea is that the
containers are something which is uh
specifically running in a set of servers
or in a set of uh platform so whenever
I'm trying to look forward to that
particular container it has to be there
into a swim network if you don't run it
into your custom Network then whatever
the default or network present it will
be hosted in that Network there so how
does the docker networking actually
works so you got a Decor file so using
the docker file you got up a custom
Docker image and from this Docker image
you have to actually go there and you
know put up like the docker container so
you can also store this Docker image to
the docker Hub so that the same Docker
image can be shared across different
users and they can also pull down their
Docker image and they can have the
container running in their systems so
for the collaborating the docker image
you require the algorithm and the
container is the ultimate thing or
object which we need to create out of
the docker image when we go with the
particular process when the whole
process goes on over there so what
happens that the instead of the docker
Hub you can use your own private
repositories also that's something which
totally relies on to you that how
exactly those things works on so a
Docker file creates a Docker image using
the build command a Docker image
contains all the project source code all
the dependencies uh using this Docker
image you can actually run the source
code in order to get a Docker container
the moment you initialize or running
instance of Docker image you will be
able to get a Docker container you can
actually use the docker hub for
collaborating or for sharing the docker
image so you can store the docker image
on Docker Hub and then different people
can actually go ahead and download or
pull this Docker image onto their system
and they can also run their specific
containers so what are the different
advantages we get with the docker
networking verify first one is the rapid
deployment portability better efficiency
a faster configuration scalability and
the security over here so these are some
of the advantages which we get when we
talk about the docker networking here
now let's talk about the container
Network model here so what is the
network model we are looking forward
from the containers perspective now this
is a kind of a architecture here now in
this one let's see that how it actually
works on now you have a Docker engine
which is a main component which takes up
all the things and all the important
components are actually integrated with
each other now the network sandbox is
the one in which you will be having your
container running up and running now
every network is having its own
attributes the particular different
Gateway IPS the IP addresses the range
of IP address the cidr blocks also
everything can be different to for two
different networks so the whole point is
that you will be defining okay if you
don't Define that I want to run this
particular container into a specific
Network then definitely that's going to
run into default Network which is which
gets created the moment you do the
installation of Dockers but anyhow any
network is required for running a Docker
container so there are different network
drivers which is available there so if
you feel that you want to create a
network so you have to choose a
particular networking or the
connectivity over there and it really
helps us to understand how the
configurations and how the different
modifications and those changes can be
really done here so a lot of changes are
actually going on and uh you know
performing there and this really helps
us to understand that how the things are
being done as such over there so network
is something which is very important
from the container's perspective so the
network sandbox is in kind of a isolated
sandbox that holds the all the network
configurations of the containers so you
will be requiring at least one Docker
container network if you want to run a
container inside in that particular
sandbox so sandbox is created when a
user requests to generate an endpoint on
the network so that's where the sandbox
gets created it can have several
endpoints in a network as it represents
a container's network configurations
like IP address Mac address DNS name so
every container will be having its own
unique IP address right so that can be a
particular endpoint to connect to that
container and it can have it like
different uh endpoints and different
different networks so that's always the
possibilities which is available there
now the endpoints establishes the
connectivity for the container services
with other services also so the moment
you work on the uh particular endpoints
so that can be used for having okay
there is a service running in a
container so how you can do that so if
in order to connect that you require
these endpoints so that you can
establish the connectivity with the
container services whatever running
inside these Docker containers
right now the network is something which
provides the specific underlining
Network attributes like the networking
support to the docker containers because
these uh Network sandbox uh boxes will
definitely have a requirement of the
network so how you're going to get that
that you will be only able to get when
you go okay I will be looking forward
for the connectivity and I can go for
the communications and I can give the
hardware because although it's a OS
level virtualization but still you
require some interaction with the
hardware from the networking perspective
and then Docker engine is uh the base
engine which is installed on the host
machine and it's actually the main
component which makes sure that the
docker containers and the corresponding
Docker services are always up and
running and the uh using the network
drivers you can actually create multiple
networks onto your system and you can
have those uh configurations now the
network architecture is something which
helps us to provide the connectivity
among the endpoints that probably
belongs to the same network and uh it's
something which is a kind of isolated
Network so different different networks
can be isolated uh networks and we can
have the endpoints to them so uh there
are different ways in which we can
establish the connectivity and this is a
complete Network architecture which is
there so you have a network drivers you
have the networks you have the network
sandboxes in which internally the docker
containers are running and then these uh
Network sandboxes are having their
respective endpoints there to access
them to establish the connectivity now
let's talk about the network drivers now
there are five type of network drivers
which is available first one is the
bridge
host none overlay and Mac VLAN so these
are the different uh particular network
drivers which is available over here uh
first one is a bridge it's a private
default Network created on the host if
you go there if you go to the
installation of a Docker this is the
default driver which gets installed onto
the system onto the host the containers
linked to this network will have an
internal IP address through which we
they can actually communicate with each
other on the same machine also you can
establish the connectivity you can
connect to the containers using that
private IP address but outside the
server you will not be able to have the
communication but internally you can
connect to the containers and containers
can also interact with each other they
can also communicate with each other
with this one the docker Daemon creates
the uh Docker 0 so if you run the ipcon
config or if config on the system you
will be able to see a dock zero kind of
a ethernet Bridge Network which is
created using which you can see that
okay this is the network which is
created by default it's a default
installation or default configuration
which automatically happens the moment
you set up a Docker instance so you
don't have to go into the configurations
or in the setup of there it will be
already available on that particular
installation board there and next one is
the host one so it's a public network so
when we go with the public network it
actually uses the host IP address and a
TCP port in order to interact with the
service running inside the docker
container so if you are looking forward
that I want to reach out or I want to
connect to the container but I want to
use an uh IP address which can be
accessible from outside world probably
some other server should be able to
resolve that in that situation the host
Network driver comes into the picture so
it uh effectively disables the network
isolation between the docker host and
the docker containers which means that
using this driver a user can actually
run multiple containers you know it's
it's not possible for the user to run
multiple containers on the same host
because of the fact that you are using
the host IP address now when we were
talking about the bridge connection at
that moment of time we were getting the
private IP addresses which was totally
isolated and totally unique so there
were actually if you create a using the
bridge connection multiple containers so
you will see that if there are five
three containers everyone will be having
a different private IP address but the
moment you go for the host one so in
that situation the IP address is not
going to change so you get some
restrictions okay because the
combination is of IP address and Port so
IP address and 8080 can happen only once
it cannot happen multiple times so
that's a limitation that you cannot run
multiple containers on the same host due
to this restriction and the next one is
the none so in this network driver the
docker containers will uh neither have
any access to the external network or it
will not be able to communicate with the
other containers also total isolation
and total private containers are being
done when we use this driver so if we
these options are usually used when you
want to disable so this is not doing
nothing but disabling the total
networking functionality for a specific
container that's what it's happening
over here next one is the overlay so
this one is uh utilized for creating an
internal private Network to the docker
nodes in the docker spam cluster so
overlay does not comes up in case of a
standalone Docker installation the
moment you go with the particular Docker
swam cluster at that moment of time the
overlay type of network is created so
Docker uh swam is an orchestration tool
so that requires overlay kind of uh
driver which can you know help them to
achieve the networking in case of
cluster because in case of Docker spam
you have a master node manager node
worker nodes different different
machines are there so in that situation
overlay is the main component or is the
main type of driver which is used and
then we have the Mac VLAN so so it
simplifies the communication processes
between the containers this network
assigns a MAC address to the docker
containers with this Mac address the
docker you know servers will route the
network traffic to a router so it's it's
not on the basis of IP address it's
actually on the basis of Mac address so
on the specific Mac address the network
the docker server will redirect the
network to a specific router
right it's usable when a user wants to
directly connect the containers to the
physical Network rather than the docker
host so that's where this communication
works on so it's a direct connectivity
between the host Network and the docker
container so there is no virtualization
which is happening over here so uh it's
something which is you know giving a
direct access to the networks but it's
definitely on the basis of Mac address
which on which the communication is
happening now let's talk about the
networking implementation and we'll see
that how we can go for a particular
Bridge Network implementation there so
let's go back to the virtual machine so
I am connected to a particular system
here so I can check that if the docker
is available to me and I can just run
the docker version so it says that okay
the client and the server component both
is available there now we are going to
see that what are the different uh
containers which is uh what are the
different Docker containers Network
which is available there so I'm going to
run a command called Docker Network LS
now the moment you do it over here you
will see that none host and Bridge these
are the different containers Network
which is available there and you can see
their Network IDs the names the drivers
the drivers is also very important
because that's what we are going to use
here so it's a very good one here so the
default one you can see that the bridge
is available and uh it's a default one
whenever you create any container by
default whether you give the container
attribute or not it's something which
gets created into the uh terms or in the
basis of the container only in the
default Network only so how we can get
that we can always get that part by you
know having the understanding that what
network we are using so I'm going to run
a couple of containers or small
container and we can see that how
exactly the containers can be executed
and can be done over the am
right so Alexi so I'm going to run a
command
docker
run iPhone d i t
I have an iPhone name
Alpine one
Alpine
image is what I am going to use
it so it pulls down the Alpine image
that's what it happened and the same
thing I'm going to run but I this time
I'm going to run uh alpine2 because I
want to create two containers
right so with this one what will happen
that I will be having a like a two
containers available here so I can say
like Docker PS so I can see that two
containers are running one is Alpine and
one is Alpine two right so now what
happens that we will see that how the
connectivity happens and what are the
network details so what I'm going to do
is that first of all I'm going to do an
uh inspect over there onto the uh Bridge
connectivity so that I can get the
detailed information so
um this is the name of the particular
ones of the network so this is the
network which is available and this is
the default one so if I scroll up you
can see that this is the name of the
bridge connectivity and even if you run
the docker Network LS so uh you will be
able to see that the ID also so ID also
if you compare so e65 that's the one
which is available now this one is
something which is using a driver called
bridge and here you can see the subnet
information now if you scroll down you
can can see that two containers are
available here so I did not provide any
kind of network details but uh
definitely what happens that the two
containers which I deployed are
basically running inside this network
okay and you can see that uh the bridge
name Docker 0 is the internet or network
which gets created uh which during the
installation of Docker gets uh
configured now
you can see that uh this is the IP
address this is the IP address here this
is the MAC address and this is also a
MAC address here so uh the IP address
you can see this is a
3.0.3 in the last and this is dot two
over here so you can see that it
increase the sequence is there so Alpine
one was having an
ip.172.17.0.2 and alpine2 is having an
incremented IP address like a different
one as in three so you can see that
these different IP addresses are there
and uh represents if you want to access
them if you want to connect on them you
will be able to have the connectivity
accordingly so even if you go inside
these containers you can actually see
that what exactly uh the connectivity
you want to establish or the
connectivity you want to perform here
right so this is the way that how the
network usually works and uh the
networks in which you are using over
here is the bridge ones which definitely
helps us to understand that how the
configurations can be done now so uh
what we are going to do over here is
that we will try to see that how exactly
uh we can uh go ahead and uh we can
connect on there and we can also see
that if we are able to communicate with
each other because probably uh if I run
like Ping command over here and I'll put
the containers like two
and I'm able to reach out there is no
problem in inching out to these IPS
because these are the private IP
addresses and I will be able to reach
out to them without any problem and
without any concerns so from the current
uh connectivity perspective there is no
problem as such and I have a connection
available over here but let's see uh
we'll go uh back to the containers we
will see that how exactly we can talk
about we can reach out to the one
container with each other so I want to
connect Alpine one with n Pine two so
how we can do that
so I'm going to use like Docker l
Pine one
okay now I got a terminal so what I can
do is that I can go for the IPA in this
show so with this one what will happen
that I will be able to know the IP
address so dot 2 is the one which is
available over here okay so this is the
IP address now I can uh simply do the uh
small ping command so I can say like
Ping google.com so that will show me
that if I have an internet connectivity
so that is great so I got a connectivity
with the internet uh over there so I
will be able to reach out any websites
or any kind of that order now I have
another IP so dot 3 is remember we were
using three different IP so I can
actually do a ping also here so ping
hyphen C5 5 request will put and three
will do here now we are trying to reach
out to the Alpine 2 over there so
although we are connecting to the Alpine
one what we have the connectivity with
alpine two also so from Alpine one you
can connect to the Alpine two containers
so that shows that since both of them
are running in the same container so
they are having the automatic uh
connectivity and you can easily reach
out to them and without any issues you
can do that and similarly the same thing
you can do it uh in case of uh alpine2
also so you get it connected to the
Alpine too and uh you can uh just follow
the same thing so you can connect it
with the if you go to the alpine2 you
can connect to the Alpine one also so if
you come out the containers I will be
always up and running and you will be
able to have the mechanisms there so the
whole idea about these things is that it
will be basically helping you to
understand that how the executions can
be done and how we can perform the
activities as such over here so this is
the way that how we deal with the
networkings and how the containers gets
created into a network and then they can
interact with each other right so this
was the demo on which we talked about
that how we can talk about a bridge
Network implementation with the docker
containers did you know the famous
Global researcher Gartner predicts by
2023 more than 50 percent of the
companies will be adopting Docker
containers
however a serverless container like
Docker will have a rise in the revenue
from a small base of
465.8 million in the year 2020 to 944
million in the year 2024. in this video
we will be doing a side-by-side
comparison of the docker containers and
the virtual machines what exactly is a
virtual machine it is an isolated
Computing environment that enables a
person to use an operating system via a
physical machine virtual machines
provide the functionality of a physical
computer as you can see on my screen
there is a virtual machine and this is
how a typical virtual machine looks like
now let's look at what a Docker is
Docker is an operating system level
virtualization software platform that
enables software developers and it
administrators to create deploy and run
applications in a Docker container with
all their dependent agencies and a
Docker container is a lightweight
software package that includes all the
dependencies like Frameworks libraries
and many more which are essentially
required to execute an application
this is the architecture of Docker tool
now let's move on to our next main topic
for the discussion that is Docker versus
virtual machine when it comes to
comparing the two we could say the
docker containers have much more
potential than virtual machines as you
can see on the left and right hand side
both the images look similar now let's
define the layers of virtual machine
from the bottom up let's begin with the
infrastructure infrastructure could be a
computer system a laptop or a virtual
private server such as an Amazon ec2
instance or Azure virtual machine or gcp
virtual machine instance on the top of
the infrastructure runs the operating
system and operating system is a
software that manages hardware and
software resources for the computer
programs on your laptop this will be
likely Windows Mac OS or Linux flavor
operating systems such as Ubuntu next
comes the hypervisor a hypervisor is a
firmware that builds and runs virtual
machines there are two types of
hypervisors type 1 hypervisors are
hyperkit for Mac OS hyper-v for Windows
and kvn for Linux operating systems and
type 2 hypervisors are virtualbox and
VMware then we have the guest operating
systems consider an example where you
want to run two apps on your server in
total isolation this process would
require two guest operating systems
which will be controlled by a hypervisor
virtual machines come with many
dependencies where each guest operating
system will at least occupy 512 MB of
your RAM this is worse because each
guest operating system needs its own CPU
and memory resources eventually this
will be expensive then on top of that
each guest operating system requires its
own dependencies such as binaries and
libraries since every application has
different dependencies it requires its
own set of libraries finally it's the
application this layer consists of the
source code for the application you have
built this was all about the virtual
machine on a server here's what the same
setup looks like when you're using
Docker containers here you'll notice
that there are a lot fewer layers Docker
doesn't require a bunch of massive guest
operating systems let me break it down
from the bottom up again infrastructure
and host operating systems are the same
as we discussed for the virtual machine
coming into the third layer instead of a
hypervisor Docker uses Docker engine
Docker engine or Docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using Docker
component
next we have our dependencies just like
on the virtual machines here
dependencies are built into a template
called Docker images as you can see on
the screen each application is still
isolated and occupies less space now
let's have a look at the significant
differences between Docker and a virtual
machine let's start with the operating
system first Docker is a container based
model where containers are software
packages used for executing an
application on any operating system
on the other side virtual machine is a
container based model it utilizes user
space along with the kernel space of the
operating system a kernel space is where
the core of the operating system runs
and provides its services to the user a
user cannot modify the space and user
space is the portion of the system
memory in which the user's processes run
Docker containers share operating system
kernels with other applications and
result in a higher server efficiency
hence Docker provides the most
substantial default isolation
capabilities among the other
configuration tools on the other hand
virtual machines did not share the
operating system also it does not
provide isolation in the host kernel in
Docker multiple workloads can run on a
single operating system but in virtual
machine each workload needs a complete
operating system or a hypervisor the
next significant difference between the
two is the performance in the case of
Docker they use the same operating
system without any additional software
like hypervisor in case of virtual
machines performance issues are a major
problem it can be due to the several
reasons like CPU constraints memory
allocation Network latency and many more
running multiple virtual machines lead
to an unstable performance Docker
containers can start up quickly and
result in less boot up time whereas
virtual machines do not start quickly
and lead to a poor performance now let's
talk about the next difference which is
portability with Docker containers a
developer can build an application and
store it into a Docker image which later
he or she can run it across any host
environment but when it comes to Virtual
machines it has portability issues
virtual machines do not have a central
Hub like Docker dust and it requires
more memory space to store data Docker
containers are smaller than virtual
machines due to which the process of
transferring files on the host file
system is easier on the other hand
dependency on the host operating system
and Hardware makes virtual machines less
portable while transferring files
virtual machines should have a copy of
the operating system and its
dependencies due to which image size is
increased and becomes a tedious process
to share data
the boot of time between the both is
very different the application in Docker
containers start without any delay since
the operating system is already up and
running on the other hand virtual
machines take much longer time than it
takes for a container to run
applications these containers were
basically designed to save time in the
deployment process of an application
whereas in Virtual machines to deploy a
single application virtual machine needs
to start an entire operating system
which would result in a full board
process so those are the major
differences between Docker and a virtual
machine now let's discuss the minor
differences between them
Docker is not always in a running state
it stops when the stop command is
executed whereas the virtual machines
are always running in the background
which will result in huge RAM
consumption talking about snapshots
Docker has a lot of snapshots a snapshot
is an image that you can upload on a
private repository to access it on
another host but virtual machines do not
consist of any snapshots in Docker
images can be version controlled just
like git they have local registry called
Docker Hub where uses store and
distribute container images on the other
hand virtual machine does not have a
central Hub they are not version
controlled
Docker can run multiple containers on a
system users can connect multiple
containers using user-defined networks
and shared volumes multiple containers
can be accessed on the same machine and
share the operating system kernel with
other containers each container is
isolated in user space Also Docker
containers occupy less space than
virtual machines and start instantly
virtual machine can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires a
certain amount of CPU RAM memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space multiple containers
can be started at a time on the docker
engine the isolation environment allows
a user to run and deploy several
containers simultaneously on a given
host virtual machines can run only a
limited number of virtual machines on a
system since each virtual machine
requires certain amount of CPU RAM
memory and other resources your physical
systems will have less space now that I
have told you the differences between
Docker containers and virtual machines
let me show you a real life case study
of how PCC uses Docker BCC news is a
British News Channel over 500 developers
working across the globe PCC news
delivers broadcasts in almost 30
different languages and with over 80 000
Daily News in English alone the news
channel ran more than 26 000 Jobs worth
more than 10 continuous Integrations
with sequential scheduling the company
had issues with identifying a way to
unify the coding process and monitor the
continuous integration consistently also
the existing jobs took up to more time
that is up to 60 Minutes to schedule and
perform its task
Docker allowed BCC news to eliminate job
wait times and run jobs in parallel it
also gave the users the ability to work
in a more flexible CI environment where
entire core processes were unified and
stored in a single place however Docker
succeeded in spreading up the whole
continuous integration process in this
topic we are going to talk about what
exactly is the various Docker commands
which we can use to interact with the
docker Docker images Docker containers
and some core components of Docker is
what we are going to talk about in this
particular topic here now let's begin
with what exactly is in Docker because
we are trying to explore that what are
the different Docker commands we can
eventually run to interact with the
docker because you have the command line
interface which is available there using
which you can run some couple of Docker
commands and internally you know you
will be able to have some particular
processing which is done at the docker
end now Docker is in config education
management tool it's being used as an
configuration management tool just like
the other configuration management tools
in the industry in the market now it's
pretty much used by the developers to
make sure that they wrap or the package
an application with all its dependency
now normally in a virtual machine what
we do is that we host or we install the
dependencies separately and then on top
of that we host our web applications or
whatever the application we have we host
it on that particular framework or
platform but here in this scenario we
are talking about like how we can wrap
an application all together with its
dependencies all the dependencies are
getting wrapped are getting uh packaged
up into a single entity
and you know that's what we call it as
in Docker container so Docker is in
configuration management tool and a
containerization tool which is there
which helps us to wrap or package both
the dependencies and the source code
within a single unit called Docker
container and this is the docker
container which the developers use to do
the deployment across multiple
environments so um as part of the
process when you are working on the
hosting of your application onto your
Docker so ultimately you are looking
forward for an entity called Docker
container so if you see if you go
through the diagram over here so in this
one this is in kind of a basic way uh
architecture that how the docker is
being architect and is getting a
deployed
so initially you have an infrastructure
like a physical infrastructure is there
you have the uh particular course memory
infrastructure all those things are
available there now on top of this
infrastructure you are hosting a host
operating system this host operating
system is responsible for taking up all
the requests and interacting uh
providing a particular interface between
the uh particular Docker and the
infrastructure the core Hardware so it
acts like a medium over here
so after the host on operating system on
top of that you are going to install the
docker engine Docker software it's just
like you got a virtual machine on Linux
and on top of that you are installing
the docker software once the docker
engine is installed then Docker engine
will take care of management of the
docker containers you don't really have
to do a lot of work Docker engine is
going to take all the internal work uh
the communication between the operating
system and the infrastructure so that
needs to be done by the docker engine so
Docker engine make sure that the current
different container gets uh up and
running and you can see that in this
scenario in this diagram we have
container one container two and
container 3 and all these containers are
actually having its own applications and
the dependencies binded up together so
that's the reason why we are saying that
with the docker we are getting a
complete package end-to-end package is
being given to us in which we have both
the particular source code and the
binaries and the executables embedded
inside that so it's a complete package
which is getting created in the form of
Docker container and the developer is
responsible for preparing this Docker
container so that these containers can
be deployed on the docker host and you
can get your application up and running
so this is what we have Docker into a
particular and the architecture of the
docker here now let's see that what are
the different commands we have for the
docker here now the very first one is
that what are the different images
related commands which is available
there the very first one is the command
which we typically use to prepare a
custom Docker image now I can easily go
to the docker Hub and I can pull down a
Docker image which is available there
but let's assume that you are working on
application source code so you want to
prepare a Docker container for that now
that Docker container you will not be
able to have it on the docker Hub you
have to prepare on your own
right so in order to prepare your own
Docker image all you have to do is that
you have to run Docker build command now
in this case we have to prepare a Docker
file which will act like a Docker a kind
of a Docker build script just like in
case of Maven we have power XML file and
in case of and we have build.xml file so
here we have the docker file which is
available there and this Docker file
makes sure that whatever the steps are
mentioned in this Docker file in the
build script it's going to perform a
series of steps and the build will be
done so Docker build is the command
hyphen T is the tag that what exactly
name uh you know whatever the image you
are building so what exactly tag name
you're trying to provide over here so
here we are using a tag name called my
image and then after the column we are
providing that what version we want to
go here 1.0 2.0 5.0 so whatever the
version you feel that you want to you
know refer you can do that
now this is the exact way that how in
the actual world the docker images are
getting built up by the respective
vendors let's say that Jenkins is one
and Jenkins wants to prepare a Docker
image so they will be preparing the
docker file in the same manner and
prepare these Docker images and publish
it to the docker Hub so all the docker
images are built up the custom Docker
images are built up with the help of
Docker file so Docker build is the
command which will process the docker
file and give you a particular Docker
image in the end
now how to list down all the docker
images so Docker list uh LS is something
which is there so this will eventually
help you to list down all the docker
images which is listed on or which is
available into your system so that will
be listed out over there for you
if you feel that you want to remove a
particular image in that case you can go
for Docker image RM command and uh
whatever the image you want to remove
you can give the respective image name
and the tag name there so Docker image
RM command is there using which you can
actually see that how the image can be
deleted from the host over here in this
one right so whatever the ways whatever
the you know mechanism is there so we
are making sure that how the image can
be built up and how we can go for the
built up and a particular image can be
deployed over here in this case so in
order to delete it in Docker image so
you can go for Docker image RM command
to remove a Docker image completely from
the docker host
so these are some couple of commands
which is available there using which you
can actually interact or manage the
docker image because in order to prepare
in order to run a Docker container we
require a source and that Source we are
going to get it from the docker image so
now we are going to see that how we can
execute these commands so first of all
what we need to do is that we need to
see that how Docker build works for that
we require a Docker file so I am going
to have a simple Docker file over here
in which we are going to have a basic
document selected as an Ubuntu after
that we are going to go for the one
attribute where we are going to do the
installation of a specific package like
let's say git and accordingly you can
whatever software you want to prepare
you want to set up you can do that and
put up the commands over here in this
Docker file so I'm going to save this
file and after that what I need to do is
that I need to run like Docker images to
find out that how many images are there
there is no images present so I'm going
to build a Docker image over here with
the name of
simply learn or whatever the name you
want to give you can give it over here
in this case it's not any kind of
restricted word so you can give the
actual Docker image name also that what
for what purpose you are preparing this
image and with that what will happen
that it will take up the uh values
whatever attributes you have put up into
the docker file so that will be
processed and that will be picked up and
once that uh Docker file has been
processed it's been uh you know prepared
you will be able to see that yes a final
product or a final Docker image is
finalized and prepared over here in this
one so we just have to wait for the
whole process to complete and once my
Docker image is prepared I will be able
to have a particular setup done or
achieved over here so that's what we
require over here in this one to be
performed
now once the installation is done so you
will be able to see like the final
Docker images being prepared over here
so it says successfully built which
means that uh the docker image is
prepared now if you run like darker
images you will be able to find out that
this image is available over here in
this one now you are seeing like two
images because one is like the basic
image which is being pulled down because
we are using a Docker file to do that to
process that one there
now in case you want to remove it so all
you need to do is that you need to run
like docker
image RM and simply learn
so if you do that what will happen that
your Docker image which is related to
Simply learn will be wiped off from your
system and in case you want to do like
removal of the Ubuntu also so that also
you can do over here with the help of
Docker images
RM Ubuntu and that will be removed from
your system so your Docker images will
be removed from your system using the
particular command called Docker image
and then arm command to remove the
docker image from your system from your
host here so that's how you deal with
the different Docker images uh commands
over here in this one now let's go back
to the document now the next section
over here is the docker container
commands over here so all the commands
related to Docker containers is what we
are going to talk about over here now
the very first one is the uh particular
container so in order to create a
container so you can run the command
called Docker create and the image
because for a container you require a
Docker image that's a pre-request so
once the docker image is prepared you
can just simply run Docker create
command and that will help you to create
a container onto your system now if you
want to run a particular
um you want to create a container and
you want to run it out also at the same
time so in that situation you can go for
Docker run command the main difference
between the docker create and Docker run
command is that the docker run command
is going to run a container and it's
going to give you a response from the
command but the docker create command is
going to create only the container so
once the container is up and running so
that's only being done by the docker
create come on but the docker run
command is going to actually do the uh
preparation of the container also and at
the same time you are being given as in
particular response also like you know
what a command you want to run so that
response also you will be able to get
here and if you feel that you want to
rename an existing container so for that
you can go for the docker rename command
so existing container you can rename it
with a new container and that's how the
particular rename of an existing
container will be done with the onto the
docker host here so Docker rename is the
command using which you can rename an
existing container and you can get a new
container over here in this case so
these are some of the options some of
the ways that how you can interact with
the containers how you can manage them
onto your Docker host over here so you
can run it you can create it and you can
rename the containers also so now what
we're going to do is that we are going
to see that how we can work on this
particular container commands here so
first of all I'm going to quickly pull
down Jenkins image so that I can create
a container out of that so it's some
kind of a 600 round MB Docker image
which is available there now you can
also have a custom Docker image prepared
using the docker file or you can have a
ready-made Docker image pulled down from
the docker Hub also so this is going to
pull the latest version of the Jenkins
from the docker Hub so that we will be
able to proceed further on that and we
will be able to continue with the
hosting so we will be converting or
running this uh specific Docker images
in the form of Docker container so that
we will be able to have a instance of
Docker container okay running in this
one so that's what we are trying to do
here so we will just wait for this a
pull activity to complete because it's
in a heavy Docker image so it may take
some time to download and once it's
downloaded you will be able to see that
docker
images is showing a specific Docker
image of Jenkins here now you're going
to create a container out of that so
you're going to run a command called
Docker create and Jenkins over here
so that will help us to do uh the
creation of a Docker container and once
that is done so you will be able to see
like using Docker PS command that if any
container is up and running and if you
go for dockerps hyphen a you will be
able to see that yes a particular Docker
container is in created mode now this is
not in running mode because you see that
when I ran the docker PS command it was
not showing it in the running mode
because I just created a Docker
container here and the created status
also shows that yes the docker container
is created but it did not run over here
so if you want to run it so definitely
you can say like docker start and
you can give the container name and that
will help me to start my container over
here but of course you if you feel that
you want it directly create a container
and uh you know you don't want to create
the container only you want to start it
also so in that case you can go for the
docker run command so Docker run command
is something which can be used instead
of uh doing the execution so you can say
like Docker run
Jenkins and what it will do it will
definitely help you to get the container
created onto of the Jenkins over here in
this case it's not like only creating a
container but in fact it's actually
starting the container also so you can
see that it started over here into your
screen itself that whole Jenkins gets
initialized over here in this one so
this is the way that how you can
initialize or you can create a container
now I can just do a control C over here
because it says that and Jenkins is up
and running so you can start using this
one according to your requirement over
here right so I'm just doing Ctrl C so
that it can be stopped over there
right now
so this is the way that how uh typically
we can create the containers now we got
like two containers over here and one is
up and running and one is something
which I just closed just now over here
now if you feel that you want to rename
a container let's say like this is a
container which is available but it's
not having a meaningful name now I want
to convert into a meaningful name like
Dev underscore Jenkins so that you can
easily do with the help of a Docker
rename command because that will rename
the docker container name so that you
will be able to connect on to that and
you can go for the processing so that's
what we can get over here in this one so
this is how you can do the various
management of the resources over here so
let's go back to the main content now if
you feel that you want to remove all the
stop containers because what happens
that sometimes we simply stop the
container but we do not remove it from
the docker host because
um we are not going for the cleanup now
clean cleanup is very required because
these containers are actually taking up
the disk space also so we need to make
sure that we should be using we should
be having like minimum amount of disk
space utilization so for that what we
need really need to do is that we need
to run Docker container prone command so
this will basically help you to prune or
do the cleanup uh Purge of all the
containers which is running on the host
machine here
and that will definitely help us to
remove all the containers which is in
stop status so that will be simply
removed over here in this one so this
really completely removes all the stock
containers onto the docker host over
here in this scenario
now second one is that it creates a new
image from a container's file changes
now the way what happens that normally
what we follow is that we use the docker
build command to do the build process
right so Docker build command is being
used in that particular way now if you
really want to go for a preparation of a
new you know image so all you need to do
is that you need to create a new image
from a container file so you can run the
command called Docker container commit
command and you know whatever container
is there so that will be saved or
preserved as in Docker image because
sometimes we also do some ad hoc changes
or modifications on the Fly inside the
docker container by going inside the
docker container and doing the steps so
we really need to preserve those steps
and that is the reason why we are
converting a Docker container in the
form of a Docker image here so that's
what we are trying to perform here so
Docker container is something which is
uh being uh done over here in such a way
that whatever the steps whatever changes
we are trying to do so that needs to be
performed over here in this case so
Docker container uh commit command is
being used so that we can get a
particular you know final image as part
of the container so the container will
be converted in the form of a Docker
image over here and the last one is that
how we can remove an existing container
so we can go for the docker RM command
which is available there using which you
will be able to go ahead and you can get
a particular container removed from your
existing system so Docker RM command is
pretty much there using which we can see
that how we can remove an existing
container from your system as such
what exactly now we are going to see
that how we can perform the various
commands on the containers here
so the very first command which we want
to do here is that uh you know in order
to see that how we can actually remove
all these top containers but for this
one what we really need to do is that we
need to first of all run some couple of
containers so I'm going to quickly run a
container called docker
or run hyphen D httpd so I'm going to
run a particular web server over here
and it should be able to give me a
proper container up and running so I can
just double check our value that it as
with the help of the docker PS command
so Docker PS command should give me the
proper confirmation that whether the
container is in up and running over here
or not so you can see that it's up and
running from last 11 seconds here now we
got a command where you know for example
we have got some stopped containers but
again you have to manually remove them
one by one now if you don't want to do
that stuff if you feel that whatever the
stock containers which is available that
should be automatically removed from
your system then we have a command
called Docker container prone now for
this what we really need to do is that
we need to actually stop this container
because again it will be only picked up
like whatever the containers which is
available in these top settings only
those will be picked up so I have copied
the container name here in this case and
I need to stop it so that I will be able
to remove it with the prone command over
here in this one and then I can run like
docker
container front command which will
basically remove all the containers
which is in these top status and once
that is done you will be able to see
like that is something which is
completely gone from your system so this
is a way that how it can not only take
care of the stop containers but it's
actually being done so that you can
remove the multiple containers with a
single command itself over here so this
is not something which will be executed
one by one on a different container but
yes it will definitely take care of
doing the uh changes and Performing the
activities
now another thing is that how we can
actually do the uh commit of a
particular Docker image let's say that
we got a Docker container which is uh
running and there are some changes like
some Dynamic changes which is available
there so you want to say this uh
particular container as a Docker image
so that whatever the changes temporary
changes are there so that will be also
saved as a Docker image so all you can
do is that let's say that again run a
particular container
of httpd here so this will help me to
get a particular container from the HTTP
perspective available of to us so Docker
PS command will give me the option
now here I have got a container in which
it's running now if I want to save this
container let's say that I went inside I
did some modification did some temporary
changes now I want to refer it I want to
use it so how you can do that so for
that what you really need to do is
you need to run like docker
commit that's the command or you can say
Docker because you're going to do a
Docker container commit over here so the
comment of the container is what we are
going to do so Docker container commit
and then we're going to see like what is
the container so for container we will
be yes again copying uh that particular
container ID and we'll say like custom
image column version one so we will be
giving a custom name or a name of a
Docker image and a tag over here in this
one so this will basically save my
Docker container which is available in
this one in the format of a particular
Docker image in a format of a Docker
image over here in this case
so as you can see that almost both of
them are having the same change but
the container which we got over here in
this one so this whatever the changes
are you want to wish you want to do you
can do that and you can then put it up
into the uh form of a Docker image a
final Docker image and at last if you
want to remove it so Docker RM and
container ID now this again Docker RM
will come remove only those containers
which is in stop status so if you want
to forcefully remove it so you will be
able to use it with the help of hyphen f
which is the forceful remove which will
remove the container completely from
your system and once it's removed from
your system you will be able to see like
there is no container running up and
running over here in this one so Docker
p is hyphen a is not something which is
up and running over here in this one so
the completely completely got uh wiped
out from your system so that's how you
basically work on these commands on this
uh particular container related commands
here so let's go back to the main
content
right so these are the commands where we
can actually do the management like how
to stop the containers how to remove the
containers and how to get a new you know
darker image out of the container here
now let's see that how we can list down
all the running containers if you feel
that you want to list down all the
running containers then you can go for
the docker containers LS command and
that will eventually help you to list
down all the containers which is
available there which is uh being there
into your system then Docker stock
command is there to stop a container
so whatever container which is there in
the running status so that will be start
with the help of the docker stop command
and then the restart command is there
using which you can do a restart of a
container into your system
right so once the container is restart
so whatever the application running
inside the container so that will also
be restarted over here in this one so
these are the different options which is
available using which we can explore
over here in this one awesome what more
commands about the container so again I
am going to run a container over here of
httpd here so that I can show you some
couple of more commands over here now we
can run like Docker PS or you can say
like Docker container LS will be list
down on all the containers which is
available to you which is being you know
present in this case now if you want to
do any kind of operations like let's say
if I want to stop it now the moment you
do the stop over here so you will be
able to uh stop the container which is
up and running for you and uh you can
come uh you know whatever the
application is being deployed that will
also not be available to you because
that's simply uh completely gone for you
now you can see that Docker 99 list is
not able to show you that particular
option that whether it's uh being shown
or not because it's in stop status so in
fact you can do a you know start or you
can do a restart so both the operations
you can pretty much do over here so that
you will be able to have a complete
activity implemented so restart is also
something which is available which can
definitely help you to see that how the
things really work and how you can go
for the container uh you know the
management over here in this case so you
can do container document in a LS
command to list down what are the
containers which is available then you
can do a restart you can do a stop also
in fact start is also there which can
help you to see that how the containers
is a really available so this is the way
that how you can manage like uh you know
even the restarts and all because this
really helps you to even do the restart
of bounces to the application which is
present inside this container so that
also you will be able to see with this
particular component here
so that let's go back to main content
and then um you know killing a running
container so if you really want to kill
a container so for that we can go for
the docker kill because Docker stop is
also going to stop the container but if
you want to forcefully kill it so in
that case you can go for the docker kill
command to do that particular kill on
the containers and then if you really
want to go inside the container and you
want to attach your terminal so for that
you can go for the docker attach command
and with this what will happen that you
can go inside the container you can do
whatever the changes you want to perform
you can do that and you can again come
back outside that also so normally
typically we use it so that we can see
some errors of uh in the logs which is
coming up in the containers and if any
kind of issues are coming up for the
applications we should be able to know
that part
now the last one is the particular
weight dock of weight is there so that
will block a container and it will go in
the weight status so Docker weight and
the container ID or the container name
you can give so with that the particular
container will go into the block status
let's see somewhat more uh commands over
here so we can run like Docker container
LS again to find out like what container
is available so you can see that this
particular container is available over
here in this one now if you see like if
I want to get a attached to this
container if I want to attach my input
and output a stream with this container
so you can run like Docker attach and
the container ID so your terminal will
be stuck over here because it's taking
up whatever the progress which is going
to be done in the container that will be
in you know a kind of attached to your
terminal over here and you will be
getting the output but the moment you
come out of this like you say Ctrl C so
you will see that you know it's
basically sending the request to the
container that is getting stopped so you
will be able to see like the docker
container list is not going to show you
because the container is in stop status
so again you have to do the restart of
the container to make sure that the
container is up and running
right so the attachment will help you to
go uh and attach your standard input and
output with your container with a
running container but when the moment
you comes out you will be able to uh
disconnect or shut down the container
and again I had to restart that
container over here in this one then
again of course we have like Docker
weight
then container is there so this will
basically put the container into a block
status because all the requests and all
will be not sent to the container and it
will be blocked and uh if you really
want to like uh consume or if you want
to make use of the container you will
not be able to do that so Docker read
command will kind of block the container
and you know if you again uh try to come
out of that so
again the request to The Container will
be
resumed and they will be able to use on
that part so Docker wheat command is
being used to block the container and
then we have Docker attached to attach
to the container the standard input and
output and lastly is the docker kill
which is going to kill the container and
you will be able to see that the
container is in simply killed status so
it's uh you know it's not like a stopped
over here if it's gracefully stopped
then the exit code definitely will be
zero but in this case since it's being
killed the particular status is 137 over
here in this one so that's a non-zero
status code so that's how where you will
be able to manage the containers on
different aspects let's go back the main
container so these were some of the
commands which was there from the docker
containers perspective let's talk about
some of the commands from the share
command perspective so how we can share
the docker images so we have a typical
pole post mechanism which is there using
which we can actually interact with the
docker Hub or a Docker registry so uh if
you really want to pull a Docker image
so in that case you can go for the
docker pull command if we want to push
an image to the registry so you can use
for the docker push command if you want
to execute a command inside a particular
running container or you want to execute
a command or S create or something like
that so you can go for the docker as a
command and with that the execution will
be done and you will be able to get a
response so that will make sure that yes
whatever the execution you are trying to
do so that will be done over here in
this mechanism now let's see that how we
can do a pull and push activity to a
Docker image so first of all the pull
command is pretty simple all you need to
do is that you need to say that okay I
want to pull a Docker image if let's say
that our Docker image is already present
then it's just going to say that it's
already up to date it's already
available there but if in some cases you
feel that the docker image is not
available and you want to pull it so all
you can do is that you can give that a
Docker image name and uh that you can
give the tag also but in this case we
are using the tag as in latest
so that's the reason why even if you
provide or you don't provide it doesn't
really matter so I'm going to give like
a Docker pull a MySQL over here and the
moment I hit on this one what will
happen that it says this a particular
Docker image is not available into my
system it's going to download it and
once it's going to be downloaded you
will be able to see that into your local
system so Docker images is something
which is going to help you with the
commands and it will give you the uh
particular ways that how the docker
image is available so I can run like
Docker images over here to see that what
are the different Docker images which is
available in this manner now if you
really want to move any of the docker
image then of course you have to do a
Docker login and you will be doing the
uh you know the connectivity to the
docker Hub and then establish the uh
connectivity and all so what you need to
do is that you can run the docker login
command we will also see this command in
the next particular slide but right now
we are just doing it because we want to
showcase that how the push really works
so uh you can actually give your
username that what username you are
holding up so the password does not
shows any activity but yes still it will
let you know that whether the login is
successful or not so in this case it
says login is successful so all you need
to do is let's say like I got this
Custom Image and I want to push it to
the docker home so you need to rename or
you need to do a tag over here because
the same if you run
Docker push custom
image column version one so if you do
that it will not be pushed into these uh
particular Docker Hub so it's going to
throw error over here that the access is
denied so all you need to do is that you
need to do a tag here
so you have to rename it in such a way
that you should be able to uh use uh add
your username over there because Docker
Hub will identify that if it's there
with your username then only it will be
pushed otherwise it will be simply
rejected over there so that's what you
need to do you need to rename your
Docker image the same Docker image which
you have you have to append your
username of the docker Hub and once that
is done so all you need to do is that
you need to just run like docker
then push is there
then this image name and then version
one
so the moment you do this what will
happen that it will start transferring
those darker image to the docker Hub you
see this uh specifies that yes this is
going to the docker Hub docker.io where
my username is there and this is the
Custom Image which is available there so
if I refresh my page on the docker Hub I
will be able to see like this public
repo which is available there but again
this one just requires a credentials and
the login which we did in just a last
command where we ran the docker login
command to do the login to the portal
and after that only we are able to do
the setup and the modifications over
here so that's how you do the login and
you are able to connect on that now
these are some of the pull and push
operations but let's say that if you got
a container which is up and running like
this is uh right now we are not getting
any container which is available over
here so you can say like Docker run
hyphen D httpd like I'm just running a
dummy container over here so that I will
be able to show you this command now if
you for some reason want to go inside
the container and want to see some
processing and want to see some content
so you can run the command called Docker
Asic hyphen ID and there you can give
the container ID this is nothing but the
full format of the container ID which is
given to you so you can use this one
also or you can use the shortened also
shortened value also you can use and in
the last we can say like bash the moment
you do this you will be going you will
be going inside the container you see
that this is the host name which is
being shown as the container ID you can
do a like psyphen EF command and it will
throw in error that DPS command is not
available because you are running this
command into the docker into the docker
container so using these kind of
commands which is not available in
container will help you to identify that
yes you are not on the host machine you
are in fact into the docker container so
that's the reason why you can do it
because for you the parts and all
everything is same the terminal is also
same so you may not be able to
differentiate in that part so that's the
reason why it's preferred that we use
that commands which is going to fail but
that's okay it will give you that okay
this command is failing because I am
into the docker container right now so
that's what we are performing over here
right and you can come out of that but
still the docker container is going to
be still up and running over here in
this case so the container is not going
to be down over here in this one so
that's how we manage the container we
can go inside and we can check some
informations and get some files there
so these are some of the commands where
we can interact now in order to log into
the docker Hub because before doing the
docker push you have to login uh you
have to get a credentials and the
connectivity with Docker Hub so you can
run the docker login command where you
can see that how the execution can be
done now using the docker login command
you can interact uh with the particular
Docker Hub you can set up the
credentials once the credentials is
being set up so what you can do is that
you can go ahead and say that okay the
configurations is done and we can go
ahead and we can perform the execution
so Docker login is the command where you
can give the credentials Docker info is
the command using which you can get the
information about the docker tool so
whatever the docker info is available
there so those things you can actually
get it over here in the case of the
docker info so Docker info is going to
give you complete information that what
exactly you have the information
available over here on this one
and then we have the docker history so
using the docker history you can see
history of the docker image that what
exactly uh the mechanisms or what are
the different image IDs are available
there so this is basically giving you
the complete history on how the docker
image is prepared all the commands is
available there and that will help you
to eventually go and understand that how
the images can be going on and you can
manage on that part
so uh these are some of the couple of
options which is available there where
we can see that how the executions can
be done and we can go ahead on that
particular part so Docker history is the
command again which will help you to see
that how you can go for the particular
mechanism and you can listen on on the
things over there so Docker login was
already done previously when we tried to
push the image but again if you try to
run Docker login you will be able to do
that now Docker info is something which
will give some additional information
about the docker and all the
informations about the docker will be
given back to you over here in this one
so the complete Clarity uh then let's
say that you got a Docker image called
uh httpd now you want to check the
history of this image that how this
image is prepared what are the different
layers which is available how many
layers are there how much size is being
modified in each and every layer so you
can see that we got a layer where we
have a particular changes of 7.838 MB
but pretty much the uh from the complete
size of this httpd The major portion is
actually of the uh this one the basic
operating system which is being
implemented and then of course there are
some packages which got deployed due to
which this uh 60 MB and 7 MB size is
coming up there so this actually gives
you the complete layer wise mechanism
that what are the informations which is
available that how the modifications
actually got modified and got changed
over here in this one so this is the
additional uh help which you can get
from the docker to manage the containers
here so these are the ways where you can
interact with the docker Hub if you
really want to create a volumes for the
containers so you can go for the docker
volume create command so Docker volume
create command is there using which you
can create the docker volumes and you
can pretty much do that uh setup so
Docker volume create is the command
which is available there for that
particular part it will create a volume
for you now let's see that how we can
actually work with the volume so you can
run the command called Docker volume LS
to find out at what are the different
volume switches available there now if
you really want to create a volume over
here in this one so you can say like
Docker volume create and you can go for
the volume name here now the moment you
do that what will happen that a volume
will be created and you can validate it
with the help of Docker volume LS
command that whether the volume is being
created or not over here so this is the
way that how you can manage the volumes
onto the docker host now let's talk
about some of the docker spam commands
here now Docker spam commands is there
to set up a particular mechanism where
you can see that how you can perform a
setup you can actually go ahead and see
that how the setup and modifications can
be done
so Docker spam is there where we can see
that how the execution needs to be done
so you can go for the command called
Docker spam init command this will
actually go for an initialization of a
Docker swamp cluster and once the
docusframe cluster is initialized then
you can pretty much go there and perform
whatever the executions you want to
perform you can do that and you can
execute as such over there so Docker
swam in it is a command using which you
can actually see that how the execution
needs to be done and how we can perform
the uh you know mechanism and the
changes over here so Docker Sam init
hyphen iPhone advice ADR address is
there which helps you to see that how
the executions can be done now joins you
have the docker spam join command which
is available there now if you go for
Docker spam join command so uh you can
have a particular host so Dockers swam
join command is there which you can run
on the Node machine and in that case
what will happen that node will be a
part of the docker spam cluster and then
if you want to leave uh from the swam
cluster then you can go for Docker spam
leave command and it will be simply
removed from the docker swamp cluster
there some of the couple lines which
you initialize or we can remove from the
docker spam cluster here so docker spam
is already being initialized or it's
been created when the moment you do the
installation of Docker so Docker spam in
it is the command using which you can
analyze analyze the docker container now
once you analyze over here so initial
after the initialization you got a
command you which you want to add it
like you want to run it onto the Dockers
fam cluster
it will act like a worker node so that
you will be able to deploy the
containers on top of that also if you
want to join it as a manager so you can
also get the join token again so it will
give you the proper command now if you
run like Docker node LS so you will be
able to see like what are the different
nodes which is available there and for
any reason if you're not comfortable
with that and you want to reinitialize
your Docker spam cluster so all you can
do is that you can say like Docker swamp
a leave hyphen f and you will be left
out of the docker spam and now if you
want to run like knock Docker node LS
you will not be able to get that output
because it's saying that there is no
particular swab manager which is
available so you can run Docker spam in
it or you can run the join command to
connect to that specific node but we
have already left it and nothing is
available over here so that's a way that
how you can manage like what are the
different Docker spam commands we can
typically run to manage the docker spam
cluster now let's talk about the docker
compost camera months now Docker compose
commands is actually there using which
we can create multiple containers it's
not only one container which can we can
create we can create go for multiple
creations of the containers with the
help of Docker compose file so dock
compose hyphen version is the U command
which we can give you the version of
Docker compose which is being used so
here we use a particular vamil format
file which will help us to create the
multiple containers we Define the
services that what are the different
containers we want to create here and
then with the help of a Docker hyphen
compose dot vimal file we can create or
we can have that particular Docker
compose file set up over here in this
case so Docker hyphen compose dot yml
file is used to do the setup and the
modification so that you will be able to
have the modifications done and you will
be able to find out a particular
multiple containers gets created all
together so Docker compose is there is
the way that how you can do the setup
how you are going to run the docker
compose file so in that case you're
going to run the docker hyphen compose
up command which will help you to set up
like how the compose can be done and
once you are done with the docker hyphen
compose up command so using this the
compose will be done and the containers
will be up and running so these are the
commands using which we can manage
multiple containers using the docker
compose one so let's try to run some
commands related to Docker compose so
Docker hyphen compose hyphen version
will let you know that what exactly
version of Docker compose is installed
into your system so you can run typical
apt command to do the installation so
Docker hyphen composes the package name
which you can install so that the
executables and the package can be
installed into your system onto the
server now all we need to do is that we
need to create a Docker compose file so
what we need to do is that we need to
create a Docker hyphen compose dot yml
file is the default name of the yml file
which we want to create here that's a
standard name so once you create this
all you need to do is like you need to
put some values attributes the very
first one is the version value that what
version of this particular attribute you
want to create here let's say that I
want to create a version two so I will
configure here that yes the version 2 is
what I require I want to set up over
here in this one now again if I want to
configure that what are the different
Services we want to run because Services
is the main thing which we will be
running on this machine on the server
here so that's what we require so then
we need to put for a particular service
called Web so web service we want to
search and we want to run and then again
we need to take care about the spacing
because that's a very important part
and we need to provide the values of the
image and uh all these configurations
here so that you should be able to set
up like how the uh images and how the
docker images can be built up over here
so uh web is the service which we want
to deploy and then of course the image
is the attribute which is there for the
web that yes engine is the one which we
are trying to build up now you can give
the ports configuration also so you can
say like ports
and inside that you can see like what
port mapping you want to perform so you
can say like
um 8080 so odd sorry 80 is what you can
dash for the engineers because it runs
on 80 Port but now I have to run like 84
I want to attach that Port over here in
this one so I can specify that 80 Port
should be available in this one so I'm
going to save this one here and I'm
going to run a command called Docker
iPhone compose up now this will run the
containers in the interactive mode but
if you feel that I want to run in the
detached mode so you can say like hyphen
D also which will of course run these
ones into the dash mode and it will be
executed so it will process your Docker
compose file and since you have used a
standard name called hyphen Docker
hyphen compose.ml so it will
automatically pick that Docker details
and start creating the container
kubernetes is an open source platform
used for deployment and management of
containers so let's get started now the
first step is to install the necessary
dependencies using two of the commands
first is sudo apt get update which gets
all the update dates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install Docker dot IO
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo systemctl
start Docker and sudo system CTU
enabledoc
so now the dock is enabled so now we are
done with the first step of installation
the next step is we have to install the
necessary components for kubernetes
before that we have to install the curl
command because current command is used
to send data using a URL syntax let's
install the curl command using the
command sudo apt-get install code
so you have to select Y and this will
take few minutes
[Music]
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download an add key for kubernetes
installation from a URL so let's go
ahead with that pseudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using C or sudo CH mode command
okay so the permission has changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a URL
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubadian cubicle and
kubernetes cni so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap of
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap off
hyperly
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
Cube ADM in it
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so moving forward the next step is to
deploy Parts using the following command
now the pods have been deployed to our
Network to see all the pods you have to
use the command pseudo Cube Vector get
pods
there you can see the costs that have
been deployed so my kubernetes well
kubernetes is really being built from
allowing you to be able to have a more
reliable infrastructure the tool itself
is designed to manage the containers you
have within your network it's very
modular in architecture which allows it
to be very easy to be able to maintain
and to be able to scale and meet the
demands that your current customers are
offering you today the actual ability
for you to be able to deploy and update
software at scale is really at the heart
and center of kubernetes it's really
well the one of the reasons why
kubernetes was created was to be able to
scale up the deployment of software into
tens of thousands of networks and
servers within a Data Center and then
finally when you start working with
kubernetes really what you're doing is
laying the foundation for building Cloud
native applications and part of this
comes from the architecture and history
of kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud-centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by Google Google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the data structured and
data infrastructure that they had within
their Network they really liked it and
one of the big benefits that kubernetes
that Google provided is that they
converted their code into an open source
program that they released as kubernetes
in 2014 and made an open source this
means that any company can use
kubernetes there's no charge for it all
you have to do is know how to use the
command line to actually get up and
running the benefit of kubernetes being
open source is that most Cloud providers
now support kubernetes so whether you're
using Microsoft Azure you're using
Google cloud or AWS you'll find that you
can actually use kubernetes and
kubernetes and at a core really helped
eliminate manual processes so it allowed
for deploying and scaling your
container-based Solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of Step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
ten thousand uh doesn't matter you have
the ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes is
also will manage the actual containers
themselves including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great benefit of
working with kubernetes is that not only
is it a cloud-centric solution but it
was really built from a core need of a
secure solution so security is at the
heart and center of all the work you're
doing now which really helps benefit any
team's scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored so that when you
have nodes that have your containers the
health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to uh the
kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment has always been
managed and checked so if you have any
additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes if
something does go wrong you can actually
set up your kubernetes environment to do
an automatic roll bag again this is just
allowing you to have that confidence
that when you're deploying a solution
that everything is going to work within
that environment and then finally
kubernetes will allow you to Mount and
add the storage needed to run your apps
so whether you have storage such as a
local SSD storage device physically on
the hardware or if you're connecting to
storage fire the cloud kubernetes will
allow you to access the storage you need
how you're accessing it so let's look a
little bit into the differences between
kubernetes and Docker swarm so if we
just step back a little bit kubernetes
and Docker often get connected with each
other and largely because kubernetes
manages containers and Docker is really
famous for creating the most popular
container management solution which is
called Docker if you're a developer
you're probably already using Docker
today so one of the things that
kubernetes is really really good at is
that it manages containers at scale and
just massive volume of containers Docker
swarm is docker's alternative to
kubernetes it's a tool that allows you
to to also manage large number large
numbers of containers there are
differences between the two of them and
right now without doubt the most popular
open source solution out there is
kubernetes from Google it just has a
massive Community behind it and the
community uh really have embraced
kubernetes and yes the original product
was by developed by Google but Google
has been great stewards and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
Docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by Docker there is a smaller
Community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm Community
um but with that said Dockers form is
really easy to set up so if you are used
to working within the doctor environment
you will be able to set up Docker swarm
very very quickly whereas kubernetes
does require some heavy lifting to get
up and running now with that said if you
are using Microsoft Azure or Google
Cloud very often those environments will
actually set up kubernetes for you so
you don't have to do it and you can
actually then focus on writing the
instructions to maintain your kubernetes
environment kubernetes has extremely
high voltage tolerance again it's
because kubernetes is has been Road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as Gmail
google.com YouTube I mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to Docker swarm which has lower fault
tolerance
um and this really kind of leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee um strong clusters and
management just a really reliable
environment Dr swarm however is able to
take containers deploy them into large
casters very very quickly two
interesting differences is that with
kubernetes the load balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures that skill set in
contrast load balancing is automatic
within Docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it uses nodes to actually manage
all the individual Hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine in a data center term
or a virtual machine and when you're
setting up an environment on a cloud
environment such as Microsoft Azure or
Google cloud or AWS kubernetes will be
managing the containers within that node
so it's important to know that
kubernetes itself doesn't work with the
individual nodes but actually works with
the cluster as a whole and and why
that's important is that it's a tool to
manage your entire environment it's not
going to come down and manage the
individual node itself it's going to
match the entire environment the actual
control of data within a cluster and
it's very flexible within kubernetes you
can have local storage such as an SSD
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that's cloud-based storage
offers you is that you are increasingly
Moving Your solution into more of a
hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of Hardware within your
data center and why that's important is
that it gives you the opportunity to
scale up your Solutions much more
effectively so if you need to increase
the hard drive space you can do that
very easily from the cloud whereas local
hardware is a little bit harder to
manage great news kubernetes gives you
both options to be able to choose from
and so the the next layer down is the
actual management of the application and
that's within a container and as
mentioned earlier Docker is the most
popular container solution out there and
again if you're a developer you're
probably already using Docker as it was
a natural maturity from using a virtual
machine but kubernetes itself will
actually manage the containers that you
have within your nodes and so you have a
collection of containers working
together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that pod so if a
container or a pod fails kubernetes will
automatically dramatically deploy out a
replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the ports themselves will actually be
managed by kubernetes and you really
want to let kubernetes do this because
it's allowing you to step away from the
manual management of Parts your
environment is just going to be
healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from Services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called Ingress and going back
earlier we talked about how security is
a key part of all the work that goes
into kubernetes and this is a great
example of where you can use an external
service but still have that layer of
security that is vital for your solution
because to be able to provide the
Ingress connection kubernetes requires
that SSL connection which all
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then and the
bottom left hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master so the master itself is comprised
of a number of key components again this
is the tool that's going to manage your
entire kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the etcd
control manager scheduler API server and
the key four component are Etc or the
cluster store the controller manager the
scheduler and the API server the cluster
store is the tool where all the details
of the work that you're doing is stored
and it's going to manage the rules it's
going to manage all the instructions and
this is where you're going to post that
information the controller is actually
going to then perform the tasks that are
stored in the cluster store and as you'd
expect the schedule is the tool that
actually controls when instructions and
tasks are pushed out to all the pods and
nodes within your network and then
finally you have an API server which
allows you to be able to control all the
operations the actual operations
themselves are all the instructions
written as rest instructions and which
allows you to take advantage of the
security that has been built into rest
and so you end up with a worker slave
architecture and slave are all the
different nodes and pods within your
network and so a pod itself will have
multiple one or more multiple containers
and then each container and then each
pod will have a Docker container a
kublet and a kubernetes proxy and the
these are tools to allow you to
communicate back up to the master layer
so the docker is the actual container
itself and this is going to actually run
your application and the instructions
here are to pull down the correct
container from the docker images that
you have within your library the cubelet
is going to manage your containers and
your container instructions that will be
deployed to the cubelet are going to be
written in either yaml or Json format
yaml is just graded if you haven't had a
chance to start working with yaml I
certainly encourage you to do so it's
very easy to pick up if you know any XML
you'll pick up yaml very quickly and
finally the kubernetes proxy is the tool
that interacts with the master
environment within the kubernetes
network and allows all the instructions
front that are pushed to the couplet and
to Docker to be able to perform
effectively so let's have a look at some
of the companies using kubernetes there
are a lot and if you're doing any work
today in the cloud and or even if you're
just starting off and doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes for
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are a Spotify sap eBay and of
course some of the the big companies out
there Google with their entire network
of solutions and Microsoft with offers
and their tools so let's take a step
into aube now let's have a look at a
kubernetes use case and in this example
we're going to look at the New York
Times and how they use kubernetes to
solve a problem that their IIT
Department was struggling with so when
New York Times started working after
their data centers their their actual
deployments was small and the
applications were managed across VMS but
the problem is is that as New York Times
became more visual company they started
building more digital Solutions and at
some point they realized that what they
needed to do was to embrace the cloud
and move all their solutions to the
cloud however their first step of using
the cloud and this is I think typical
for a lot of companies is that they
treated like the cloud hosted provider
in the same way as they would with a
Data Center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team I
came in and they said look how about we
stop thinking of our Solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
Amazon and start thinking them as Cloud
first Solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using Google Cloud platform with
kubernetes as servers and to provide
greater efficiency and so by using
kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
Solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you do the deployments it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the New York Times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do Solutions through a more
traditional ticket based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
New York Times website so this finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take it our time
to do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going to look through and will let
you read through this but we have a
cluster which is a set of machines
physical vertical in which applications
are managed and run we have a node that
are the working machines that run
containerized applications and other
workloads there is the pod which is
within a node and there's a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is used to define a POS life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources labels are key value
pairs that are attached to objects such
as pods and the key value pair or the
label can be filtered organized and
perform operations on resources
replication sense Define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
manage when you want to either replace a
pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the direct to which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to a resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top tier pods which
provide a single IEP address and DNS
Name by which the pods can be accessed
so this time what we want to do is take
you through kubernetes demo actually
runs through some of these basic
controls so I'm going to take you
through a video of how to actually
install kubernetes and to use some of
the basic instructions so kubernetes is
the most wildly used platform for
container management the first step is
to actually install the necessary
dependencies so let's see if there's any
updates first so the first so to check
if there's any updates when you use the
command sudo app dash get update we're
going to enter in our password and this
looks like it's going to take a few
minutes because we've got a few updates
that need to be running all right we're
done all right next we're going to write
sudo app get install Dash y APK T Dash
transport https and this will install
all the dependencies we need to actually
start installing the solutions needed
for kubernetes all right that was quick
now we're going to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo apt install
Docker dot IO I'll go typo correct that
quickly and put in y so vs and we
continue and it's going to take a while
because we're going to download and
install Docker off the internet and it's
quite a large installation now would be
a good time to go get a cup of coffee
because it'll take us about a minute to
get this all done once we actually have
Docker installed we'll let you go ahead
and we'll start Docker and enable Docker
using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable Docker we're going to
using so we're going to use sudo
systemctl start Docker and sudo
systemctl enable Docker this will be
quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to install the curl command and
then kubolate Cube C and then cubeadm
and we're going to install all the
necessary tools we'll do the curl
command cubelet cubic C2 and Cube ADM
and so let's go ahead and put in the
sudo apt-get install Curl we're going to
get a prompt we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudocal dash s and
then we have a long URL which is https
packages.cloud google.com apt dark
apt-key dot gpg
sudo
apt-key there we go I'll create my typo
there okay now we have to go ahead and
change permissions of a folder so we do
that with sudo chmod
777 slash Etc apt slash
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit and we're going to
create a simple file and so what we're
going to type in is the following
command DB httbt
apt-cubernetes dot IO slash kubernetes
Dash zenial Main and we're going to save
this file in the ETC folder and then
look for and then a APT which is going
to be down a little bit and there we
have it and we're going to save it in
the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as kubernetes dot list and
we'll save that and then we can close
out the notepad and go back to the
terminal window and let's look and see
see if there are any updates again so
we're going to go ahead and run apt-get
update and it's going to run any updates
from what we've created and we want to
check what's in the folder and so we do
cat slash X at ATT Etc apt
sources.d kubernetes dot list and there
we are it shows what we have in that
text file and so we're going to go ahead
and we're going to install cubelet cubic
cubic 2 and Cube ADM but first we're
going to have to initialize the master
I'm going to show you what an error you
would get if you were to install cubelet
and the other files too quickly you get
a fine error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm qbx2 and kubernetes CNN and so
we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap up Dash a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo Cube ADM in
it and this will take a few minutes for
it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the Pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cuboo
Cube CTL apply
we have a long Pathway to type out which
is Dash fhqbs raw githubs content.com
choreos flannel Master documentation
Cube file Dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by
creating mkdr Dash p and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot Cube and
create that new directory and sudo CP
Dash I and then the path will be
Etc
kubernetes
admin.conf and then dollar sign home
slash dot Cube dot slash config
and then final one will be pseudo
c-h-o-w-n dollar sign open Prime ID Dash
U closed paren colon dollar sign open
Brain ID
G closed paren door sign home slash dot
Q slash config all right now we're going
to go ahead and deploy and uh let's see
and oh yeah I think I have a typo in my
command here yep oh yeah I did have a
typo and so
um I've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spelled with a
t not an S and then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic Cube CTL
apply dash dash F and then we're just
going to change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
pods that we have in our Network and so
we're going to do that by writing the
commands sudo cubic TCL get pods Dash or
all dash dash name spaces and it should
list all of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all the content now
we're going to so there's only one note
so let's see what we have here so we're
going to use the command sudo you know
cubic TL get nodes there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
ngi and access service and we're going
to do that with the command sudo cubic
CTL run Dash Dash image equals nginx and
we're going to put this into Port 80 so
it's going to be nginx Nash app dash
dash Port equals 80 dash dash
environment EMV equals uh open Con open
quota domain equals cluster close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo Cube CTL exposed
deployment nginx Dash app dash dash Port
equals 80 dash dash name equals nginx
Dash HTTP and once we've done this we
will be able to then run the command to
actually see our services and there'll
be quite a few of them
and our final command is sudo docker
ps-a
there we are quite a lot of lists quite
a lot of services listed so there you
are that's the instructions on how to
get Docker up and running and uh with
some basic commands and it is worth
going through a few times to get right
um but once you actually have the um the
kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your Docker environment and
containers it's extremely powerful we're
going to take a deep dive into the
kubernetes architecture so let's have an
overview of the kubernetes architecture
so kubernetes has really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of four key areas which
essentially control all of your nodes
and and the node contains multiple pods
and each pod has your Docker container
built into it so consider that you could
have a really almost an infinite number
of PODS I'm sorry infinite number of
nodes are being managed by the master
environment so you have your cluster
which is a collection of servers that
maintain the availability and the
compute power such as RAM CPU and disk
utilization and you have the master
which is really components that control
and schedule uh the activities of your
network and then you have the node which
actually hosts the actual Docker virtual
machine itself and be able to actually
control and communicate back to the
master the health of that pod and we'll
get into more detail now later in the
presentation so you know you keep
hearing me talk about containers but
they really are the center of the work
that you're doing with kubernetes and
can the concept around kubernetes and
containers is really just a natural
evolution of where we've been with
internet and digital Technologies over
the last 10 15 years so before
kubernetes you had tools where you
either running virtual machines or
you're running data centers that have to
maintain and manage and notify you of
any interruptions in your network
kubernetes is the tool that actually
comes in and helps address those
interruptions and manages them for you
so the solution to this is the use of
containers so you can think of
containers as that Natural Evolution
from you know uh 15 20 years ago you
would have written your code and posted
it to a Data Center and more recently
you probably posted your code to a
virtual machine and then move the
virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container and
everything is self-contained and can be
pushed out to your environment and the
thing that's great about containers
they're they're isolated environments
very easy for developers to work on them
but it's also really easy for operations
teams to be able to move a container
into production so let's kind of step
and back and look at a competing product
to kubernetes which is Docker swarm now
one of the things that we have to
remember is that darker containers which
are extremely popular I'm built by the
company Docker and made open source and
Docker actually has other products one
of those other products is Docker swarm
and Docker swarm is a tool that allows
you to be able to manage multiple
containers so if we look at some of the
uh the benefits of using Docker swarm
versus kubernetes now one thing that
you'll find is that both tools have
strengths and weaknesses but it's really
good that they're both out there because
it helps keep they really kind of
justifies the importance of having these
kind of tools so kubernetes was designed
originally from the ground up to be Auto
scaling whereas took a swarm isn't the
load balancing is automatic on Docker
Swan whereas with kubernetes you have to
manually configure load balancing across
your nodes the installation for Docker
swarm is really fast and easy I mean you
can be up and running within minutes
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll will get there I mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's a when you compare the two Docker
swarms much easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's it's real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with Docker swarm it's cluster
strength isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison but
kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability kubernetes was designed for
by Google to scale up and support Google
Cloud Network infrastructure they both
allow you to be able to share um storage
volumes with Docker you can actually do
it with um any container with that is
managed by the docker swamp whereas with
kubernetes it manages the storage with
the pods and a pod can have multiple
containers with in it but you can't take
it down to the level of the container
interestingly kubernetes does have a
graphical user interface for being able
to control and manage the environment
the reality however is that you're
likely to be using terminal to actually
make the controls and Commands to
control your either Docker swarm or
kubernetes environment and it's great
that it has a GUI and to get you started
but once you're up and running you're
going to be using terminal window for
those fast quick administrative controls
that you need to make so let's look at
the hardware components for kubernetes
so and what's interesting is that
kubernetes is extremely light of all the
systems that we're looking at is
extremely lightweight
um it allows you to have if you compare
it to like a virtual machine which is
very heavy you know kubernetes is
extremely lightweight and other uses any
resources at all interesting enough
though is that if you are looking at the
usage of CPU you it's better to actually
take it for the cluster as a whole
rather than individual nodes because the
nodes will actually combined together to
give you that whole compute power again
this is why kubernetes works really well
in the cloud where you can do that kind
of activity rather than if you're
running in your own data center
um so you can have persistent volumes
and such as a local SSD or you can
actually attach to a cloud data storage
again kubernetes is really designed for
the cloud I would encourage you to use
cloud storage wherever possible rather
than relying on physical storage the
reason being is that if you connect to
cloud storage and you need to flex your
your storage the cloud will do that for
you I mean that's just an inherent part
of why you would have cloud storage
whereas if you're connecting to physical
storage you're always restricted to the
limitations of the physical Hardware so
that's um kind of pivot and look at the
software components as compared to the
hardware components so the main part of
the components is the actual container
and all of the software running in the
container runs on Linux so if you have
documents stored as a developer on your
machine it's actually running inside of
Linux and that's what makes it so
lightweight and really one of the things
that you'll find is that most data
centers and Cloud providers now are
running predominantly on Linux inside of
the um the the container itself is then
managed inside of a pod and a pod is
really just a group of containers
bundles together and the kubernetes
scheduler and proxy server then actually
manage what how the pods are actually
pushed out into your kubernetes
environment the the pods themselves can
actually then share resources both
networking and storage so pods aren't
pushed out manually they're actually
managed through a layer of abstractions
and part of their deployment and and
this is the strength of kubernetes you
use to find your infrastructure and then
kubernetes will then merge if for you
and there isn't that problem of manual
management of PODS if you have to manage
the deployment of them you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
Services is on Ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster and again this is done
security through SSL layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so this dive
now into the actual architecture before
we start looking at a use case of how
kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is we looked at this uh
diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there were really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environments which
controls the scheduling the
communication and the actual commands
that you have created and pushes those
out and manages the health of your
entire node Network and each node has
various pods so we like break this down
so the master node is the most vital
component with the master you have four
key controls you have Etc the controller
manager schedule an API server the
cluster store Etc this actually manages
the details and values that you've
developed on your local workstation and
then we'll work with the out the control
schedule and API server to communicate
that out those instructions on how your
infrastructure should look like to your
entire network the control manager is
really an API server and again this is
all about security so we use restful
apis which can be packaged in SSL to
communicate back and forth across your
pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
at every single layer of abstraction the
communication is secure the schedule as
the name would imply really schedules
when tasks get sent out to the actual
nodes themselves the nodes themselves
are are dumb nodes they just have the
applications
um running on them the master and the
scam is really doing all of the work to
make sure that your entire network is
running efficiently and then you have
the API server which has your rest
commands and the communication and back
and forth across your networks that is
secure and efficient so your node
environment is where all the work that
you do with your containers gets pushed
out too so a work is really a it's a
combination of containers and each
container will then logically run
together on that node so you'd have a
collection of containers on a node that
all make logical sense to have together
uh within each node um you have uh
Docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
you have your cubelet which is a service
for conveying information back and forth
to the service about the actual health
of the kubernetes node itself and then
finally you have the proxy server and
the proxy server is able to manage the
nodes the volumes the the creation of
new containers and actually helps pass
the community the the health of the
container back up to the master to see
whether or not the containers should be
either killed stop started or updated so
finally let's look at see where
kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have greater performance and with
the end goal of being able to Delight
the customer increase value to the
customer and enhance increased value and
revenue into the organization so example
of this is a company called BlackRock
where they actually went through the
process of implementing kubernetes uh so
they could so BlackRock had a chance
where they needed to be able to have
much more Dynamic access to their
resources uh they were running complex
installations on people's desktops and
it was just really really difficult to
be able to manage their entire
infrastructure so they actually went and
pivoted to using kubernetes and this
allowed them to be able to be much more
scalable and expansive in the in the
management of their infrastructure and
as you can imagine kubernetes was then
hooked into their entire existing system
and has really become a key part of the
success that BlackRock is now
experiencing of a very stable
infrastructure and the bond bottom line
is that BlackRock is now able to have
confidence in their infrastructure and
be able to give their confidence as back
to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services
because what it is specific to AWS Cloud
platform what are orchestration tools
the application development and the life
cycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fault tolerance self-healing
capabilities Auto scaling all this as
complicated over the last few years as a
part of devops one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all these
application dependency or lifecycle
management using some or the other of a
tool so that's where these orchestration
tools have become very very popular so
what kind of features that they provide
is you'll have to just let them know
what are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a One-Stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where these orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management Docker swarm and
kubuntis many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with Apache
missiles there are many other container
Management systems but I'm going to pick
Docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two Frameworks for the sake of
comparison I picked up Docker swarm and
kubuntis just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to Containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exists when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for Docker swarm is a cluster management
solution that is provided by Docker
container Docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only Docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only Docker containers
Docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than Docker
and including Docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got Docker in them which I've got rkt in
them which they have got Alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a Docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 Max nodes so in case your
application is totally written in Docker
containers and the load or the expected
cluster size is about 50 60 nodes docus
swarm should be a choice of
orchestration tool on the other hand
kubernetes is something that was open
sourced by Google and and the kind of
the scale of operations that kubernetes
can cater to is Google scale so if in
case your applications are more than a
thousand nodes that is where kubernetes
comes into play that's the big
difference that exists between Docker
swarm and kubernetes putting those
differences aside let me compare Docker
swarm and kubernetes based upon other
features which are similar in nature the
first and important feature that
kubernetes provides is something called
as Auto scaling if at all the load on
your cluster is too high and an
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new VMS or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the Fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the
powerfulness of Auto scaling which is
provided by kubernetes and this
unfortunately does not exist in Docker
swarm the other feature of load
balancing specifically application node
balancing so Docker swarm gives you an
application Level Auto load balancing
however kubernetes gives you the
flexibility of manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for application load balancing
installation as I mentioned earlier
Docker swarm is a loose cluster of
containers which are running on nodes it
is very easy to spin up a new node and
then connect them to a swarm and this
can be done in a very very loose coupled
way where you can and creates forms of
your choice notes are allowed to connect
to swarms and quit or leave the Swarms
on the fly so in and all the
installation is pretty easy and fast
kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes is the way
to spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many Master nodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the Fly based upon the requirement on a
Docker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to kubernetes worker
nodes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave a swarm or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
Loosely coupled architecture for Docker
swarm while kubernetes the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docus warm
runs only Docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and a
lot of other things with each other
because they all have the same signature
they are all from the same family so
it's very easy for them to share not
just volumes but a lot of other things
however for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also when it comes to kubernetes
kubernetes groups containers in
something called as pods while a pod can
have either one container that's a
preferred choice or multiple containers
and the idea of pod is like each pod can
run in any other node it's not
guaranteed that you would want to have
two or three parts to be running on the
same node that makes data sharing a
little bit of a different thing compared
to Dockers form GUI so there's not a
good enough UI tool in Dockers form at
least the CE edition of it which will
allow you to get to know what is running
on your containers what is the size of
the containers what is the volume of the
containers and all that stuff there are
some free and open source tools like
portaner which gives you a good
visibility into your running Docker
containers however there's nothing at a
swarm level that is provided by Docker
kubernetes gives you an out of the box
dashboard which is easy to configure and
set up you can also Club it with some
metrics services and you can also get
information about the size of the
cluster that is running what is the load
on the nodes and stuff like that all
this across your cluster in a very
beautiful dashboard perspective so that
way this is little bit of a good UI for
kubernetes file for Dockers form there
isn't anything that is provided out of
the box let me spend some time in
explaining a little bit about the
kubernetes architecture what comprises
of the kubernetes cluster what resides
in a master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an API server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be one three five
typically an odd number this is as per a
typical cluster management thing where
you would need the master nodes to be in
odd numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to home and stuff like that all the
Masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cuboctl
or the command from using which anybody
can assign some workloads to the cluster
can also be run either on the same node
or on a separate node so Cube CTL is the
command line tool the that we will be
installing and using in order to fire up
our commands to our cluster so if at all
I have to put up a job on our cluster if
I have to give out any specific commands
to my cluster all this is done using
cubic CTL there's a bunch of rest apis
which is used by qbctl and Cube CTL will
talk to the API server and fire up the
commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node Master node
without saying it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running Thruster with only
one master node if your master node goes
down there's no other way that you know
you can or any user can talk to the
different nodes in the cluster so Master
node is the most vital component
responsible for the complete kubernetes
cluster there's always one node that
should be running as a master node
that's a bare minimum requirement for
your cluster so what are the other
components in the master node the most
important one is called etcd so this is
nothing but a data store a value of key
value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
Daemon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of the workloads that
is running based upon the configuration
that the user has set in so if at all if
you are aware of something called as a
replication controllers endpoint
controllers namespace controllers all
these controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what in the cluster and places
the workload on whoever is the available
resource at that time all right APA
server this is one other important
component in in our kubernetes cluster
where how would the end user deploy or
give out any sort of a workload onto
your cluster all the requests come to
the API server so this is an entry point
for all your requests that come into
your cluster anybody wants to deploy
something anybody want to scale up a
controller anybody who wants to bring
down few Services anybody wants to put
in a service all this will have to come
in as a part of a rest API endpoint and
API server is the entry point in case
you don't want uh you know somebody to
access your cluster in case you want
only specific people or specific users
to be running some specific workloads
you can set all those role-based access
control for this APA server so this is
the entry point for anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick overview about the master node
what what are the important components
of a master node now let's go over to
what runs in a worker or a slave node as
I mentioned earlier slave nodes are
something where the job that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run as a pod as a service as a container
so in kubernetes world there's something
called the part a pod is nothing but a
combination of a container it is a
wrapper around your running containers
so slave nodes are the worker nodes
typically run these parts so that is
where the whole workload typically gets
run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
manages what runs in the Pod who has to
have access to the Pod what is the state
of the Pod is it in a running state is
it going down for some reason and all
the stuff so let's quickly go over those
components that is there in the slave
node the most important component in my
opinion that should be on the on the
Node should be the container runtime as
I mentioned earlier kubernetes can run
any different types of containers not
just Docker so in case you want to have
a node which wants to have Docker
running on it rkt running or at LKC
running on it or any other container
environment that is running on it you
have to ensure that the specific
container runtime environment is
available on that specific know so that
whenever a job is submitted a
description of what needs to be run as a
part of the Pod what should be the image
with it should be powered and what kind
of a container to spin up so that's what
you know when the job is finally
assigned to this particular node it
would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cube alert as the name says cubelet or
cube alert is a small subset which talks
to the cube API server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qvpa server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exist in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no Affinity towards
any node on which these ports are
running because pods or containers are
something called as ephemeral they can
run anywhere so how would somebody reach
out to these applications that is
running in some pod which is running in
one container now and running in
probably another container another node
all together tomorrow so that is where
your kubernetes proxy contains a picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these spots and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a DNS server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the pod on which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by acting as a load
balancer and a network proxy now that at
a very high level we know what are all
the components that make up of our
kubernetes cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster we'll spin up
this cluster on AWS platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node probably
you're thinking that is maybe pretty
hard to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
free node kubernetes cluster using a
tool called cops and I will be doing
this whole setup on my AWS Cloud okay so
what is cops cops is nothing but a
simple tool this is an admin tool that
allows you to bring the production grade
kubernetes environments as I said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why I would use something called as a
cops and I will use this on my cluster
which I'll spin up on my AWS instance so
I have an AWS account and what I'll do
first is I will first pin up an ec2
server I will power this with one of the
Linux Amis and I will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where I'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case I'll try to keep
it little small I don't want too many
nodes in my cluster I'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know AWS is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what I
would do is I will create an IAM role
which will attach to my S2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that I am going to specify
all right so once I have my cluster set
up I will also install cubic CTL which
uh you'd probably know by now is nothing
but a command line utility using which I
can kind of connect to my cluster give
out some jobs put some parts and stuff
like that so I will use qbctl I will
also have a pair of SSH keys so that
from this machine I would be able to
successfully get onto the master node
and submit jobs on my behalf so let me
Begin by first logging into my AWS
account all the steps that I will be
following to bring up my AWS cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and I'll be sharing you this document in
a GitHub repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that I would need is to
launch an AWS ec2 instance now this is
an instance where I am going to install
cops and I will use it as a base server
from where I'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
AWS account and let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
um it doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire I would recommend choose free tire
only and choose an Ami of your choice
let me choose this instance I will make
it T2 micro that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
I don't want to change anything here so
that looks good maybe I will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance I'll name this as my
cops server all right I would need a
bunch of ports to be opened up so what I
will do is I'll create a new security
group called open to the word I would
not recommend that you do this since I
don't want to it will take a long time
for me to specify quickly pick and
choose the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster I don't want to do
that I will open up all the HTTP and
https ports so that it's quicker so I
will say all TCP I would save from
anywhere just to be on the safe side
also open HTTP and https and I will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me I will say review on launch
alright so I chose a T2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness I've
opened up all the ports and the instant
details are you've seen what is that
I've chosen all right now important part
is like I would need a keypad I need to
create a new keypad I will call this as
simply learn keys I will download this
key pair and then I will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what I'll do is I will convert I have
this Pim file which is the pair of keys
the SSH keys with which I need to log
into my ec2 instance so I'll need to
convert this because I'm trying to
connect from my Windows box I would need
to convert this into a PPK file so I
have put engine I'm going to load my set
of keys here and convert that key into a
ppk3 all right open all right I would
say save and save privately yes I would
say simply learn or simply learn private
private key and save this here done that
that's all so this is my public key
which is the pem file and this is my PPK
or my private key Now using the private
key I will log into my ec2 instance okay
now my ec2 instance is up and running it
is running in this Ohio region and this
is the IP address of my public IP
address of my machine so let me connect
to it so I use mobile exterm which is
nothing but an SSH emulator you can use
putty or any of these sessions which I
allow you to do on SSH this is my IP
address of my machine and since I've
spun up an Amazon Ami the user this is
the default user I would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session say
okay I am in my Amazon ec2 instance so
let me look at what are the other things
that I need to do all right so as I said
I just brought up my ec2 instance but I
would need my ec2 instance to run few
things on my behalf so that it can spin
up easy to other ec2 instances it can
also talk to an S3 bucket where I'm
going to store the instance date of my
kubernetes cluster also some sort of an
auto scaling group because I want to
spin up more and more instances I also
want to have a private hosted Zone using
my Route 53 so I would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what I
would do is I will go and create a
permission a role in the ec2 or rather
in the AWS IM role and I will attach
this I am role to my ec2 instance all
right so let me go to my IM which is
nothing but the identity and access
management I will create a role called
as possibly cops rule I will create a
role this role will be used by my ec2 so
I'm going to click on ec2 I'll say next
permissions they would need a lot of
permissions uh specific permissions to
be very honest and the permissions are
all listed out here S3 ec2 and all this
stuff just to keep it pretty simple what
I will do is I'll create a role with the
administrative axis all right so I don't
want any tags I'm going to review I'll
create a role name I will say cops fold
for ec2 all right so I'm going to create
a rule which has got administrative
access rules I'm going to create a role
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance from which I am going to run a
my cluster would have all the
prerequisite permission so that it can
go and spin up instances talk to S3
buckets and all that stuff all right now
let us have our running instance get
powered by this roles I will connect
this role to my running instance alright
so this is my ec2 instant that is
running I will say action attach attach
attach attach replace IM roles so there
is no rule as of now I would want my
cops role for easy to zero that I
created so I want this new rule to be
assigned to my ec2 all right great now
my ec2 instance which is my cop server
has got all the required permissions so
that he can create a cluster on my
behalf great now before this let me do a
sudo gem update iPhone y so that any of
the because this is a newly provisioned
VM I just want to ensure that all my
library system libraries are all updated
so that when I do install cop and Cube
CTL and all those things none of them
will fail because of some dependency or
package issues so I'm just running a
sudo update iPhone y so that all the
libraries are updated okay looks like it
is done so let me go ahead and install
all cops cops is a pretty simple
installation it is available in a
particular location I have to just copy
this and ensure that I do a curl and I
install this particular stuff all right
so it is fetching uh the cops tool it's
installing for me once it is copied down
let me change the mode so that I can
execute it and then also let me move it
to my user local bin so that it is
available for me in my path okay that's
pretty much the cops installation let me
also do one other thing let me install
something called as qbctl so this is
what would be you know a tool using
which I'm going to be firing my commands
to my kubernetes cluster once it comes
up okay this is a pretty smaller
executable so keep sitting here all
right so I have Cube CTL as well as cops
installed on my ec2 server now okay now
what I'll do next is I'm going to create
an S3 bucket in AWS so that the
equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name S3
bucket with this name so let me go to S3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name I will just say create a
bucket okay so this is simply run dot
kubernetes is the bucket that I created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
uh go and create a DNS entry or a DNS
zone or a AWS Route 53 hosted zone for
my cluster so this is required so that
you know I can give a cluster name for
my kubernetes cluster that I'm coming up
so I will create a private hosted Zone
and possibility possibly I will call
this as simply learn.in so this will be
my name of my private hosted Zone in
case you already have any other public
hosted zones in your name you can always
put a Route 53 hosted Zone specific for
your domain name since I don't have any
one I'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to Route 53 click on any of these and
you can get these hosted zones out here
so I'm going to create a hosted Zone
here I'm going to create a hosted Zone
click on create hosted Zone
um this would be simply learn.in I want
to create a public no I don't want
public I want a private hosted Zone and
I'm going to associate my VPC ID for
this hosted Zone since I'm going to try
out all my exercises in the Ohio region
I will associate the VPC of the Ohio
region for this all right so this is the
one that is specific to the Ohio region
so I will say this one I'll say create a
hosted so great now let me come back to
my ec2 box my ec2 is all powered with
whatever it needs in order to go out
with the installation of my cluster only
few things that I need to take care of
is that you know now that I put a name
for my cluster I also have an S3 bucket
that I've configured for my cluster I
will have to ensure that I need to put
in these two configurations as a part of
my cluster building activity so I will
open my bash RC file and I'm going to
export these two variables if at all you
remember well these two variables are
nothing but the cluster name which is
nothing but the public or sorry the
private hosted Zone that I created and
the S3 bucket where I'm going to create
or rather I'm going to store my cluster
state so let me copy these two and open
up my bash RC file all right so I will
just add these two and copy these and
Export them out as my variable I'm going
to save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right I've got
these two that have configured and I
also ensure that this environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of SSH keys this is to ensure that
I can log into the box that I'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
SSH iPhone Keygen I don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so I
created a bunch of my keypad now I'm all
set to go ahead and run my cops cops
will ensure that this will take some
time for the cluster to come up but this
is exactly how I would Define my cups
command I already got a copy here so
cops create cluster the state of the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what I have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all I don't specif there's a
configuration for specifying the master
or the control pane as well if I don't
specify that the default one is one so
I'm going to create one primary or the
master node and to worker nodes uh size
of my master Note size of the worker
nodes or what are the zones where I want
this to be created and where do I store
the cluster information and okay I've
already added this must account this is
actually not required but this is the
command that I'm going to fire off so
that I bring up my cluster all right
that went off very fast but this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and
that's why this more very fast now that
everything looks good with whatever
configuration that is specified now let
me go ahead and create the cluster by
saying curbs update cluster hyphen
iPhone here yes now this will take some
time a good five to ten minutes for it
too because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as I
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration I'm going to come up with
one master server and two notes or the
worker nodes all right so this is the
command for me to validate the cluster
and I'm going to try it out first I'm
pretty sure that will fail because all
my servers are not up yet it is taking
some time the validation everything
failed but let me try to look at my ec2
instances and see how many servers do I
have running as of now if you see I had
only one server that had started which
was my cop server and automatically the
other three instances one is called
notes dot simply not in and this these
two are the nodes and this is the master
node so these 3 got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that I
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good five to
ten minutes so what I'll do is I'll
pause the video now and I'll come back
once on the server the cluster is up and
running it's been a good uh eight to
nine minutes uh since I started my
cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so this is a master node uh
minimum One Max one some notes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro uh subnet so my clusters seem
to be up and running and my cluster name
is billon.in so what I would want to do
is now let me just log into the master
and see if I can run some pods so let me
get back to my installation steps here
the variates and cluster is done so let
me log into my since my cluster name is
simply learn.n this is the way to log
into my box so let me get into my box so
if you see here this is the host name
first the machine that I'm currently in
if you see this this is nothing but our
this cop server this is about now from
here I'm trying to get into the master
box all right so if you see the IP
address has changed I was in a different
box I'm in a different box now if I see
host name you'll find a different host
name so this is 153 which is nothing but
the master node yep that's 153 this is
the particular host so I'm getting into
this machine now so I started the
cluster from my cop server here it ran
and brought up three nodes so I'm
actually getting into my master node and
see if I can run some parts on it
alright so let me try Cube CTL get
cluster info right Cube CTL get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
Master node and one master node and two
worker nodes so let me see if I have
some pods here keep this little get pods
so there's no pod as of now so what I'll
try to do is let me just spin up a very
very simple Pawn just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct I have a a simple node.js
application that I have built and I've
got a container for that this is already
pushed to the docker up registered is
called simply run Docker Hub and the
image name that I have here is called my
node app and I will use this image to
power one of my parts that I will run so
this is the way in which I am going to
launch my pod let me show you this
commands Cube CTL run the name for my
deployment that I'm going to run hyphen
iPhone image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my container so
this is simply learn Docker Hub forward
slash my node app hyphen F1 replica is
equal to I want two replicas to be
running and the port that I want to
expose this particular part is on eight
zero eight zero so let me run this as
soon as this is run it creates something
called as a deployment all right now let
me just say I'm not really interested in
the deployment I'm interested in
checking effect all the parts are up and
running so I will say Cube CTL get what
all right so that was pretty fast so I
have two parts that are running here
these are two replicas because as I
asked for two replicas these parts are
running so I can run Cube CTL describe
pod pickup all right I can pick up any
of the Pod name and see what is the Pod
what is the information does it contain
from what is the image that is pulling
what is the image image Name ID this is
actually running my pod which is
actually spinning up a container great
so first of good so in kubernetes the
pods can are ephemeral so they can be
there at any time cannot be at any time
if I need to expose my pod outside I
will have to create a service for my pod
so what I'll do is I'll create a very
very simple service by exposing this
particular deployment before that you
check Cube serial get deployment so
there's a deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so I
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as
um yeah I'll just expose this let me see
all right I'm not specifying what type
and all I don't want to get into the
complications of um what are the
different types of exposing this service
and all that stuff so if I don't specify
find anything it gives me something
project cluster ID so this is where my
pod is actually exposed so let me just
check if at all this part is up and
running I'll just try a simple curl
command R curl HTTP colon this is my
cluster IP and the port is 8080 if at
all I hit this it's actually hitting my
application and giving me uh whatever I
put a simple uh sys dot out kind of a
thing where I'm just printing
um the container ID of whatever pod is
serving uh mix out of so I'm actually
hitting my container and I'm getting
this output from the content so
everything looks good my content is up
and running so let me just go and clean
it up I will say Cube CTL delete
deployment simply learn app this should
get rid of all the parts that I created
Cube CTL get pod all right these parts
are interminating things let me just
check qctl get Services there's one
service I don't want this service let me
delete that keep CTL delete service I
want this all right this sounds good let
me come back to my host my cop server
from where I'm running so I managed to
successfully verify this part see if
everything is up and running so what
I'll do is I'll just go ahead and
complete this demo by going and getting
rid of my cluster so cops delete cluster
hyphen iPhone yes all right so this will
ensure that it will clean up my complete
cluster that I created so I had three or
four running instances if you see them
all the three are shutting down because
you know the cop server which had cops
installed on it uh has now got a mandate
to go ahead and shut down and clean up
the whole instances and all those things
that are created as a part of my
deployment in this video we're going to
cover a common conversation which is
kubernetes versus Docker so let's go
through a couple of scenarios let's do
one for kubernetes and then one for
Docker and we can actually go through
and understand what the problem specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one one
is with Bose and Bose has a large
catalog of products that kept growing
and their infrastructure had to change
so the way that they looked at that was
actually establishing two primary goals
to be able to allow their product groups
to be able to easier more easily catch
up to the scale of their business so
after going through a number of
solutions they ended up coming up with a
solution of having kubernetes running
their iot platform as a service inside
of Amazon's AWS cloud service and what
you'll see with both these products is
they're very Cloud friendly but here we
have um Bose and kubernetes working
together with AWS to be able to scale up
and meet the demands of their product
catalog and so the result is that we
were able to increase the number of
non-production deployments significantly
by taking the number of services from
being large bulky Services down to small
micro Services being able to handle as
many as 1250 plus deployments every year
an incredible amount of time and value
has been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at
Docker and see what a similar problem
that people would have so the problem is
with PayPal and PayPal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and PayPal doesn't just have
PayPal they have Braintree and venmo so
the challenge that PayPal was really
being given is that they had different
architectures which resulted in
different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decade-old architecture with PayPal
through to a modern architecture with
venmo through the use of Docker paper
was able to unified application delivery
and be able to centralize the management
of all of the containers with one
existing group the net net result is
that PayPal was able to migrate over 700
applications into Docker Enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this ultimately opened up a
50 increase in availability for being
able to and add in additional time for
building testing and deploying of
applications just a huge win for PayPal
now let's dig into kubernetes and Docker
and so kubernetes is an open source
platform and it's designed for being
able to maintain a large number of
containers and what you're going to find
is that your argument for kubernetes
versus Docker isn't a real argument it's
kubernetes and Docker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and Docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with Docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to create a
nice consistent experience so that your
developers are working in the same
containers that are then also pushed out
to production so with Docker you're able
to manage multiple containers running on
same Hardware much more efficiently than
you are with a VM environment the
productivity around Docker is extremely
high you're able to keep your
applications very isolated the
configuration for dark here is really
quick and easy you can be up and running
in minutes with Docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so if we look at the
deployment between the two and the
differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of PODS and
services in its deployment whereas with
Docker it's around about deploying
services in containers so the the
difference
um here is that kubernetes is going to
manage the entire environment and then
and that environment consisting of PODS
and inside of a pod you're going to have
all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers that can
control the surfaces that actually power
the applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution it has it turned on and is
always available whereas a Docker does
not and and that's not surprising
because Docker is a tool for building
out Solutions whereas kubernetes is
about managing your infrastructure
kubernetes is going to run health checks
on the liveness and Readiness of your
entire environment so not just one
container but tens of thousands of
containers whereas Docker is going to
limit the health check to the services
that it's managing within its own
containers now I'm not going to kid you
kubernetes is quite hard to set up it's
it's of the tools that you're going to
be using in your devops environment it's
it's not an easy setup for you to use
and and for this reason you want to
really take advantage of the services
within Azure and other similar cloud of
environments where they actually will do
the setup for you Docker in contrast is
really easy to set up you can as I
mentioned earlier you can be up and
running in a few minutes as you would
expect the fault tolerance within
kubernetes is very high and this is by
Design because the architecture of
kubernetes is built on the same
architecture that Google uses for
managing its entire Cloud infrastructure
in contrast Docker has lower fault
tolerance but that's because it's just
managing the the services within its own
containers what you'll find is that most
public Cloud providers will provide
support for both kubernetes and Docker
here we've highlighted Microsoft Azure
because they were very quick to jump on
and support kubernetes but the realities
is that today Google Amazon and many
other providers us having first level
support for kubernetes it's just become
extremely popular in a very very short
time frame the company is using both
kubernetes and Docker is vast and every
single day there are more and more
companies using it and you should be
able to look and see whether or not you
can add your own company to this list
let's go through and you're going to be
asked to explain what the architecture
of Docker is and Docker really is the
most popular containerization
environment so Docker uses a client
server architecture and the docker
client is a service which runs in a
command line and then the docker Daemon
which is run as a rest API within the
command line will accept the requests
and interacts with the operating system
in order to build the docker images and
run the docker containers and then the
docker image is a template of
instructions which is used to create
containers the docker container is an
executable package of applications and
its dependencies together and then
finally the docker registry is a service
to host and distribute Docker images on
among other users so you'll also be
asked to provide what are the advantages
of Docker over a virtual machine and and
this is something that comes up very
consistently in fact and you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a Docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for Docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all Docker does contain an occupy Docker
containers occupy significantly less
space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
Docker is significantly faster than a VM
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single Docker image Docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation Docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your Arguments for Docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for Docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like Docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
Docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is Leverage The Power of
Docker swarm so Douglas warm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
imagine node as you'd assume matches the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed so what are the
commands to create a Docker swarm and so
here we have an example of what a
manager node would look like and once
you've created a swarm on your major
node you can now add working nodes to
that swarm and again when you're
stepping through this process be very
precise in the execution part that needs
to be taken to be able to effectively
create a swan so start with the manager
node and then you create a worker node
and then finally when a node is
initializes a major node it can
immediately create a token and that
token is used for the worker nodes and
associating the IP address with the
worker nodes question 17 how to run
multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers as single service by using
Docker compose and Docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yaml
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a Docker file so a
Docker file actually is used for
creating Docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can I
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things I really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
Whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the Whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show show the flow for
creating a build environment as in
architect this should be something that
you're comfortable doing and by doing it
in the interview and suddenly you want
to ask permission before you actually do
it but doing this in the interview
really helps demonstrate your
comfortable feelings of working with
these kind of architecture drawings so
back to the question of creating a
Docker file so we go through and we have
a Docker file that actually then goes
ahead and creates the docker image which
then in turns creates the docker
container and then we are able to push
that out up to a Docker Hub and then
share that Docker Hub with everybody
else as part of the docker registry with
the whole network so what are the
differences between Docker image and
Docker containers so let's go through
the docker image so the docker images
are templates of a Docker container an
image is built using a Docker file and
it stores that Docker file in a Docker
repository or a Docker Hub and and you
can use Docker Hub as an example and the
image layer is a read-only file system
the docker container is a collection of
the runtime instances of a Docker image
and the containers are created using
Docker images and they are stored in the
docker Daemon and every container is a
layer is a read write file system so you
can't replace the information you can
only append to it so while you can
actually use yaml for writing your so a
question you can be asked is instead of
yaml what can be an alternate file to
build Docker compose so yaml is the one
that is the default but you can also use
Json so if you are comfortable working
with Json and my that is something that
should be get comfortable with is you
want to be able to use that to name your
files and it's a frame reference Json is
a logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a JavaScript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a Docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a MySQL Docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a Docker image or pull
from an existing Docker image from a
Docker repository or Hub and then you
want to be able to then use Docker to
create a new container which has my SQL
from the existing Docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image now below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the command
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have Docker registry
Is An Open Source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing Docker
images whereas in contrast for
repositories a collection of multiple
versions of a Docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between Docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the the registry Docker also
has its own default registry called
Docker hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
Docker images it is stored in a Docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own Enterprise registry so
you're going to be asked you know what
are the cloud platforms that support
Docker really you know lifts them all
and we have listed here Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure Google Cloud
Rackspace but you could add in their IBM
bluemix you could put in Red Hat really
any of the cloud service providers out
there today do support Docker it's just
become an industry standard so what is
the purpose of Expose and publish
commands in Docker so if we go through
expose is an instruction used in Docker
file whereas publish is used in Docker
run command for expose it is used to
expose ports within a Docker Network
whereas with Publishers can be used as
side of a Docker environment for expose
it is a documenting instruction used at
the time of building an image and
running a container whereas with
published is used as to map a host port
to a running container port for expose
is the command used in Docker whereas
for publish we use the command Dash p
for when we're doing our command line
used in Docker and examples of these are
expose 8080 or with Docker we would put
in all for publish we would do the
example Docker run Dash Dash p and then
0.0.0.80 colon 80 as our command line in
this video we're going to take you
through the 13 most common questions
that you are likely to be asked in a
kubernetes interview we're going to
break up the interview questions into
three categories it's going to be
beginner intermediate and advanced the
beginner questions are really going to
cover about three quarters of the
questions that we're going to ask here
and then the intermediate and advanced
will finalize out the official out the
final quarter and and the reason is is
that quite typically most interviews
you'll be asked you know intermediate to
beginner level questions mainly beginner
level questions just so you can
demonstrate your understanding of
kubernetes and then there's always one
Advanced question that gets thrown out
just to make sure that you really do
know what you're talking about and
you've done at least one or two
kubernetes environment setups to be able
to validate your experience so let's
kind of jump into that first section
which is you know why is kubernetes
widely used and your answer to this
really comes into the fact that
kubernetes is widely used because of
three distinct areas one is that
kubernetes is an open source platform
that is readily available for the
management containers and allows you to
manage the deployment scaling and
management of those containers and so
the first area is that it allows you for
easy deployment of your containers the
ability to scale effectively within
kubernetes not just vertically but
horizontally for your containers and
then finally the kubernetes environment
itself was really designed to make it
easy to manage containers
um in small parts other key areas of why
kubernetes is popular is that kubernetes
is the single largest open source
project out there since its launched in
2014 is just grown in Leaps and Bounds
around that project there is just a huge
Community both an online and physical
Community there are just a large number
of online groups that are supporting
kubernetes and allow you to get fast
access to information but in addition to
that there are also a lot of local
meetup groups that cover specifically
kubernetes whether as part of a devops
group or as part of a dedicated
kubernetes group the actual environment
itself is a really robust way of being
able to manage your containers and
containers are becoming the most popular
way of being able to deploy cloud-based
applications could be communities is an
effective and persistent storage
environment so kubernetes is also able
to effectively manage persistent storage
whether it's local storage as a SSD
drive or a local hard drive or whether
it's cloud-based storage and because of
the way that kubernetes architecture
it's really designed for the cloud from
the ground up so it's a great way to get
started in building out your Cloud
Solutions and then finally the actual
tools within kubernetes are designed to
help and manage the health and
monitoring of the environment itself so
what is Google container engine so the
Google container engine is another open
source solution but it's designed for
managing the docker containers and
clusters and so kubernetes is a
container management solution and Docker
is the most popular container solution
out there and this is just a way of
being able to bring the two effectively
with into each other so that you can
have Docker containers manage the
application and then kubernetes managed
the scale of your app applications as
they're vertically and horizontally
scaled across your network so what is
the difference between kubernetes and
Docker and this is important because
kubernetes and Docker are often dropped
in the same sentence and there's a lot
of people that get confused between the
two so fundamentally kubernetes is about
taking pods which contain containers
which have applications in and deploying
them at scale across a cloud Network
Docker is the container solution itself
so the actual application itself is put
into the docker container because of
this difference kubernetes is designed
for auto scaling is highly available
whereas Docker simply isn't because it
doesn't have to worry about that within
the container itself the kubernetes
environment will check for liveness and
Readiness of the health of the entire
infrastructure whereas with Docker it's
just really going to check the services
that are coming in and out of the actual
application itself within the container
kubernetes is complicated to set up it
really is just simply complicated setup
and what you'll find is a lot of cloud
services will actually do the setup for
you whereas Docker is very easy to set
up the as you would expect with the
tolerance ratio there is high fault
tolerance with the kubernetes whereas
with Dockers low-fat tolerance again
this is fundamental in the two different
types of strategy that kubernetes and
Docker have they're both connected
tightly with each other but they both do
different things so what are the notable
features of kubernetes one is the
ability to do container balance
kubernetes always knows where to place a
container within its entire network
within the pods and with its
infrastructure the services are managed
for Security Network and storage it is
self-monitoring so it goes in and is
able to check its own nodes for health
and the containers within the nodes to
make sure that the applications are
always running effectively you can do
the scaling effectively both vertically
and horizontally within kubernetes the
solution is open source so there's no
actual fee for the actual kubernetes
service itself and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does it mean
by storage orchestration now storage
orchestration is that you're able to
access and share either local storage
such as a hard drive or SSD drive or a
cloud-based drive and my preference is
always to go with cloud-based drive
because then you're really positioning
Your solution to be a true cloud-based
application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes well you get
automatic rollback for changes that go
wrong the a you're able to automate a
lot of the processes that would have
been manual processes previously you're
able to scale the resources both
vertically and horizontally easily and
quickly and then these three areas the
rollback automating roll Bank automating
services and being able to scale
indirectly allows you to save money by
reducing the amount of time and people
working on your operations environment
so let's break out the architect picture
of kubernetes so you're going to be
explaining us to explain how is
kubernetes architecture structured and
there are three key areas there's the
application layer there's kubernetes
layer and then there's the
infrastructure layer we're going to
start off with the infrastructure layer
and so the infrastructure layers are
base layer and this is where all your
where you make your clusters for your
collections of storage and networking
resources within kubernetes and this is
where you would have if your databases
are your data stored locally on a hard
drive or in the cloud your core Network
and the VMS that you'll be building out
your infrastructure on these allow you
to group many machines together into a
single unit so that you're able to scale
up and down very easily to meet customer
demand so let's talk about the middle
layer which is the kubernetes layer now
so if we're looking at our architecture
for a kubernetes layers really broken
down for the the core operating system
the docker container environment and the
kubernetes T's code itself and this is
where you're able to take machines and
pull them together as a cluster so that
they work within that kubernetes system
you have a master controller within the
kubernetes that actually then we'll go
ahead and manage the scheduler the
control manager the API server and then
you'll be able to Cluster all of these
kubernetes together so that they're all
working and processing as one single
unit and then finally let's look at the
application layer where you actually
have your apps and so the application
layer where you have your pool and your
services you know kubernetes will use
API to connect in and out of this layer
it's to run your applications within
containers and you use instructions that
are written in yaml or Json to actually
set up those containers and you actually
have the environment running on a plan
that examines these instructions so it
keeps the entire environment healthy API
ecosystem is used to interact with the
cluster it's so you don't have to to do
that by yourself so make sure that
you're referencing that the apis are
secured and connecting in and out of the
system and so you have your scheduling
control manager actually from the
kubernetes environment doing the hard
work and then the workers themselves
execute the the commands that coming
from kubernetes so you will be asked to
kind of dig into some of the key areas
such as explaining the master node and
listing its components so the master
note is comprised of four key components
there's the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the API server
so four key components remember four
fingers four components and then you're
going to be asked to maybe dig deeper
into what is a cluster within kubernetes
and so a customer is really a
combination of resources such as
machines that into a single node and
then those nodes are pulled together and
work as a single cluster as a whole
kubernetes will work with that whole
whole cluster and then once you're
actually working with that whole cluster
if a node fails or needs to be removed
kubernetes is able to do that quickly
and effectively so let's talk a little
bit about what are the different types
of controllers in kubernetes and there
are five types of control manager you
have the node controller the service
account the token controller the
endpoint controller and the replication
controller and so the no controller
controls and handles the node in the
system the service account enables
access controls in the system the token
controller cleans up any tokens for
non-existent service accounts the
endpoint controller joins services in
pods to the endpoint objects and the
replication controller manages the Pod
life cycle so what is the role of the
cloud controller manager within this
environment and so the role the cloud
control manager is really to help manage
persistent storage and so persistent
storage is storage that's either local
storage to the physical machine such as
an SSD or hard drive or cloud-based
storage and this allows the storage to
be shed across the entire network what
is the role of the cube API server and
the cube scheduler so the cube API
server responsible for the establishment
communication between the kubernetes
nodes and the master components and and
it does this through the through apis
the apis themselves are all commands
that are rest based commands and it
implements an interface which means
different tools and libraries can
communicate effectively with each other
so what is the role of the cube API
server and the cube scheduler so the
cube schedule actually does the
distribution of work across the entire
infrastructure so the actual yaml script
that you've written are executed
appropriately at the right time so
you're going to be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume is just a place where
you can store data again this can be
local data as in a hard drive local to
the physical machine or it can be
cloud-based data so what is a cubelet
and a cube proxy so a cubelet is a
service responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
itself the process and the Q proxy
itself is responsible for maintaining
the work and the standards within the
node server in addition every node in
the cluster runs a simple Network proxy
and Q proxy routes requests to the
correct container in that node in
addition you'll have some basic and
primitive load balancing and management
of the node from the proxy itself and
there's additional layers of management
that get done outside of the proxy but
the proxy is also there to help do some
localized load management so what is
Cube CTL so Cube CTL is your command
line or terminal window interface that
allows you to execute commands and later
in this video we'll actually go through
some of those commands
etcd is the store that configures the
details and essential values such as key
value pairs that are distributed across
your entire network it also manages the
network rules and the post-forwarding of
activity so what are the disadvantages
of kubernetes well the first is it's
really hard to install and configure and
this is why Azure and many cloud
services such as Google Cloud will
actually do the installation and
configuration of kubernetes for you it
does take a long time to get up and
running with kubernetes not so much for
the actual software but your own
experience of being able to use
kubernetes it is not simple to manage
the service you actually have to have a
lot of experience and this is why people
get paid a lot for kubernetes skills
it's a difficult environment to get up
and running and be effective in that
management again kubernetes is just not
an easy platform to learn it takes a lot
of time and effort and one of the
disadvantages is that while kubernetes
itself is free because it is an open
source project getting the people who
are skilled you to using kubernetes is
expensive all right so those were kind
of the introductory questions that you
can expect to be asked in your interview
the next set of questions are really
going to be on an intermediate and
advanced level and these are the
questions that will be thrown out you
know you can see these as being the the
trick questions which are really there
to test that you have the skill set to
be able to implement and manage
kubernetes within a company so what
happens if a master node fails what
happens if a worker nerve fails how
would kubernetes manage that well
kubernetes is really designed for this
kind of scenario and so you can actually
look at it and the response would be is
that the Pod itself does not get
affected and kubernetes will actually
respond and fix the uh the failed node
whether it is needs to be repaired but
there needs to be restarted or needs to
be replaced so what is a service role in
kubernetes so a service role is an
extraction for all of the pods it
provides a virtual IEP address and it
allows client lines to connect two
containers running in the pods using
that virtual IP address and the command
that you would use to get that would use
some of these Cube CTL commands it's
quite a simple one it's Cube CTL get
services and you get a full list then of
all the services that are available so
how do I do a rollback in deployment and
so there's a couple of ways you can do
the rollback and the first is if you
want to see the rollout history
deployment you would write Cube CTL
rollout history deployment and then in
square brackets deployment if you want
to just restore to the previous rollout
the command would be Cube CTL rollout
undo deployment and then in square
brackets deployment and that would take
you back to the previous deployment so
what is an Ingress controller so an
English controller it really is a pod
that manages that inbound traffic and
The prominent feature that traffic is
that it is secured with an SSL
termination and so what we're going to
do to now address some of the key ways
in which you can provide API Securities
on kubernetes and we have eight of those
so the first four are implementing TL
TLS for your security the second would
be API authentication the third is to
make the kubus protection the cubeless
protected via authorization mode equals
webhook command the fourth is to monitor
rbac failures the fifth is to remove
those default service account
permissions six would be to filter
egress to Cloud API metadata apis the
seventh is to use pod security policy to
restrict container policies and protect
the node and the eighth and final is to
keep the cube at the latest version all
right let's go into some of the more
advanced commands and so the advanced
questions you're going to get are all
going to be commands that you're going
to be asked to write now my advice for
you um for these questions is to make
sure that you have some of these basic
commands memorized they don't have to be
perfect when you're in the interview
environment but it's good to be able to
get up to a whiteboard and actually
write out what these commands are just
so you can actually demonstrate that you
know what the commands are the
interviewer isn't going to ask you
questions on how would you apply
kubernetes to the company that you're
being hired for because you simply don't
have that knowledge but they do want to
be able to see clearly that you
understand the commands and terminal
window instructions that will be able to
demonstrate how you would actually go in
and access some of that information so
from the first questions you might be
asked is how do you package kubernetes
applications and so you would use the
package manager within kubernetes to be
able to manage to and configure and
deploy applications into your cluster
and so here we have the the helm command
that you would use so what are in it
containers and any container gets
executed before any other containers can
run on the Pod and so you want to be
able to illustrate what the init
instructions would look like and here we
have an example and I would again use
this example and maybe memorize it for
when you have this question come up in
your interview so what is the difference
between a config map and a secret and
these are more uh fundamentals so a
config map just has the instructions
that are clearly available in plain text
on what the cube is supposed to do
whereas the secrets are actually
encrypted and these are like passwords
and other sensitive data that you don't
want to have um easily available these
are encrypted information that have to
be decrypted to access the content so if
a node is Tainted is there a way to
schedule the pods to that node and the
answer is no there isn't and so what you
have to do then is schedule the Pod to
be fixed so that schedule the Pod to fix
the tainted node to allow for
tolerations to that and we have here the
example code that you would use to do
that so how do you deploy a feature with
zero downtime in kubernetes well
kubernetes is designed to be able to
roll out
um applications with zero downtime and
here we have four examples using the
rolling update as a strategy for zero
downtime deployments and kubernetes
again memorize one of these so you can
actually illustrate how you use rollout
to be able to deploy a zero downtime
solution so how do you monitor a pod
that is always running and so to do that
you would use the liveness probe to
check the health of the application
within the Pod and see whether or not
there are any failures or whether or not
the Pod itself needs to be restarted so
how do you drain traffic from pod during
a maintenance so again
um this is a simple command for you to
remember but to be able to drain an
application so that it's easy for you to
be able to do maintenance on the
application you would use the cube CTL
drain and then in square brackets the
node name and that would then
temporarily drain uh that particular
Parts you can actually do maintenance on
it what you have to then and this would
probably give you bonus points with your
in an interview is then a reference the
uncordant command so that you can
uncoordinate the actual node itself so
that the Pod itself can come back up
into live um and work as a fully
functioning solution so to be able to
tie services to a partner to a set of
PODS is that you can apply labels to the
actual Parts themselves and then use the
labels as selectors to be able to glue
services to that pod and again we have
here an example of how you'd actually do
that and again this is one of those
where you can probably won't be asked to
write this out but it'd be good to have
this memorized how do you get all pods
on a node and so the following command
one will actually go ahead and bring all
the pods into a kubernetes cluster this
is quite lengthy and you know maybe you
want to like talk to how this would be
done but we have the instructions on how
to do that right here the important part
is to make sure that you are when you're
talking about the node name that you
reference to whoever you're interviewing
that you would what you would switch out
to reference the actual nodes that
you're trying to pull together into the
kubernetes cluster so how do pods Mount
NFS volumes and so in these examples
here we actually Define the NFS server
and then the Pod and how you'd actually
Mount two together and again what you
want to be able to do is illustrate why
you would use yaml and how you'd
actually then point to specific IP
addresses within your kubernetes
environment within either the production
or test environments to be able to
illustrate how you would Mount up those
NFS volumes and with that we have
reached the end of day two so far we
have learned the Dockers and communities
on day three of devops learning week we
will reveal the next stage where you
will Master the devops testing so stay
tuned and don't mess it up thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
stay tuned for more from Simply learn